ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM. THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL
AGUIAR-CURRY. ARAMBULA OUR QUE
HAN. BENNETT BERMAN BIGELOW
BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH BURKE
CALDERON CARRILLO CERVANTES
CHAU CHEN CHIU CHOI COOLEY
COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY DAILY
DAVIES FLORA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA.
KILEY LACKEY LEAD LEVINE LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI THIS AREA QUINN
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS CORK CORK SILVA
RAMOS RAY IS LOOSE REBAJAS
ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO
SALAS SANTIAGO SANTIAGO C. R.
TO SMITH STONE TEAM CALAVERAS
VIA FOOD WELL VOEPEL WALDRON
WARD WEBER. WICKS WOOD MISTER
SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS
PRESENT. A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN
THE ASSEMBLY.
YES OUR GUESTS
AND VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER. WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN IMAM
YASIR KHAN IMAM YASIR. IN THE
NAME OF GOD. THE MOST GRACIOUS
THE MOST MERCIFUL. OH GOD. WE
THANK YOU FOR ANOTHER DAY TO
WORK FOR. AND TO BE HERE WITH
OUR COLLEAGUES ON THIS FLOOR.
WE PRAY THAT YOU MAY BE WITH US
TODAY TO DEFEND US. WITHIN US
THE YOU MAY SUSTAIN US BEFORE
US BUT YOU MAY LEAD US. BEHIND
US THAT YOU MAY PROTECT US
ABOVE US. THAT YOU MAY BLESS US
AND EVERYTHING THAT WE DO. I
MEAN. THANK YOU MA YES SIR YES
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE MISTER
LACK. PLEASE JOIN ME READY
BEGIN. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE.
STATE. WHICH IT STANDS ONE
NATION. YEAH MEMBERS IF I GET
HAVE YOUR TO PLEASE. JUST
YESTERDAY NINE INNOCENT LIVES
WERE LOST IN ANOTHER MASS
SHOOTING TRAGEDY THIS TIME IN
SAN JOSE. PLEASE RISE FOR A
MOMENT OF SILENCE TO HONOR THE
VICTIMS OF THIS SENSELESS ACT.
THANK YOU MEMBERS. READING OF
THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL.
ASSEMBLY SHIMMER SACRAMENTO
THURSDAY APRIL TWENTY SECOND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE SUBMITTED
NINETY THE HONORABLE REPORT
ABOUT QUE HAN ASSISTANCE
RECORDED FOR YOU BE SIMPLY
PRESIDING CHIEF FOR C. PARKER
DE FOR DAY BOWMAN. THE RULES
CALL ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK
MCCORMACK THE SIM MOTION TIME A
FIVE A THIS IS SPEAKER TEM TO
ASSAULT AT ARMS DOORS THE APPS
MEMBERS AT NINE AM MOVE. MR
LACKEY SO. THE READING OF THE-
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATION SEVENTY THERE ARE.
ENTRY AND REFERENCE OF BILLS
WILL BE DEFERRED REPORTS OF
WILL BE READ AND D. A- MESSAGE
FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE ARE
NONE THIS FROM THE- THERE ARE
NONE. MOTIONS AND THERE ARE NO
ABSENCES TODAY. NOW WE ARE
MOVING TO PROCEDURAL MOTIONS
MISS REYES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTIONS
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER. I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY
FIVE POINT FIVE. TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CUNNINGHAM TO
SPEAK ON A GERMAN AND MEMORY
TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY SIX TO
WITHDRAW AB SEVENTY FIVE
O'DONNELL FROM THE RULES
COMMITTEE IN ORDER THE BILL TO
THE SECOND READING FILE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. AT THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHOR'S PLEASE MOVE THE
FOLLOWING BILLS TO THE INACTIVE
FILE. ITEM FOR TWENTY SEVEN AB
TEN NINETY ONE BERMAN. ITEM ONE
SIXTY TWO EIGHTY SIX SEVEN ONE
WORD. THE CLERK WILL NOTE.
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
SEVENTY EIGHT THE AUTHORS ARE
GIVING A ONE DAY NOTICE TO
REMOVE THE FOLLOWING BILLS FROM
THE INACTIVE FILE ITEM AB ONE
AB SEVEN TWENTY THREE LOW ITEM
EIGHT TO EIGHTY SIX NINETY
ARAMBULA. AGAIN THE CLERK WILL
NOT. AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR'S PLEASE REMOVE THE
FOLLOWING BILLS FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ITEM. FOR
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY NINE SEVEN
FIVE THREE OF US ITEM FOR
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY SIX THIRTY
ONE BLOOM ITEM FOR THIRTY THREE
AB ELEVEN FIFTY FIVE SALAS AND
ITEM FOR THIRTY NINE AB TWELVE
NINETY EIGHT BLOOM. AGAIN CLERK
WILL NOTE. MISTER SPEAKER THERE
IS A LIST OF BILLS WITH PENDING
BEFORE AMENDMENTS AT THE DESK
THE BOTH SIDES HAVE AGREED TO
ADOPT WITH A SINGLE VOICE VOTE
I ASK THAT THE READING CLERK
READ THE LIST OF BILLS WITH
AMENDMENTS AND THAT WOULD THEN
ADOPT THEM. BY UNANIMOUS
CONSENT. CORKERY ITEM FOURTEEN
A SYMBOL SIX SEVENTY NINE
FRIEDMAN ITEM SIXTEEN ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTEEN FIFTY THREE OF US
ITEM FORTY ASSEMBLY BILL TEN
FORTY THREE THREE OF US. ITEM
FORTY SIX ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN COURT ITEM ONE
TWENTY THREE ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
SEVENTY FOUR CHAU. ITEM ONE
EIGHTY EIGHT ASSEMBLY GO EIGHT
NINETY SIX BENNETT ITEM TWO OH
NINE ASSEMBLY BILL TEN TWENTY
FRIEDMAN. ITEM TO THIRTY ONE
ASSEMBLY WILL ELEVEN THIRTY TWO
WOULD ITEM TWO FIFTY ONE
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE SEVENTY
SIX CARILLO. ITEM TO NINETY
THREE ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN
SEVENTY ONE ARAMBULA I AM THREE
HUNDRED ASSEMBLY BILL FORTY
FIVE AGUIAR-CURRY. ITEM THREE
FIFTY EIGHT ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN
NINETY FOUR CARILLO AND ITEM
THREE SEVENTY ONE ASSEMBLY BILL
NINE FORTY ONE BENNETT. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. I MOVED TO. THE RULE SIX
NINE. TO ALLOW THE AUTHORS TO
TAKE UP LATE AMEND ON THE
FOLLOWING BILLS. ITEM ONE
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY FOUR FORTY SIX
MAYES. ITEM TO NINETY SIX AB
TWENTY SIX HOLDEN. ARDIAN THREE
THIRTY FOUR AB FIVE TWELVE
HOLDEN. ITEM. THREE SEVENTY
FOUR EIGHTY NINE FOUR EIGHT
HOLDEN AND ITEM THREE SEVEN
FIVE. EIGHTY NINE FIFTY EIGHT
WARD. MR FLOOR FOR A PURPOSE
ARE YOU MISTER SPEAKER WITH
HOLDEN ELSE CONSENT AS FOR ROLL
CALL VOTE MR FLOOR AS
WITHHOLDING MISERY S. MOVES
MISTER GIBSON. THIS IS A RULES
SUSPENSION PROCEDURAL VOTE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROOM. IS
REYES IS ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE
MISTER FLORES ASKING FOR NO.
THIS IS A PERSON VOTE MEMBERS.
YEAH THIS IS PROCEDURAL THIS
RACE IS ASKING FOR AN AYE MR
FLORA'S ASKING FOR A NO. CLERK
WILL. CLOSE ROLE AS FORTY FIVE
MINUTES THIRTEEN RULES ARE
SUSPENDED.
MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY
FILE. THERE WAS RUMORED TO
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING.
STARTING AT THE TOP OF THE FILE
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO.
SB SIX SIX NINE BY MR LACKEY.
CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
SIXTY NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LACKEY AN ACT RELATING TO
FIREARMS. MR LACKEY EMAIL BUT-
WELL THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS THE TWENTY SIXTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE AUTHORIZED COUNTY
PROBATION DEPARTMENT OFFICERS
TO PURCHASE AND UTILIZE NON
ROSTER FIREARMS. LAST YEAR THE
LEGISLATURE AT A REQUIREMENT
FOR COMPLETION OF THE POST
BASIC COURSE BEFORE ALLOWING
COUNTY PROBATION DEPARTMENT
OFFICERS TO PURCHASE AND USE
NON ROSTER FIREARMS WHICH
INADVERTENTLY AFFECTED
PROBATION OFFICERS WHO ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO COMPLETE THE POST
BASIC COURSE AS A CONDITION OF
THEIR HIGHER CONTINUED
EMPLOYMENT. THE CLARIFICATION
ON THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW COUNTY
PROBATION DEPARTMENTS TO
CONTINUE. TO USE NON ROSTER
FIREARMS UPON SUCCESSFUL
COMPLETION OF TE FIREARMS
PORTION OF THE COMMISSION ON
PEACE OFFICERS STANDARDS AND
TRAINING AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND I VOTE.
THANK YOU MR LACKEY. SEEING NO
DISCUSS OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL THE ROLL. ALL MEMBER
VOTE IT IS TO VOTE. ONE ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRED VOTE.
THE NEW.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE
ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FORTY EIGHT
KNOWS ELEVEN. THAT MEASURE
PASSES. FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE
AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN BY MR
GABRIEL CORPORATION ASSEMBLY
BILL FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CABLE AND
OTHERS AN ACT RELATING TO LEGAL
ASSISTANCE MR GABRIEL YOU MAY
OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I'M PLEASED TODAY TO PRESENT AB
FOURTEEN ABBY'S EIGHTY SEVEN
WILL WILL STOP A STATE WIDE
LEGAL DEFENSE AND EDUCATION
FUND. KNOWN AS THE HOMELESSNESS
PREVENTION FUND TO PROTECT OUR
MOST VULNERABLE RENTERS AND
HELP PREVENT HOMELESSNESS
BEFORE IT BEGINS. IN CALIFORNIA
WE HAVE SPENT A LOT OF TIME AND
MONEY AND RESOURCES FOCUSED ON
HOW TO HELP THOSE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. BUT FAR LESS ON
HOMELESSNESS PREVENTION HOW WE
CAN STOP IT FROM HAPPENING IN
THE FIRST INSTANCE. EVICTIONS
PLAY A KEY ROLE IN DRIVING
HOMELESSNESS AND RIGHT TO
COUNSEL PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN
PROVEN TO PREVENT HOMELESSNESS
AND SAVE TAXPAYER RESOURCES.
THIS BILL SUPPORTED BY A BROAD
COALITION OF SEVERAL DOZEN
NONPROFIT COMMUNITY AND FAITH
BASED ORGANIZATIONS AND HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST- I
VOTE ON A. B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN. NAME IS GABRIEL MISTER
DAVE CHIU WERE. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER COLLEAGUES RISE
AS A JOINT ON. TO SUPPORT
EIGHTY FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN A
CRITICAL BILL TO ENSURE THAT
VULNERABLE TENANTS ARE
SUPPORTED WITH LEGAL COUNSEL.
THIS BILL BUILDS ON LOCAL
APPROACHES THAT HAVE BEEN
PROVEN TO SAVE TAXPAYER
RESOURCES. AND IMPROVE THE
FAIRNESS AND EFFICIENCY OF OUR
JUDICIAL SYSTEM. WHEN IT COMES
TO EVICTIONS ONLY 3% OF TENANTS
HAVE LEGAL REPRESENTATION. WELL
OVER 81% OF LANDLORDS HAVE
REPRESENTATION. WELL I SERVED
AS PRESIDENT OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
I WAS PROUD TO BE THE FIRST
CHAMPION. FOR PILOT PROGRAMS OF
FUNDING FOR ADDICTION DEFENSE
AND WE'VE SEEN HOW LIFE
CHANGING THOSE PROGRAMS CAN BE.
THIS BILL WOULD LEVEL THE
PLAYING FIELD AND ENSURE THAT
OUR JUDICIAL SYSTEM INSURANCE
REPRESENTATION FOR ALL. AND
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
MY VOTE. THANK YOU SHOWN. SAY
NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION. ON
THE ITEM. CARCLUB THE ROLE
MEMBERS A VOTE. ALL MY VOTERS
OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. CLARK WELL.
CULTURAL CHAT ABOUT ICE FORTY
SEVEN KNOWS TWELVE. THE MEASURE
PASSES THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOUR AB TWO EIGHTY TWO BY MR
LACKEY CORKERY. SOME PEOPLE TO
READY TO BUY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LACKING AN ACT LEADING TO
MISDEMEANOR DIVERSION MR LACKEY
MAKE IT OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS LAST YEAR THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED A MEASURE
THAT WOULD MAKE ALL MISDEMEANOR
CRIMES ELIGIBLE FOR DIVERSION.
WITH LIMITED EXCLUSIONS SUCH AS
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. AS THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED THIS BILL INTO
LAW HE OUTLINED AND ASSIGNING
MESSAGE THAT HE WOULD LIKE THE
LEGISLATURE TO REVISIT THIS
PROPOSAL. AND ALSO EXCLUDE
DELIGHTS FROM ELIGIBILITY FOR
DIVERSION. THIS BILL DOES JUST
THAT AND THAT'S WAS THE
GOVERNOR'S CALL TO EXCLUDE THE
ALLIES FROM ELIGIBILITY FOR
MISDEMEANOR DIVERSION I ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. FAMOUS LACKING
SENIOR DISCUSSION OF EIGHT ON
THIS ITEM. LIKE LIBERAL. DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS AT
ABOUT. YEAH. YEAH ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS THAT A VOTE. WELL CLOSE
ROLE TYLER I FORTY DOES NOT.
THE MEASURE PASSES. PASS A
RETAINER FILE ITEM FIVE SIX
SEVEN THIS IS FOR ITEM NUMBER.
EIGHT AB TEN THIRD FOUR BLUE
SACRAMENTO ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
THIRTY FOR BY REMEMBER BLOOM
AND I IN THE CAMPUS MISTER.
THIS IS MEMBERS AB TWO THIRTY
CLARA EGGS LAW THAT ALREADY
ALLOWS LOCAL G. TO PERMIT
CANNABIS CAN LOUNGE. IF THEY
WISH. CURRENTLY OF A CANNABIS
WHICH TO PER FOOD CUSTOMERS IT
MUST BE DELIVER IN FROM A NAY
BILL. WHICH IS VERY IN A AND
DOES NOT MEET OTHER HOSPITALITY.
AB TEN THIRTY FOUR WOULD ALLOW
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS THAT CHOOSE
TO DO SO TO PERMIT THE SALE AND
PREPARATION OF NON CANNABIS
FOOD AND BEVERAGES NON
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES. IN
CANNABIS CONSUMPTION LOUNGES.
THIS WOULD BE A LOCAL DECISION
AND NO CITY WOULD BE REQUIRED
TO PERMIT IT THE FOOD AND
BEVERAGES PREPARED AND SOLD ON
SITE WOULD NOT BE INFUSED WITH
CANNABIS AND THE BEVERAGES
WOULD BE NON ALCOHOLIC. THE
BILL SIMPLY ALLOWS A LOCAL
JURISDICTION TO ALLOW CANNABIS
CONSUMPTION LOUNGES TO ALSO
PREPARE AND SELL NON CANNABIS
FOOD AND BEVERAGES ON SITE TO
THEIR CUSTOMERS IF THEY WISH. I
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF AB TEN
THIRTY FOUR. THANK YOU AS WELL.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION ON THE
ITEM CARPOOL OVER THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS OF. THE DESERVE A ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE. ALL
MEMBERS.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL
TIDE OF EYES FORTY ONE. NO
THREE. THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM NUMBER NINE IS AB EIGHT
FORTY SIX BY MR LOW. THE CLERK
WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
FORTY SIX ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOGAN
ACT LEADING UP CONTRA THE
SHALLOW EMAIL OPEN THANK YOU
VERY MR CALL THIS IS THIS BILL
A FORTY SO ON WEARING OVER I
RIVAL. THAT'S HEADED IT THANK
YOU MITCHELL. SENIOR DISCUSSION
OF. CLICK LIBERAL. IT IS OUT OF
IT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF. IT IS
ADDED UP CLERK WILL. CLOTHES
ARE ALL TIED UP AT I. FORTY
FIVE NORTH TWELVE. THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEMS TEN THROUGH
THIRTEEN PASS AND RETAIN. THIS
IS FILE ITEM.
MEMBERS WE HAVE
THE SPECIFIED OF FOURTEEN PASS
RETAIN A PILOT OF FIFTEEN WE'VE
DISPENSED WITH FILE ITEM
SIXTEEN PASS RETAIN ON.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
WE'RE FILE ITEM TWENTY THREE AB
EIGHT AB THREE FIFTY EIGHT
CORKERY. ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
FIFTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FLOOR ANAK LEVINE LECTURE ELECT
SECURITY. MISS FLORES YOU MAIL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THREE
IT WOULD HAVE WHAT I AND FENCE
SYSTEM IS GIVING ITS INTERNAL
COMPONENTS IN HOUSE THE AND
WHERE THEY SHOULD BE INSTALLED
I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MISS FLOOR C. NOTICE. OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM. CLICK
LIBERAL. HOME OF. IT IS TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE PHONE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF. THE
CLERK WELL. THOSE ARE ALL TO UP
AND I SIXTY TWO KNOWS. THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILA TWENTY.
THROUGH TWENTY EIGHT PASS
RETAIN FILE ITEM TWENTY NINE IS
AB THIRTY SIXTY SEVEN CORPORATE
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN SIXTIES
BY SOME LOGIN I LEADING TO
POLITICAL ACT OF NINETEEN FOUR
MR LOW YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR VIGOR CALL THIS
IS SOMETHING BILL SIXTY FOUR
AND SPACE I RIVAL. THANK YOU
MISS LOW. SO NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM WITH ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS AT ABOUT.
THIS TAKES. FOUR ALL MEMBERS
REPRESENTATIVE OF HARTWELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I. SIXTY
THREE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES PASS AND RETAIN A
PROBLEMS THREE TWO THIS IS FILE
I'M THIRTY THREE A. B. THREE
THIRTY EIGHT BY MISTER RAMOS
CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
THIRTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAMOS AND OTHERS AN ACT
RELATING TO THE STATE CAPITOL.
MISTER ROSS THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I HAVE BEFORE
YOU TODAY ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
THREE EIGHT A MEASURE TO BRING
FORWARD THE VOICE OF
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST PEOPLE ON
THE ISSUE OF MISTREATMENT AND
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT OF A HORDE PASS
OF THIS STATE'S HISTORY. ONE
THAT TRUSTEES IN GENOCIDE TO
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST PEOPLE. VERY
LITTLE OF THE CALIFORNIA NATIVE
AMERICAN SLAVERY DURING THE
MISSION PERIOD IS CAPTURED IN
OUR HISTORY BOOKS SPANISH
MISSIONARIES AND THE MILITARY
SUB DUDE AND ENSLAVE CALIFORNIA
NATIVE AMERICANS TO FORCED
LABOR AND DISPLACED FAMILY
MEMBERS IN THEIR QUEST TO
COLONIZE THE ALREADY INHABITED
CALIFORNIA. A MENTALITY THAT
CARRIED FORWARD TO THE STATE'S
EARLIEST LEADERS WITH THE FIRST
GOVERNOR SITTING PAID BOUNTIES
TO FORM MILITIAS AIDED BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WHO EMBARKED
ON A DELIBERATE POLICY OF
GENOCIDE AS DEFINED BY POST
HOLOCAUST HUMAN RIGHTS
TRIGGERING TRIBUNALS. ONE PARA
SET UP SERVES AS A CONSTANT
REMINDER OF THAT ERA OF VIEWING
CALIFORNIA INDIANS AS LESS THAN
HUMAN. SOME ARGUE THAT TODAY'S
VALUES SHOULD NOT JUDGE SARAH
YET AS EARLY AS FIFTEEN THIRTY
SPANISH KING CARLOS SAID I
FORBADE SLAVERY DUE TO
MISTREATMENT OF INDIANS AND IN
FIFTEEN THIRTY SEVEN POPE PAUL
THE THIRD ISSUE AN ETIQUETTE
TRYING TO AND MASSACRES AND
SLAVE MEANT OF INDIAN PEOPLE.
FRENCH NAVY CAPTAIN WHAT JEAN
PRACTICE TO GOLUB A AND-
MONTEREY THE STATE. NOW KNOWN
IN SEVENTEEN EIGHTY SIX WAS
APPALLED BY THE MISSIONARIES
ABUSE OF NATIVE AMERICANS
WRITING BAD CORPORAL PUNISHMENT
IS INEFFECTIVE ON THE INDIANS
OF BOTH SEXES WHO NEGLECT THE
EXCISE OF PITY AND MANY SINS
WHERE IN EUROPE ARE LEFT TO
DIVINE JUSTICE. CITIES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY AND EVEN SOME
CATHOLIC INSTITUTIONS HAVE
REMOVED TRUCK TRIBUTES TO
SARAH. AND IN. TWENTY FIFTEEN
MISTER SPEAKER. POPE FRANCIS
APOLOGIZE FOR THE MANY SAID
FROM AGAINST THE NATIVE PEOPLES
OF AMERICA AND ASK FOR
FORGIVENESS YES FOR FIFTY YEARS
HIS STATUE HAS STOOD IN THE
CAPITOL GROUNDS AS A CONSTANT
REMINDER TO THE NATIVE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA. OF THE
ATROCITIES COMMITTED AGAINST
THEM AND THE HORRID TREATMENT
INFLICTED UPON THEM DURING THE
SO CALLED COLONIZATION PERIOD.
THIS BILL WILL PAVE THE WAY FOR
THE VOICES OF THOSE WHO WERE
OPPRESSED ENSLAVED AND FORCED
INTO LABOR TO BUILD THOSE
MISSIONS TO ONCE AND FOR ALL TO
HAVE A VOICE A VOICE THAT WILL
TELL A FACTUAL ACCOUNT OF
HISTORY. THAT HAS NOT BEEN SAID
AT THE LEVEL THAT WOULD GIVE A
BALANCED APPROACH TO THE PAST
IT HAS BEEN ONE SIDED FOR YEARS
NOW IS THAT TIME FOR THE VOICE
TO BE HEARD THROUGH THIS
LEGISLATURE THIS BILL WILL
BRING IN A NEW ERA.
CALIFORNIA'S ELECTED OFFICIALS
TAKE ACTION TO CORRECT THE
WRONGS OF THE PAST AND
RECOGNIZE THE IMMENSE
CONTRIBUTIONS THE CALIFORNIA
NATIVE AMERICANS HAVE MADE TO
THIS GREAT STATE. M. THE
AMOUNTS COST AT WHICH SHOWS
CONTRIBUTIONS CAME. AB THREE
THREE EIGHT WILL AUTHORIZE THE
CONSTRUCTION OF A LONG OVERDUE
MONUMENT TO THE TRIBES WHO
CONTINUE TO CALL THIS PLACE
HOME IT WILL BRING A LONG OVER
DUE. PROCESS TO THE
MEMORIZATION OF A MAN WHO SET
FORTH THE MENTALITY OF TREATING
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST PEOPLE AS
LESS THAN HUMAN BY D.
AUTHORIZING THE CONTINUED
PRESENCE OF THE SIERRA STATUE
IN THE CAPITOL I ASK. FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. THE MISS ROSS MISTER
MATHIS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE AS A PROUD.
JOINT AUTHOR ON THIS BILL. THE
IMPORTANCE OF GIVING BACK TO
OUR NATIVE AMERICAN HISTORY.
CANNOT BE EXPLAINED. THE NEED
FOR IT IS MONUMENTOS THE FACT
IS IN A AND I SAID THIS IN
COMMITTEE WHEN WE GOT
OPPOSITION ACCUSE US OF BEING
CANCEL CULTURE THE FACT IS WE
HAVE TO TELL THE TRUE HISTORY
WE HAVE TO LOOK AT THE FACT
THAT HUMAN HISTORY ISN'T ALL
SUNSHINE AND RAINBOWS. THERE'S
A DARK SIDE TO HOW. WE GOT TO
WHERE WE'RE AT. AND WE NEED TO
FACE THAT AS A BODY IN GIVE THE
NATIVE PEOPLE. WE HAVE THE
HISTORIC RIGHTS TO THESE LANDS
THE ABILITY TO TELL THAT
HISTORY ASK YOU FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANKS RATHAS MISTER NAZARIAN
IN THE REAR THE CHAMBER YOUR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I STAND TODAY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB THREE THREE EIGHT
WE'VE DISCUSSED GENOCIDES
RACIAL INJUSTICES AND CONTINUED
DISCRIMINATION ON THIS FLOOR
MANY TIMES BEFORE. THIS BILL
WILL SERVE AS THE END OF A LONG
AWAITED PERIOD IN THE LIVES OF
THE NATIVE PEOPLE. IN
CALIFORNIA LONG OVERDUE- JUST
AS WE HAVE COME TOGETHER FOR
OUR ARMENIAN JEWISH API LATINO
AND LACK COMMUNITIES. I ASK
THAT WE COME TOGETHER FOR A
NATIVE AMERICAN PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA IT IS NOT
APPROPRIATE TO HAVE A STATUTORY
REQUIREMENT TO ERECT AND
MAINTAIN A STATUE OF. JUNIPERO
SERRA ON THE STATE CAPITOL
GROUNDS WE SHOULD BE HONORING
OUR NATIVE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
BY REPLACING IT WITH A NEW
MONUMENT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER NAZARIAN. MISTER SEA
IN THE WORK MR GARCIA THE RICH
YOU'RE A MISTER SPEAKER IN
CALLING GUY WHO. AND SUPPORT OF
AB THREE THREE EIGHT BY OUR
CALL FROM THE ILLINOIS. YOU
KNOW. RECENTLY WE'VE HEARD THE
SAYING PEOPLE ARE ENTITLED
THEIR OWN. BUT BUT NOT THEIR
OWN FACTS. AND I. THE BILL COME
FALL BECAUSE WHAT IT DOES IS
BEGINS TO TELL THE REAL STORY.
OF CALIFORNIA NATIVES AND THE
TREATMENT OF THEIR PEOPLES. AND
BY THIS BILL MOVING FORWARD THE
LOCAL TRIBES HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TELL THEIR
STORY. AND SO FOR THOSE REASONS
AND MANY MORE I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB THREE THREE
EIGHT. THANK YOU MR GARCIA
MISTER RIVAS AT YOUR DESK THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I ALSO RISE-
IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE THREE
EIGHT YOU KNOW I WANT TO THANK
MY COLLEAGUE FROM HIGHLAND FOR
AUTHORING THIS CRITICAL.
LEGISLATION AND AS WE'VE HEARD
THIS BILL OF KNOWLEDGE AND
ELEVATE THE OFTEN IGNORED
HISTORY- ARE NATIVE PEOPLE BY
HONORING THEM WITH A MONUMENT
HERE ON CAPITOL GROUNDS IN. OUR
STATE IS HOME TO A PROXY SEVEN
OR TWENTY THOUSAND NATIVE
AMERICANS IN. THIS IS LONG
OVERDUE THIS RECOGNITION AND SO
FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER. THANK
A MYSTERY OF US MR FRAZIER IN
THE REAR CHAMBER. BAKER
ALTHOUGH I AM NOT CALIFORNIAN
NATIVE I AM NATIVE BLOOD. FROM
OKLAHOMA AND I APPLAUD MY
COLLEAGUES FOR BRINGING THIS.
FORWARD I DID TRY TO DO THIS
SEVERAL YEARS AGO. AND I'M GLAD
HE WAS ABLE TO CREATE THE
SYNERGY TO BRING THIS FORWARD.
pIN CALIFORNIA AND OF AMERICA.
HAVE A DAY OF RECKONING COMING
A DAY OF RECOGNITION. IN A DAY
OF APPRECIATION FOR THAT WE
SHOULD SUPPORT THIS BILL GOING
FORWARD THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER FRAZIER MISTER MCCARTY
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I'M A PROUD JOIN
AUTHOR WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAMPOERNA DINO. HI THIS IS
IMPORTANT TO OUR STATE CAPITOL
HERE THE SEAT OF GOVERNMENT IT
HERE IN SACRAMENTO THIS WOULD
AUTHORIZE THE CONSTRUCTION OF A
MONUMENT RECOGNIZING OUR NATIVE
PEOPLE ON OUR TRIBES. AND IT'S
A SHAME THAT FOR DECADES WE HAD
ONLY ALL ALL WE HAD HERE WAS
THE MONUMENT TO. TWENTY BUT A
SET UP THE STATUE IN THE
CAPITOL PARK WHICH DEATH
FOCUSED ON THE ENSLAVEMENT OF
OUR NATIVE PEOPLE SO THIS IS A
LONG OVERDUE RECOGNITION AND I
STAND IN FULL SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR MCCARTY AND MR
COOLEY IN THE REAR CHAMBER.
COLLEAGUES I'M VERY PLEASED TO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS I THINK.
THIS VENUE THE CAPITOL PARK TWO
OF KNOWLEDGE ARE NATIVE PEOPLES
IS ACTUALLY VERY SIGNIFICANT.
HERE IN THIS BUILDING WE WORK
TOGETHER TO SECURE A BETTER
FUTURE FOR OUR CHILDREN. FOR
OUR SOCIETY THIS GREAT
CALIFORNIA SO IMPORTANT IN THE
GLOBE. AND- YEAH FROM THIS
BUILDING I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
MIND WE WERE PRECEDED HERE BY
PEOPLE WHO LIVED HERE
SUCCESSIVELY FOR GENERATIONS
WHO TOOK CARE OF THEIR FAMILIES
TO PROVIDE A FUTURE FOR THEIR
CHILDREN AND ACTUALLY DID SO
WITH A BALANCE. OF WITH THE
WORLD AROUND THEM. THE WE ARE
STILL WORKING TO TRY TO FIND
THAT BALANCE SO I THINK. TO
DEDICATE A SPACE IN THE
CALIFORNIA KAPPLE PART. TWO OF
KNOWLEDGE THE SOCIETIES THAT
LIVED HERE BEFORE US TO SUFFER
DEPRESSION. WHO LIVED IN
BALANCE WITH THE WORLD OF HAND
AND YET SAW. BY THEIR WORK AND
LIFE TO PROVIDE FOR THEIR KIDS
JUST AS WE DO IN THIS BUILDING.
I THINK IT'S VERY VERY FITTING
TO HAVE SUCH A KNOWLEDGE ON
THESE CAPITOL GROUNDS THAT WE
REMEMBER THAT WE ARE JUST A
PART OF A GREAT HUMAN
ENTERPRISE. WE ARE NOT THE
FIRST ON THE SCENE. THANK YOU
MISS COOLEY SEE NO OTHER
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION
MISTER RAMOS WHO MAKE CLOTHES
IF YOU WISH THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER THANK YOU TO MY
COLLEAGUES WHO- RISE AND TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL IN CLOSING
THIS BILL IS ABOUT RESPECT AS
THE VERY ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THAT
WE ALL REPRESENT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS HAD ATROCITIES
HAPPENED WITHIN THEM. WE HAS A
STATE LEGISLATURE SHOULD NOT
SHY AWAY FROM THIS ISSUE WAS
STAND AS ONE AND BE THAT VOICE
THAT HAS YET TO BE HEARD. I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. NAME IS ROSS
AND WITH THAT CLERK WILL OPEN.
ALL MEMBERS. IS THAT A VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS THAT A VOTE.
WELL CLOSE A ROLL TIDE OF I
SHOULD SEVEN NO TWO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES PASSER. THIRTY
THIS IS FILE THAT THIRTY FIVE
AB FOR THREE CORPORATE. WAS
BILL FOUR FORTY THREE BY A
MEMBER CARILLO INOCULATED TO
HEALING ARCH THIS CARILLO YOU
MAY OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER AND
MEMBERS I AM PROUD 2% ASSEMBLY
BILL FOUR FOUR THREE WHICH
WOULD ALLOW INTERNATIONAL
MEDICAL GRADUATES TO
PARTICIPATE IN A FELLOWSHIP
PROGRAM OFFERED AT A FEDERICO
THE FIGHT HEALTH CENTER. IN
RURAL AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA THIS
BILL WOULD ALSO EXPAND ON
EXISTING PROGRAM WITH THE
MEDICAL BOARD TO ALLOW ITS
SPECIALTY FACULTY PERMIT TO BE
ISSUED AT A FEDERALLY QUALIFIED
HEALTH CENTER. FOR AN
APPLICATION FOR AN APPLICATION
FORM VISIT PHYSICIAN THAT
SPEAKS THE LANGUAGE OF NEED
MATCHING THE PATIENT POPULATION
ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE
COMMISSION ABOUT SEVEN MILLION
CALIFORNIANS LIVE IN AN AREA
WITH A SHORTAGE. OF HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS THESE THOSE SHORTAGES
ARE CONCENTRATED IN COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR MAKING THE NEED FOR
MULTI LINGUAL PHYSICIANS EVEN
MORE ACUTE. THROUGH THE COVERED
NINETEEN VACCINE ROLLOUT
CONTINUES WE HAVE SEEN HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS TO HAVE
CULTURALLY COMPETENT PHYSICIANS
THAT CAN BUILD RELATIONSHIPS
WITH AN ADVOCATE FOR OUR
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. AND
COMMUNITIES WITH DIFFERENT
LANGUAGES NECESSITIES AB FOUR
FOUR THREE WILL ALLOW US TO
CONTINUE TO BUILD A GLOBALLY
COMPETITIVE HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE AND IT WILL BENEFIT
CALIFORNIANS THAT NEED IT MOST.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED NO
OPPOSITION AND HAS RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
LOOK FORWARDING I LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING TO WORK WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS AS THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD. AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THEY
MISCREANT DOCTOR CHECK. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER FOR YOUR TIME A ONE TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FROM LOS
ANGELES FOR HER DEDICATION AND
BRING THIS BILL FOR IT. TO THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR IT'S MORE
IMPORTANT THAN EVER THAT
DESPITE THIS PANDEMIC WOULD BE
MORE FROM MY WORKERS INTO OUR
WORKFORCE. AND TELEMEDICINE AND
TELE PSYCHIATRY FANTASTIC
HAVING A PERSON IN FRONT OF YOU
IN TERMS OF HEALTHCARE ISSUES
IS MORE IMPORTANT EVER SO THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BRING
THIS TO THE FLOOR AND THIS
ISSUE IS NOT A PARTISAN ISSUE
AND I ENCOURAGE MY COLLEAGUES
ON BOTH AISLES. TO FALL THROUGH
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU
DOCTOR. I SEE NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLICK LIBERAL. ZERO MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE FOR THE SERVER. THE CLERK
WILL CALL ARE ALL TIED I SIX
FIVE NO ONE. THAT MEASURE THIS
IS ITEM SIX AB FOUR FIFTY FIVE
I MISS WICKS CORKERY. ASSEMBLY
RULE FOR FIFTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WICKS AND OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE AND TRANSPORTATION
MISS WHICH EMAIL THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS EIGHTY
FOUR FIFTY FIVE WOULD AUTHORIZE
THE BAY AREA TOLL AUTHORITY. IN
CONSULTATION WITH CALTRANS TO
ESTABLISH TRAFFIC LANES FOR
TRANSIT AND SPECIFIED HIGH
OCCUPANCY VEHICLES ON THE BAY
BRIDGE CORNERDURING PEAK HOURS
GROWING TRAFFIC CONGESTION IS
MAKING BUS RIDERSHIP SLOWER AND
LESS RELIABLE IN THE BAY AREA.
TRANSIT RELIABILITY CHALLENGES
IN THE BAY AREA QUARTER
PARTICULARLY IMPACT WRITERS
HAVE FIXED INFLEXIBLE WORK
HOURS THAT DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTS LOW INCOME BLACK AND
LATINO WORKERS 40% OF TRANSIT
RIDERS MAKE LESS THAN FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR 60% OUR
PEOPLE OF COLOR AND 30% SPEAK A
LANGUAGE OTHER THAN ENGLISH AT
HOME. BY SUPPORTING A MORE
RELIABLE BUS SERVICE ACROSS THE
BAY AREA BRIDGE. EIGHTY FOUR
FIFTY FIVE ENSURES EQUITABLE
ACCESS AND OPPORTUNITY FOR
THOUSANDS OF RETURNING WORKERS
IN THE BAY AREA. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
WICKS. SEEING NOTED. DEBATE ON
ITEM. CLICK LOCAL. MEMBERS OF.
THE DESIGN TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
OF THE DESIGN TO VOTE. ALL
SHALL RESIDE OF. CLARK WELL.
CLOTHES ARE ALSO UP AS FORTY
NINE THOSE. TEN THAT MEASURE
PASS. A PASSER TEN OF ALLEN
THIRTY SEVEN. THIS IS FILE ITEM.
THIRTY EIGHT EIGHTY SIX NINETY
SEVEN FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS CLERK WILL READ WITH
AMENDMENTS. SOME PEOPLE SIX
NINETY SEVEN WITH A MEMBERS BY
ITS MEMBER BUT SHALL. MICHELLE
ON THE AMENDMENTS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISS SPEAKER MEMBERS
A. B. SIX NINETY SEVEN WE
CREATE A PROGRAM FOR THE STATE
TO PLAN MANAGE AND IMPLEMENT
FOREST RESTORATION PROJECT ON
US FOREST SERVICE LANDS. THE
AMENDMENTS WOULD MOVE THE
PROGRAM TO BE UNDER SECRETARY
OF THE NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY
AN AUTHORIZED THE STATE TO
CONTRACT WITH OTHER STATE
AGENCIES AND PRIVATE ENTITIES
TO IMPLEMENT SOME OF THE
PROJECT I'D ASK WHERE I GO.
THANK YOU IS CHELSEA NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE EYES HAVE
IT THE MEMBERS ARE BILL OUT TO
PER. AND BACK ON FOR. REPORTER
PASS A RETAIN A FOLLOW THIRTY
NOW OF THIS WITH FILE ITEM TO
IS FILE ITEM FOR ONE. AB
THIRTEEN FORTY. CORKERY
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRD FORTY FOUR
BY ASSEMBLY ARAMBULA AN ACT
RELATING TO HEALTH DR RABIA
EMAIL. THANK YOU MISTER STE AND
MEMBER. SHARON EXCHANGE. S. P.
HAVE ASSIGNED IN. H. HEPATITIS
C. AND OTHER INFECTIOUS
DISEASES IN CALIFORNIA. AB
THIRTEEN FORTY FOUR WILL
PROTECT THESE VITAL SERVICES BY
PROVIDING THESE PROGRAMS WITH
AN EXEMPTION FROM SEQUEL
REQUIREMENTS. CALIFORNIA C.
P.'S PROVIDE A WIDE RANGE OF
SERVICES IN ADDITION TO SYRINGE
ACCESS AND DISPOSAL INCLUDING
HIV AND HEPATITIS TESTING.
OVERDOSE PREVENTION TRAINING
AND REFERRALS TO DRUG TREATMENT
HOUSING AND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. THESE SERVICES HAVE
HELPED GARNERED THE TRUST IN
PEOPLE WHO WOULD NOT OTHERWISE
SEEK OUT HARM REDUCTION
STRUCTURE OF ASIS. WE MUST BE
REMINDED THAT THERE IS AN
URGENT NEED TO EXPAND AS HE
PEES IN OUR STATE IN ORDER TO
ADDRESS OUR LOOMING OPIOID.
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY. DURING
THE PANDEMIC THERE HAS BEEN A
SHARP INCREASE IN OVERDOSE.
DEATHS AS EVIDENCED BY THE CDC.
THE NEED FOR ACCESS TO SYRINGES
AND OTHER SERVICES PROVIDED BY
SAP'S IS NOW GREATER THAN EVER.
WITHOUT IMMEDIATE LEGISLATIVE
ACTION THE PUBLIC HEALTH
PREVENTION SERVICES PROVIDED BY
S. C. P.'S DIRECTLY AUTHORIZED
BY CDPH WILL BE CURTAILED. AND
NEW PROGRAMS WILL BE DETERMINED
AT THE PRECISE TIME WHEN THE
NEED FOR THEM IS INCREASING. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. EIGHT THANK YOU ARAMBULA
MISTER MCCARTY YOUR USE THIS IS
A PUBLIC HEALTH IS AND SO NOT
BE POLITICAL ISSUE. I'M I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM FRESNO FOR BRINGING THIS
MATTER TO OUR ATTENTION NOW WE
DO KNOW THAT THERE'S A CRISIS
IN OVER DEBT OVERDOSE CRISIS IN
OUR STATE. THROUGH OPIOID
EPIDEMIC- I JUST HEARD THIS
MORNING THEY THEN THENUMBER OF
DEATHS WE ANTICIPATE HAPPENING
IN SAN FRANCISCO THIS YEAR IS
OVER SEVEN HUNDRED FROM DEATHS
FROM OPIOID ABUSE AND FENNEL.
HAVING THESE FACILITIES MAKES
SENSE BUT UNFORTUNATELY IT'S
BECOME A POLITICAL WEDGE ISSUE
THIS WILL ENABLE COMMUNITIES TO
FOCUS ON PUBLIC HEALTH AND
REDUCE BARRIERS FOR PEOPLE TO
THROW UP ROADBLOCKS IN
PREVENTING THESE FACILITIES TO.
TO BE PART OF OUR COMMUNITIES.
WITH THAT I ASK THE ARRIVAL
THANK YOU. DAMOS MCCARTY MISTER
GALLAGHER RECKON. YES THEY YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBER- YEAH
THIS IS IMPORTANT TO ME AND MY
DISTRICT- BECAUSE MANY OF THESE
PROGRAMS THOUGH HAVE A NEEDLE
EXCHANGE PROGRAMS CAN BE DONE
VERY WELL AND CAN CERTAINLY. BE
HELPFUL IN GETTING PEOPLE OFF
OF- DRUGS DEALING WITH THE
OPIOID CRISIS CRISIS THAT'S
TRUE MANY OF THESE PROGRAMS
HAVEN'T BEEN OPERATED SAFELY-
AND IN THE INTEREST OF THE
COMMUNITY AND I'LL GIVE THE
EXAMPLE OF THIS IN MY COMMUNITY
AND ONE OF MY COMMUNITIES ALONE
IN CHICO THIS WAS OPERATED AS A
NEEDLE DISTRIBUTION. ROGAN NOT
AN EXCHANGE PROGRAM. GIVING OUT
NEEDLES THESE NEEDLES ENDED UP
IN OUR PARKS AND OUR WATER WAYS
IN PLACES WHERE CHILDREN PLAY.
AND BECAME A HEALTH HAZARD IN
OUR COMMUNITIES AND IT WAS ONLY
BY SOMEONE BRING IN A SEQUEL
LAWSUIT. THERE WAS ABLE TO STOP
THIS PROGRAM FROM GOING FOR
BECAUSE THEY HAD NOT GONE
THROUGH. AND MITIGATED AND EVEN
PLAN FOR. THE OPERATION OF
THIS- PROGRAM IN THAT COMMUNITY
THIS BILL TAKES AWAY THAT.
ABILITY AND I KNOW WE TALKED A
LOT ABOUT SEQUEL ON THIS FLOOR
AND HOW IT IS AN IMPEDIMENT. TO
HOUSING TO THE CONSTRUCTION OF
WATER STORAGE PROJECTS. TWO SO
MANY VITAL INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
WE NEED IN OUR COMMUNITIES BUT
WE'VE NEVER DONE A NEEDLE WE'VE
NEVER DONE A SEQUEL EXEMPTION
FOR THAT. WE'VE DONE A SEQUEL
EXEMPTION FOR ARENAS AND SPORTS
STADIUMS. WE DON'T DO IT FOR
THE VITAL THINGS THAT WE ALL
KNOW WE NEED BUT WE'RE GONNA DO
IT HERE FOR NEEDLE NEEDLE
PROGRAMS. THAT'S NOT
CONSISTENT. AND ALSO WHEN YOU
WHEN WE HAVE EXAMPLES RIGHT NOW
AND IT'S NOT JUST MY COMMUNITY
THIS HAPPENED IN ORANGE COUNTY.
THIS IS HAPPEN IN MANY
DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES UP AND
DOWN CALIFORNIA WHERE. THESE
PROGRAMS WERE NOT PLANNED
APPROPRIATELY AND THEY DID NOT
COORDINATE WITH THE COMMUNITY.
A SECOND THING THAT YOU SHOULD
BE AWARE OF IT'S NOT JUST THIS
EXEMPTION HERE THAT'S GOING ON.
RIGHT NOW DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH IS DOING EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS TO TAKE AWAY LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ABILITY TO
CONTROL NEEDLE EXCHANGE
PROGRAMS. IN THEIR COMMUNITIES
SAY THAT THE PERMIT YOU CAN
ONLY GO TO. DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH AND GET THE
PERMIT THEY HAVE THEY DON'T
HAVE TO GO. THROUGH THE LOCALS
SO IT'S TAKING AWAY NOW YOUR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES ABILITY TO
ENSURE THAT THESE PROGRAMS ARE
DONE SAFELY. ALONG WITH
HUMANELY AND SO I ASKED I ASK
YOU PLEASE DO NOT GO ALONG WITH
THIS BLINDLY THIS COULD CAUSE A
LOT OF PROBLEMS FOR YOUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. AND I WOULD URGE A
NO VOTE WE NEED SOME MORE
DISCUSSION ON THIS. THIS BILL
AS IT IS TODAY TO ME IS NOT
ACCEPTABLE TO LOCAL CONTROL AND
TO ENSURE THAT THESE PROGRAMS
ARE OPERATED. IN THE RIGHT WAY
AND PROTECT OUR COMMUNITIES IN
ADDITION TO HELPING THOSE WHO
DESPERATELY NEED NEED TO GET
OFF DRUGS THANK YOU. MR COOLEY
YOUR RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR
CHAMBER. COLLEAGUES THIS IS NOT
A TOPPER FOR WHICH I ORDINARILY
HAVE A LOT OF CONTACT. THOUGH I
ACTUALLY HAVE ON MY PHONE A
PHOTOGRAPH OF A TRASH CAN. IN A
ROOM THAT I ENCOUNTERED ON
LET'S SAY BUSINESS THAT HAD
EIGHT OF. SYRINGES TUCKED AWAY
IN PLACES IN THE ROOM ARE JUST
ASTONISHED TO ENCOURAGE THAT
SORT OF THING HERE. I DO FEEL I
NEED TO JUMP UP IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. AND NOTE THAT. IF
THERE ARE PROGRAMS THAT ARE NOT
BEING PROPERLY ADMINISTERED.
THAT IS A SUBJECT MATTER FOR
OVERSIGHT. TO LOOK FOR WHAT
THEY'RE DOING AND TO TIGHTEN IT
UP THAT IS A SPECIFIC FUNCTION
OF GOVERNMENTAL BODIES TO LOOK
AT EXISTING PROGAMS. AND IF
THEY'RE NOT RUNNING IN THE
RIGHT WAY ADDRESS THAT. SEQUEL
IS MORE OF A GATEKEEPING
FUNCTION AT THE VERY OUTSET. SO
A SEQUEL A REVIEW WILL NOT SHED
LIGHT ON THE ULTIMATE DETAILS
OF THE ADMINISTRATION OF A
PROGRAM. THAT IS IMPLEMENTED.
SO I. PERSONALLY FEEL THAT
SECRET IS MORE OF A GATEKEEPER
ROLE IN ADVANCE IF THERE ARE
OBJECTIONS THE ADMINISTRATION
PROGRAMS WHICH ARE WELL MADE.
AND I HAVE MY OWN EVIDENCE OF
THE PROBLEMS OF SYRINGES-
THAT'S AN OVERSIGHT FUNCTION
BUT I DON'T BELIEVE THIS BILL
WILL UNDERMINE AN IRISH AND I
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS COOLEY SAY
NO OTHER MAY. SEEKING RE. DE
RAM THAT YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK
YOU FOR THE OFFER. TO PRESENT.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK ASSEMBLY
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH MY
OFFICE ON AMENDMENTS TO REMOVE
OPPOSITION FROM THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES. AND THE
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA THROUGH AMENDMENTS
ON APRIL EIGHTH I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. AND WITH
THAT THE CLERK WILL CALL THE
ROLL. MEMBERS WE DESIGNED A
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
THOSE. ALL MY VOTERS OUT OF.
THANK WILL CLOSER ALL TIED UP
HIGHS FORTY THREE. THOSE
SIXTEEN. THE MEASURE PASSES.
THIS IS FILE ITEM FORTY TWO AB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY NINE CORPORATE
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN EIGHTY
NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES
AND OTHERS AND ACT WITHIN THEIR
POLLUTION THIS RACE YOU MAY
OPEN THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS TO THEIR PRESENT TO YOU
AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY NINE WHICH
WILL MODERNIZE THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION'S CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM. THE
INLAND EMPIRE THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY THE GREATER LOS ANGELES
AREA ARE CURRENTLY CLASSIFIED
AS EXTREME NON ATTAINMENT AREAS
WELL THE BAY AREA SACRAMENTO
SAN DIEGO RANGE FROM MODERATE
TO SEVERE NON ATTAINMENT UNDER
THE FEDERAL CLEAN AIR ACT. AB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY NINE WILL FOCUS
INVESTMENTS IN THAT IN THAT
PROGRAM TOWARDS EMERGING MEDIUM
AND HEAVY DUTY FREIGHT INDUSTRY
AND DEDICATE 50% OF THE FUNDING
TO PROJECTS LOCATED IN
POLLUTION BURDENED COMMUNITIES.
CLEANING UP THE TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR IS CRITICAL TO
CORRECTING ENVIRONMENTAL
INJUSTICES AND ENSURING EVERY
CALIFORNIAN HAS ACCESS TO CLEAN
AIR I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. THE AIM IS REYES
SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE CLUB
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. THAT ABOUT
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRABLE.
THE CLERK WILL. CLOSER TALBERT
EYES FORTY FIVE KNOWS NINE THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEMS FORTY
THREE THROUGH FORTY FIVE PASS
RETAIN WE'VE DISPENSED WITH
FORTY SIX THIS IS FILE ITEM
FORTY SEVEN. AB FIVE FIVE NINE
CORKERY. ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE TWO
NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER ARAMBULA
AND ACTUALLY IN THE RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DOCTOR RANDALL YOU
MAY GET OPEN THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT AB FIVE FIVE
NINE URBAN GREEN SPACES WERE
VITAL TO MENTAL HEALTH AND
RESILIENCY DURING THE PANDEMIC
UNFORTUNATELY MANY COMMUNITIES
LACK ACCESS TO THESE SPACES.
THE SAN JOAQUIN RIVER
CONSERVANCY AIMS TO INCREASE
PUBLIC ACCESS BUT THE GUIDING
BODY IS MISSING VOICES
REPRESENTATIVE OF COMMUNITIES
WHICH COULD BENEFIT THE MOST AB
FIVE FIVE NINE WOULD GIVE THESE
UNDER REPRESENTED VOICES A VOTE
ON THE SAN JOAQUIN RIVER
CONSERVANCY BOARD NOTABLY ONE
OF THE FIRST TRIBAL NATION
SEATS ACROSS ALL CONSERVANCIES.
AB FIVE FIVE NINE ALSO REFRAINS
THE FOCUS OF COUNTY RESIDENTS
SEATS ENSURES THE BOARD IS
FULLY SEATED AND MAKES OTHER
CHANGES TO ALIGN ITS OPERATION
AS A STATE AGENCY ALONGSIDE
OTHER CONSERVANCIES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON AB FIVE FIVE NINE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR. MYSTERONS YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I THANK THE
AUTHOR- FROM FRESNO- I'M
ADDING- INCLUDING THE TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES AND IN THIS
IMPORTANT BOARD- FOR THE FIRST
TIME THE TRIBAL RECOGNITION OF
HAVING A SEAT ON THIS BOARD. IS
A VOICE AS FAR INCOMING I WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR THAT
URGENT AYE VOTE ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MYSTERONS SEEN
ADDITIONAL THIS. OF EIGHT ON
THE ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. DESIRABLE ALL MEMBERS ARE
OF A. ALL MEMBERS OF A RESERVE
OF. CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLE
CHINA'S FORTY SIX KNOWS
THIRTEEN. THE MEASURE PASSES
PAST RETAIN A FILE ITEM FORTY
EIGHT THIS IS FILE ITEM FORTY
NINE. AB THIRTEEN OH TWO DR CAR
CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY RULE
THIRTEEN OF TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK AN
ACCOLADE IN THE CANNABIS DOCTOR
QUIRKY MAIL. YOU SPEAKER IN
TWENTY NINETEEN THE BUREAU OF
CAN CAN. THE REGULATIONS TO
CLARIFY A PORTION OF THE
LANGUAGE ADOPTED IN PROP SIXTY
FOUR WITH RESPECT TO BILLBOARD
ADVERTISING. LANGUAGE IN
PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR STATES
THAT A LICENSEE SHALL NOT
ADVERTISE OR MARKET ON A
BILLBOARD OR SIMILAR
ADVERTISING DEVICE LOCATED ON A
HIGHWAY. STATE OR FEDERAL THAT
CROSSES THE CALIFORNIA BORDER
YEAH OF COURSE STATE HIGHWAYS
DON'T CROSS THE CALIFORNIA
BORDER. HOWEVER BUT THAT'S WHAT
IT SAID IT WAS VERY HARD TO
FIGURE OUT THIS WHAT THIS MEANS
BECAUSE FOR EXAMPLE. I EIGHTY
IN OAKLAND YOU CAN ADVERTISE ON
BUT I FIVE EIGHTY YOU CAN-
BASICALLY WE'VE ASKED THE
LAWYERS WHO WERE IN THE ROOM
THEY HAVE NO IDEA WITH THE
LANGUAGE CAME FROM OR WHAT IT
WAS MEANT TO DO. IN TWENTY TEN
WHICH IS WITH THE BUREAU
DECIDED THAT PROP SIXTY FOUR
DOES NOT CLERK THE BUREAU OF
CANNABIS CONTROL. OF JUST NOT
CLARIFIED WHAT EXTENT SURE
VERSION SUCH REAR PROHIBITION
SHOULD TAKE PLACE AND FELT THAT
A FIFTY MILE RADIUS WAS
APPROPRIATE. IN TWENTY TEN
THESE REGULATIONS WERE
CHALLENGED THE COURTS STRUCK
DOWN THE REGULATIONS. ARGUING
THAT THE BUREAU- SUPERSEDED THE
AUTHORITY GRANTED IN PROP SIXTY
FOUR. AGAIN WE REALLY DON'T
KNOW WHAT THAT LANGUAGE WAS
MEANT TO DO. PRACTICALLY
SPEAKING THIS MEANS THAT
ADVERTISING IS NOT ALLOWED LONG
FOUR THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED
MILES OF INTERSTATE HIGHWAYS.
INCLUDING FIVE TEN EIGHTY BUT
NOT INCLUDING FIVE EIGHTY SIX
EIGHTY. TWO EIGHTY THREE
EIGHTY. I BECAUSE IT IS SO IT'S
JUST A MESS. AB THIRTEEN OH TWO
WOULD MODIFY THE REGULATIONS
BUREAU DROPPED IT IN TWENTY
NINETEEN AND ALLOW CANNABIS
LICENSES TO ADVERTISE YOUR
MARKET ON A BILLBOARD ALONG THE
HIGHWAY THAT IS FURTHER THAN
FIFTEEN MILES RADIUS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA BORDER. THE FEELING
HERE WAS THAT THIS WOULD
PREVENT PEOPLE FROM. SCENE THE
BILLBOARD WHO FROM ANOTHER.
CANNABIS ADVERTISING IS ALREADY
EXTREMELY RESTRICTED CALIFORNIA
STATUTE REGULATIONS SPECIFY
THAT ADVERTISEMENT COULD NOT BE
ATTRACTIVE ARE GEARED TOWARDS
AUDIENCES UNDER THE AGE OF
TWENTY ONE. THIS IS POLLUTES
PROHIBITION ON CARTOON
CHARACTERS IMAGES OF ANYONE
UNDER THE AGE OF TWENTY ONE AND
TOYS. WE ARE SERIOUSLY
CONCERNED ABOUT CLOSING THE
DOOR ON THE ILLICIT MARKET
WHICH IS WERE MINORS GET ACCESS
TO CANNABIS WITH UNKNOWN
CONTAMINANTS WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE WE HELP THE LEGAL MARKET
GROW AND THRIVE A. B. THIRTEEN
OH TWO ACCOMPLISHES THAT I ASK
THE ARRIVAL OF. THANK YOU DR
COURT. SEE NO MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THIS ITEM THE
CLUB ROLL ALL MEMBERS OF. ZERO
ALL MEMBERS A DESIRE TO VOTE.
THIS TAKES THIRTY FOUR. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF.
CLARK
WELL CULTURAL TIE ABOUT ICT FOR
KNOWS FOR. THAT MEASURE PASSES
RETAIN ABOUT FIFTY ONE THIS IS
FILE ITEM FIFTY TWO AB ONE
COOKERY. ASSEMBLY BILL ONE BY A
SOME MEMBER TO GARCIA AND
OTHERS AN APPLICANT HAS WASTE
MS GARCIA EMAIL ME THANK YOU AB
ONE EIGHTH DTIC REFORM
SOMETHING WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT. FOR FIVE YEARS AT LEAST
SINCE OUR FIFTH ATTEMPT- TO
MAKE SURE WE DON'T HAVE ANOTHER
EXCITED RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK GARCIA SEEING
NO DISCUSSION OR TO ON THE ADAM.
CLICK LIBERAL. MEMBERS THE
SENATE VOTE ALL MEMBERS OUT OF
A. YEAH. YEAH ALL MEMBERS OUT
OF A. NEVER AGAIN. WE HAVE.
ALSO HAVE. CLARK WELL CLOSE
ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FORTY NINE
KNOWS. DEVONSHIRE PASSES. HAS
RETAINED APPELLATE FIFTY THIS
IS FILE ITEM FIFTY FOUR. AB
SEVEN COOKERY ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
RODRIGUEZ AND OTHERS AND
ACCORDING TO EMERGENCY
AMBULANCE EMPLOYEES MISTER
RODRIGUEZ THANK MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS ARRIVED TODAY TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN
LAST YEAR THIS BODY PASSED AB
TWENTY NINETY TWO. A SIMILAR TO
THE ONE BEFORE YOU TODAY AB
SEVEN AS A REINTRODUCTION OF
THAT MEASURE TO ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS POSED BY THE
MINISTRATION WHICH WERE ONE
LACK OF PROVISIONS REGULATING
THE USE OF THE GEAR AND TO THAT
EMPLOYEE SHOULD NOT HAVE TO PAY
FOR THE SECURE IN THE FIRST
PLACE I MEMBERS WITHOUT- I
AGREE WITH MY PERSONAL WORK
EXPERIENCE IN THE M. S. I
TOTALLY AGREE ONE HUNDRED
PERCENT. EMPLOYEE SHOULD NOT
HAVE TO PAY FOR PROTECTIVE GEAR
YEP PRIVATE SECTOR EMS FIRST
RESPONDERS OR DISPATCH OUT TO
RESPOND TO EMERGENCY CALLS
WITHOUT ADEQUATE GEAR PROTECT
THEMSELVES YOU MAY ASK WHY DOES
THE BILL ONLY APPLY TO THE
PRIVATE SECTOR IT'S BECAUSE IN
CALIFORNIA OVER 80% OF THE EMS
AMBULANCES ARE OPERATED BY THE
PRIVATE SECTOR EMS PERSONNEL.
OVER 76% OF THE NINE ONE ONE
CALLS ARE FIELDED BY PRIVATE
SECTOR YEAH MESS PERSONNEL YOU
MAY ALSO HEARD FROM THE
OPPOSITION THAT IS GEAR IS NOT
NECESSARY WELL THEY BEGIN TO
NATIONAL ROLL OUT THEIR OWN
SUBSIDIZED PROGRAMS FOR THE
VERY SAME HERE THIS BILL WOULD
PROVIDE. EVERY NINE ONE ONE
CALL THAT YOU MUST RESPOND HERS
RESPOND TO HAS THE POTENTIAL TO
BECOME A DANGEROUS SITUATION
OFTENTIMES THEY'RE ASSAULTED BY
THE PEOPLE THAT THEY ARE TRYING
TO HELP THERE ARE MANY STUDIES
SURVEYS AND ARTICLES INCLUDING
A TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN LABOR
REPORT BY UCLA THAT REVEALED
THAT OCCUPANT TAKE OCCUPATIONS
EMTS CAN BE DANGEROUS WITH HIGH
RATES OF MORTALITY ENTRY.
MENTAL M. FOR TOM. BIRDS ARE
CONTINUE WORK WITH. AND WITH
THE EMPLOYEE INDUSTRY ENSURE
THE FOR GEAR IS PROVIDED TO OUR
PRO FOR. ARE SPECTRUM I GO.
THANK YOU MISTER MASTERS UNTIL
YOUR- THANK YOU SPEAKER MAY OF
THE LAST DAM SINCE. OF AB
SEVEN. I'D LIKE TO THINK MY
CALL FOR. THIS AND HIS
PERSEVERANCE OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS TO TRY TO. ENSURE THAT WE
ADDRESS IT. IS VICE CHAIR OF
THE NEW EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
COMMITTEE AND A FORMER FIRST
RESPONDER FOR THIRTY FIVE
YEARS. I CAN ATTEST TO THE NEED
FOR THIS BILL. DANGER
SITUATIONS ARE OCCURRING MORE
FREQUENTLY IN OUR COMMUNITY
THESE CHANGES REQUIRE MORE
SAFETY FOR FIRST RESPONDERS.
WITH MORE PRIVATE AMBULANCE
COMPANIES RESPONDING TO
INCIDENTS ALONGSIDE LAW
ENFORCEMENT THESE HEROES NEED
FURTHER PROTECTION FROM HARM.
COLLEAGUES THIS BILL SIMPLY
REQUIRES THAT THE PRIVATE
AMBULANCE COMPANIES RECOGNIZE
THREATS OUR PARAMEDIC SPACE AND
PROVIDE THE NECESSARY
PROTECTION FOR THEIR EMPLOYEES
IT IS NOT RIGHT TO ASK THEM TO
PAY FOR IT THEMSELVES. IT IS
FOR THOSE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER SAY ARE. SAYING NOBODY
DISK. OR DEBATE ON THE ADAM.
CLARK LOW THE ROLE. IS THAT
VOTE ALL OVER VOTERS OUT OF A.
HOWEVER SERVICE ARE VOTE. CLERK
WILL CLOSE ROLE TIDE ICE THREE
NO. EIGHT THAT MEASURE PASS
THIS IS ITEM FIVE AB NINE CLICK
ON. SOME PEOPLE NINE BY SOME
MEMBERS WOULD AN ACCURATE IN
THE FIRES. DOCTOR WILL YOU MAIL.
THANK YOU MISTER IN MAY EIGHT
NINE THE REACH FORCE AND PARK
OR ARE F. PER THAT IS UNDER WAY
AT THE PARK CONVERT CONSERVE.
THE BILL HAS NOT OFFICE AT RISK
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
JACK AND WHAT. SEE NOTICE. OUR
DEBATE. CLICK. ZERO ALL MEMBERS
ARE A. YEAH. ALL MEMBERS
DESERVED VOTE. CUICUILCO ROLL
TIDE UP I SIXTY SAID KNOWS.
THAT MEASURE. WE ARE TO PASS A
FILE ITEM TO SIX IN FIFTY SO.
THIS IS FILE ITEM. FIFTY EIGHT.
AB SEVEN. WE HAVE AMENDMENTS.
WE HAVE AMENDMENTS. BEFORE THE
BODY. MR GALLAGHER ON THE
AMENDMENTS. YES CERTAINLY I'M
SORRY CORKERY THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER SOME PEOPLE THIRTY
SEVEN WITH AMENDMENTS BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GALLAGHER SAID
WARM MR GALLAGHER ON THE
MINUTES THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER- AS MY COLLEAGUES KNOW
I AM A SUPPORTER OF MAIL BALLOT
VOTING HAS SUPPORTED THE BILL
LAST YEAR DURING. THE COVERED
NINETEEN PANDEMIC ANY
AMENDMENTS TO. THAT I BELIEVE
WILL MAKE THIS BILL BETTER.
WE'RE GONNA START DOING MAIL
BALLOTS ON EVERY ELECTION WE
ALSO NEED TO HELP INSURE BOTH
ACCESS AND INTEGRITY. OF THE
ELECTIONS PROCESS- SO THESE
AMENDMENTS WOULD ONE REPEAL THE
EXISTING LAW THAT ALLOWS ANY
PERSON. INCLUDING POLITICAL
OPERATIVES TO RETURN VOTERS BBM
BALLOTS. AND PROVIDES INSTEAD
THE ONLY FAMILY MEMBERS AND
ROOMMATES OF VOTERS MAY RETURN
THERE- VOTE BY MAIL BALLOT-
WHICH BY THE WAY WAS THE LAW
UNTIL. TWENTY SEVENTEEN- NUMBER
TWO THIS DELETES LANGUAGE IN
THE BILL. THAT WOULD ALLOW
ELECTION OFFICIALS TO COUNTY
BOARD VOTE BY MAIL BALLOTS THAT
ARRIVE UP TO SEVEN DAYS AFTER
THE ELECTION AND INSTEAD MAKE
IT THREE DAYS WHICH WAS AND HAS
BEEN- THE ELECTION LAW. AND
THEN THIRTY CLARIFIES THAT
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS SHALL NOT
MAIL VOTE BY. VOTE BY MAIL
BALLOTS TO VOTERS WITH AN AN
ACTIVE REGISTRATION STATUS AND
WE SAW THAT IN THIS LAST
ELECTION MANY BALLOTS WENT OUT
TO PEOPLE WHO HAD ALREADY
MOVED. HAD MOVED TO DIFFERENT
COUNTIES A MOVE TO DIFFERENT
STATES. IN MANY CASES- AND SO
WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT BALLOTS
ARE ONLY GOING TO ACTIVE
REGISTERED VOTERS SO THE IS A
REASONABLE COMMONSENSE.
AMENDMENTS THAT WILL ENSURE THE
INTEGRITY OF THE MAIL BALLOT
PROCESS. I IN THE FUTURE AND I
WOULD ASK MY COLLEAGUES
SUPPORT. FOR THESE REASONABLE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU. THIS RACE.
MISTER SPEAKER I MOVE TO THE
LADY IN THE ON THE MISS RACES
MOVING THE LADY MEMBERS THE
TABLE BY MISTER GAVE. MEMBERS
IS A PRETTY VOTE LADY BY IT'S
ON THE MUCH PRESS VOTING. IS
THE THRESHOLD CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ISRAEL'S IS ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE SHOULD GALA IS
ASKING FOR A NOVA. TO THE ON
THE TABLE. MAJORITY FOR A VOTE.
CLERK WILL. CLOSE ALL EYES
FORTY KNOWS SO. THE MEMBERS ARE
LAID ON THE. WE HAVE ADDITIONAL
AMENDMENTS. MISTER SAY ARE TELL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER ON THE
AMENDMENTS THIS COMMON AND
PARTNER. SOME BILL THIRTY SEVEN
WITH MINUTES A SOME MEMBER SAY
CLOSE TO MR SAYRE TELL. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER THIS
COMMONSENSE NON AMEND REQUIRES
REGISTRY DON'T CHECK BY AT IN.
REFERENCES DEBRA FROM STAY AND
GO AGENTS. IF WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE YOUR GOING TO PER VOTE BY
MAIL WE TO IN MAN. THAT ENSURE
THAT OUR VOTER ROLLS ARE
ACCURATE AS POSSIBLE IT IS
POSITIVE FOR THOSE REASONS THAT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THANK YOU. MS RESTAURANT
PURPOSE I MOVED TO LOOK. TO THE
LADY AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE.
MISS REYES MOSTLY THE ON THE
TABLE SECOND BY MISTER GABRIEL.
MEMBERS THIS IS A PROCEDURAL
VOTE MAJORITY PRESIDENT VOTING
CARPAL OPEN THE ROLE. IS THAT
THE NINE VOTE. SURE ARTISTS
ASKING FOR A NOBLE. THIS IS
PROCEDURAL.
THIS IS PROCEDURAL.
YEAH CLARK WELL. CLOSE REAL
TIDE OF WHAT I SHOULD DO KNOWS
A- THE MEMBERS ARE LAID ON THE
TABLE. NOW TO THE AND SHE-
CORKERY. ASSEMBLY THIRTY SEVEN
BY SOME MEMBER FIRM AND- OTHERS
ENACT TO A LOT. THIS BERMAN YOU
MAY OPEN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND TO PER BOTH VOTERS
POLL WORKERS LAST YEAR I
AUTHORED AB EIGHT SIXTY WHICH
WAS A SUCCESSFUL BIPARTISAN
REGISTERED VOTER A BALLOT AMONG
OTHER PROVISIONS ACCORDING TO
THE SECRETARY OF STATE OVER
EIGHTY SIX POINT 5% OF THE
SEVENTEEN AND A HALF MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WHO PARTICIPATED
IN THE NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY
GENERAL ELECTION VOTED ON THE
BALLOT THAT WAS MAILED TO THEM.
DATA SHOWS THAT SENDING
EVERYONE A BALLOT IN THE MAIL
PROVIDES VOTERS ACCESS AND WHEN
VOTERS GET BALLOTS IN THE MAIL
THEY VOTE SB THIRTY SEVEN WILL
MAKE SOME OF THESE IMPROVEMENTS
PERMANENT ENSURING THAT EVERY
ACTIVE REGISTERED VOTERS MAIL
THE BALLOT FOR EVERY ELECTION
SIMILAR TO PROVISIONS IN MY
EIGHTY EIGHT SIXTY LAST YEAR SB
THIRTY SEVEN MAKES A NUMBER OF
IMPORTS OTHER IMPORTANT
CCOMMODATIONS TO HELP
FACILITATE VOTING BY MAIL IN
FUTURE ELECTIONS IT ALLOWS
COUNTIES TO BEGIN PROCESSING A
RETURN VOTE BY MAIL BALLOTS
EARLIER. SO THAT THEY CAN
BETTER MANAGE THEIR WORKLOAD TO
GET MORE BALLOTS COUNTED ON
ELECTION NIGHT AND ALSO EXTENDS
THE DEADLINE FOR RECEIPT OF
VOTE BY MAIL BALLOTS SO THAT
VOTERS ARE NOT DISENFRANCHISED
BY POTENTIAL POSTAL SERVICE%
DELAYS SB THIRTY SEVEN ALSO
ENSURES VOTERS CONTRACT THEIR
BALLOTS AS THEY MOVE THROUGH
THE MAIL SYSTEM INTERPROCESS BY
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS BERMAN.
MISTER SAY ARE TELL YOUR RECORD.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
REQUEST A FEW WE OPPOSE THIS
MEASURE- IN THE LAST TWO
ELECTIONS WE HAD SPECIAL
ELECTION. ONE IN DISTRICT
SEVENTY NINE WONDER DISTRICT
FIFTY FOUR. DISTRICT SEVENTY
NINE PRODUCED 21% OF THE VOTERS
THEY'RE ALL MAIL BALLOTS THERE
ARE THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND OF
MAIL BALLOTS SENT OUT. AND
THOSE BALLOTS COST TWO DOLLARS
AND FIFTY CENTS APIECE TO SEND
OUT. SO WHAT WE'VE DONE
BASICALLY WITH. WHERE IF YOU'RE
LOOKING AT THESE THESE NUMBERS.
IS FOR- FOR THE SEVENTY NINE TH
DISTRICT. SEVENTY NINE OUT OF A
HUNDRED BALLOTS GOT THROWN IN
THE TRASH. THAT MEANS THAT
MEANS. CLOSE TO THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS OF OUR
TAXPAYER DOLLARS WENT DIRECTLY
IN THE TRASH. FOR THE FIFTY
FOURTH DISTRICT IT WAS EVEN
WORSE. IT WAS 14% 14% THAT
MEANS. EIGHTY SIX OF A HUNDRED
BALLOTS WENT IN THE TRASH
THAT'S OUR TAXPAYER DOLLARS. SO
IT APPEARS THAT WHILE THIS MAY
WORK WELL IN SOME ELECTIONS IT
DOESN'T WORK WELL IN OTHERS AND
SO IF WE WANT TO REFORM. THIS
BALLOT ALSO IN ORDER TO GIVE
PEOPLE GREATER ACCESS IT
DOESN'T APPEAR THAT THIS IS THE
ONLY ANSWER AND WHAT I THINK WE
NEED TO DO IS WE NEED TO PUT A
COMMISSION TOGETHER STUDY THIS
FIGURE OUT WHAT WILL CREATE A
MORE JUST AND IN A BETTER
SYSTEM FOR PEOPLE TO VOTE. AND
AND THEN ENACT LAWS THAT WILL
DO THAT. BECAUSE THIS PIECEMEAL
APPROACH IS NOT WORKING. IT IS
NOT INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
BALLOTS BEING RETURNED IN THESE
PEOPLE HAVE THEIR BALLOTS AFTER
HOUSE THEY COULDN'T MARK ONE
SPOT AND SEND IT IN. SO THAT IS
NOT ACCESS TO BALLOTING IS NOT
THE PROBLEM HERE. WE NEED TO
LOOK AT THAT MORE CAREFULLY
FIND OT WHAT THE PROBLEM IS.
AND FIX THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR NO VOTE ON THIS. MR
GALLAGHER YOU'RE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN VERY
BRIEFLY IF WE WANT TO DO THIS
IN A BIPARTISAN MANNER THE SAME
WAY THAT WE DID LAST. LAST
YEAR. THEN WE SHOULD TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT BIPARTISAN INPUT. AND I
THINK WHAT WE WANT HERE IS AN
ELECTION SYSTEM THAT PROVIDES
GREATER ACCESS AND ABILITY FOR
PEOPLE TO. GET THEIR VOTE IN
AND MAIL BALLOT DOES THAT. BUT
ALSO ENSURING THE INTEGRITY. OF
THE VOTING HAVING REASONABLE
PROTECTIONS AGAINST THAT SUCH
AS INACTIVE VOTERS. ET YOU KNOW
GETTING SENT BALLOTS- SO I
DON'T. WITHOUT THESE READ
AMENDMENTS I CAN'T SUPPORT THIS
AS A BIPARTISAN. PROCESS FOR
MOVING FORWARD AND THAT'S
UNFORTUNATE THANK YOU. MR
BERMAN YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER I
APPRECIATE THE CONCERNS FROM MY
COLLEAGUE FROM MURRIETA. ABOUT
POTENTIAL WASTE IN ELECTIONS I
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
HIM TO SEE WHAT WE CAN DO TO
STOP THIS RECALL THIS
UNNECESSARY RECALL FROM
HAPPENING. WHICH IS GOING TO
WASTE FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN TAXPAYER MONEY. ON A
RECALL FOR SOMEBODY WHO WILL BE
ON THE BALLOT THE NEXT YEAR I
TOTALLY. IN UNNECESSARY WASTE
OF TAXPAYER DOLLARS TO MY
FRIEND FOR YUBA CITY WHEN IT
COMES TO THE ISSUE OF THE
INTEGRITY OF OUR ELECTIONS I
WANT TO APOLOGIZE TO
CALIFORNIANS I WANNA APOLOGIZE
TO CALIFORNIA VOTERS I KNOW.
TOO MANY OF THEM. HAVE LOST
FAITH IN OUR ELECTION SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE THEY HAVE
BEEN LIED TO. THEY HAVE BEEN
LIED TO INCESSANTLY THEY WERE
LIED TO BY FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP. THEY WERE LIED TO BY
FEDERAL ELECTED OFFICIALS THEY
WERE LIED TO BY SOME PEOPLE IN
THIS BUILDING. ABOUT THE
INTEGRITY OF OUR ELECTIONS IN
CALIFORNIA IN THE GREATEST
DEMOCRACY. IN THE WORLD AND IT
WE SHOULD MAKE SURE THAT EVERY
CALIFORNIA KNOWS THAT WHEN THEY
VOTE THEIR VOTE IS COUNTED. AND
THAT OUR ELECTIONS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE SECURE WE
CANNOT. PASS LEGISLATION AND
PASS POLICIES BASED ON LIES WE
CANNOT UNDERMINE OUR DEMOCRACY
AND AN INCREASE VOTER
SUPPRESSION LIKE THEY'RE DOING
IT TOO MANY STATES. ACROSS THE
COUNTRY BASED ON LIES AND I
KNOW. I RESPECTFULLY ASK MY
COLLEAGUES DO NOT LET LIES
IMPACT THE POLICIES THAT WE
PASSED IN THIS BUILDING WE NEED
TO MAKE IT. I WENT TO INCREASE
ACCESS TO THE BALLOT FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB THIRTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU MR BERMAN AND
WITH THAT. CIRCLE OF THE WORLD
ALL. IT IS OUT OF A ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. THE CLERK
WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF THAT I
FIFTY TWO. KNOWS FIFTEEN. THAT
MEASURE PASSES. THIS RARE S.
FOR WHAT PURPOSE THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER THERE IS A LIST
OF BILLS ON THIRD READING TODAY
THAT HAVE THE SUPPORT OF BOTH
CAUCUSES AND WE'VE AGREED TO
TAKE THEM UP IN ONE BATCH AND
THEN APPLY THE FIRST ROLL CALL
VOTE TO THESE BILLS I WOULD ASK
THE CLERK TO READ THE BILLS ON
THIS BATCH LIST AND THEN OPEN
THE ROLE. ON THE FIRST BILL.
MEMBERS PLEASE PAY CLOSE
ATTENTION AS A CLERK READS THE
LIST OF BILLS THAT HAVE BEEN
APPROVED TO BE PASSED. AS A
BATCH AGAIN THESE BILLS HAVE
THE SUPPORT OF BOTH CAUCUSES.
YOU'LL NOT NEED TO PRESENT. ON
THESE ITEMS THE CLERK WILL READ.
I'M SIXTY EIGHT ASSEMBLY BOW
NINETY EIGHT FRAZIER ITEM SIXTY
NINE ASSEMBLY WILL NINETY NINE
IRWIN ITEM SEVENTY THREE
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE OF SIX
DOLLARS ITEM EIGHTY FORCING
PEOPLE TO FORTY RODRIGUEZ ITEM
NINETY ASSEMBLY BILL TWO EIGHTY
SEVEN COURT. AT A NINETY FOUR
SOME PEOPLE THREE THIRTEEN
CRISTINA GARCIA AT A NINETY
FIVE ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
FIFTEEN STONE ITEM NINETY SEVEN
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE TWENTY FIVE
OR WHEN I TO NINETY EIGHT
ASSEMBLY WILL THREE THIRTY ONE
JONES SAWYER ITEM NINETY NINE
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE FORTY WARD.
I DON'T WANT TO ONE ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE FORTY FIVE QUICK
SILVA ADAM ONE OF THREE
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE FIFTY SIX
CHEN ITEMONE OF SIX ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE THREE SALAS I DON'T
WANT TO WAIT ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE NINETY SIX CABLE ADAM ONE
THIRTEEN ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
SEVENTEEN MCCARTY. ADAM ONE
FIFTEEN A SINGLE FOR THIRTY
SEVEN KALRA ITEM ONE EIGHTEEN A
SYMBOL FOR FIFTY GONZALEZ ADAM
ONE TWENTY FIVE ASSEMBLY BILL
FORTY THREE JONES SAWYER ITEM
ONE TWENTY SIX ASSEMBLY WILL
FORTY SIX EDUCATION COMMITTEE
ITEM ONE TWENTY NINE ASSEMBLY
BEFORE NINETY EIGHT QUICK
SILVA. AND ONE THIRTY FOR SOME
PEOPLE FIVE FIXING FIVE SIXTEEN
DALLI- ITEM ONE FORTY SIX
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE SIXTY FIVE
LACKEY ADAM ONE FORTY SEVEN
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE SEVENTY SIX
MAIENSCHEIN AND ONE FIFTY ONE A
SYMBOL SIX OH TWO GRAYSON ITEM
ONE FIFTY EIGHT A SINGLE SIX
FIFTY THREE WALDRON. ITEM ONE
SIXTY NINE A SYMBOL SEVEN FORTY
FOUR RODRIGUEZ I DON'T WANT
SEVENTY FIVE ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTY ONE DALY I DON'T WANT
SEVENTY SIX ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTY SEVEN CABLE I DON'T
WANT SEVENTY EIGHT A SYMBOL
IT'LL SEVEN GRAYSON ITEM ONE
EIGHTY FIVE ASSEMBLY BILL A
SIXTY FIVE CORK SILVA. I DON'T
WANT TO BE SEVEN ASSEMBLE EIGHT
EIGHTY SEVEN LEVINE ADAM ONE
NINETY NINE A SIMPLE NINE SIXTY
FIVE LEVINE ITEM TWO HUNDRED
ASSEMBLY ONE NINE SEVEN SEVEN
GABLES ITEM TOOLS SIX OR SOME
PEOPLE TO KNOW THREE
CONSOLIDATES. ATTEMPT TO
ALREADY TO SOME LEGAL TEN
FIFTEEN WHAT ROUTE RUBIO ITEM
TO TENNYSON MIDDLE TEN THIRTY
THREE BARRICADE HAND. ITEM TO
EIGHTEEN ASSEMBLY WILL TENDED
TO WALDRON ITEM TO TWENTY SIX
ASSEMBLY BILL OF ELEVEN BERMAN
AND IN TWO THIRTY SEVENTHS
IMAGE BILL ELEVEN EIGHTY FIVE
SERVE ARTISTS ADAM TO SIXTY ONE
A SINGLE THIRTEEN FIFTY SEVEN
CERVANTES. ITEM TO SUCCEED
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN TWENTY
THREE DOLLARS I AM TO SIXTY
NINE ASSEMBLY WILL FOURTEEN
TWENTY NINE HOLDEN BUT IN TWO
SEVENTY SIX ASSEMBLY BILL
FOURTEEN SIXTY FIVE. REYES ITEM
TO READY TO ASSEMBLE FIFTEEN
THIRTY TWO BUSINESS. A
PROFESSION COMMITTEE I'M FORTY
FOUR SO THE BILL FIFTEEN
THIRTY. BUSINESSES PROFESSION.
ITEM TWENTY FIVE ASSEMBLY BILL.
THIRTY FIVE AS A PROFESSOR
COMMITTEE. AND IT ITEM TO
RELEASE ASSEMBLY WILL FIFTEEN
TO SIX BY. OF COMMITTEE. WITH
OBJECTION. THE CALL WILL NOW
READ THE FIRST BILL WE OPEN
ROLE. SEPARATE ASSEMBLY BILL
NINETY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRAZIER AN ACT RELATING TO
HEALTH CARE THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
WISH TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTER
WISH TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF
THE. WHO WISH TO VOTE. ALL OF
THESE. YEAH. CLARK WELL. ALL
MEMBERS HEARD WHICH TO VOTE.
WELL. CLOSE ROLE. TODD OF I
SEVENTY ONE NO. ZERO THE CLERK
WILL NOW READ THE REMAINING
ITEMS. ASSEMBLY- NINETY NINE I
SEVEN ONE NINE ZERO ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE OH SIX I SEVENTY ONE
NO ZERO SOME PEOPLE TO FORTY I
SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO SOME PEOPLE
TO EIGHTY SEVEN I SEVENTY ONE
OH ZERO SOME PEOPLE THREE
THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE OH ZERO
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE FIFTEEN I
SEVENTY ONE NOW AT ZERO
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTY ONE OH ZERO ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE THIRTY ONE WITH
URGENCY AS ANYONE KNOWS YOU'RE
ON THE URGENCY AS EVERYONE
KNOWS YOU'RE ON THE BILL SOME
PEOPLE THREE FORTY. I SEVEN ONE
NINE ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
FORTY FIVE I SEVENTY ONE NO
ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL THREE FIFTY
SIX I SEVENTY ONE DOWN ZERO
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE EIGHTY
THREE I SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE NINETY SIX
SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO ASSEMBLY
BEFORE SEVENTEEN I SEVENTY ONE
NO ZERO SOME PEOPLE FOR THIRTY
SEVEN I SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO SUM
BEFORE FIFTY I SEVENTY ONE NO
ZERO SUM WE GO FORTY THREE I
SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO SUM WE GO
FORTY SIX I SEVENTY ONE THOSE
ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR NINETY
EIGHT I SEVENTY ONE OH ZERO
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE SIXTEEN.
SEVENTY ONE OH ZERO ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE SIXTY FIVE SEVENTY
ONE NO ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
SEVENTY SIX SEVENTY ONE THOSE
ARE AWESOME PEOPLE SIX OH TWO I
SEVENTY ONE ZERO SUM ZERO SIX
FIFTY THREE I SEVENTY ONE OH
ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN FORTY
FOUR I SEVENTY ONE THOSE ARE
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY ONE I.
SEVENTY ONE DOES YOUR ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVENTY SEVEN I SEVENTY
ONE NO ZERO ASSEMBLY GO IT'LL
SEVEN FIVE SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO
ASSEMBLY BILL HE SIXTY FIVE I.
SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO ASSEMBLY
BILL. SEVEN FIVE SEVEN ONE
THOSE ARE ASSEMBLY WILL NINE
SIXTY FIVE I SEVENTY ONE NO 0%
BILL NINE SEVEN I SEVENTY ONE
THOSE SOME PEOPLE TEND OF THREE
I SEVENTY ONE ZERO SO PEOPLE
TEND- SO ONE ZERO WE GO TO
THIRTY THREE I SEVENTY ONE NOW
ZERO WE GO TO EIGHTY TWO I SAW
ONE THOSE ARE SUM WE GO A LOT I
SEVENTY ONE ZERO WE WILL LET IN
EIGHTY FIVE FIVE. ONE ZERO SOME
PEOPLE FOR SEVEN FIVE ONE THOSE
SUM BEFORE TWENTY THREE I
SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO SOME PEOPLE.
FOURTEEN TO NINE THIRTY ONE
ZERO SOME PEOPLE TO FIVE HI
SEVENTY ONE OF ZERO PEOPLE
FIFTH THIRTY TWO. SEVENTY ONE
DOES YOUR ASSEMBLY FIFTEENTH
FOUR I SEVENTY ONE NOW AT.
ZERO
MEMBERS WE ARE BACK IN FILE
ORDER. THIS IS FILE ITEM SIXTY
ONE AB FIFTY SIX BY MR SALLIS
CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTY
SIX BY SUMMER SALAS AND OTHERS
IMMACULATE IN THE BENEFITS.
THIS IS CHELSEA MAY OPEN. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER REMEMBER AT
TO I RISE TO PRESENT BILL SO
WHAT WILL AND A NUMBER OF
COMPREHENSIVE REFORMS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDT- MEMBERS I
DON'T NEED TO TELL YOU OF ALL
OF THE HEARINGS AND EVERYTHING
WE'VE DISCUSSED AND SOME OF THE
PROBLEMS. THAT ARE OCCURRING
OVER A DVD BUT I DO WANT TO
THANK- THE TWENTY THREE CO
AUTHORS IN A BIPARTISAN FASHION
THAT ARE SIGNED ON TO THIS BILL
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR RIVAL
THIS SPEAKER. THANK AYE SALAS
SENIOR. OR DEBATE MISTER KILEY
IS WAY AT ME. MR KILEY ARE. IN
THE REAR OF CHAMBER. I THANK
MISTER SPEAKER I'M GONNA
SUPPORT THIS I THINK THE
MEASURES- WILL HELP I'M NOT
SURE HOW MUCH GOOD THERE ARE
ULTIMATELY GOING TO DO BUT I
THINK THAT WE NEED TO PAUSE FOR
A SECOND AND JUST TAKE A LOOK
AT THE PROCESS THAT HAS GOTTEN
US YEAR. AFTER MORE THAN A YEAR
OF ABJECT FAILURE AT THE EDT WE
EVENTUALLY GET A STATE AUDIT
WHICH EVENTUALLY PRODUCES SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS WHICH IS ARE
NOW BEING- IMPLEMENTED OR BEING
CODIFIED THROUGH AN ACTIVE
LEGISLATION AND THEN HOPEFULLY
WE'LL BE IMPLEMENTED OVER THE
EDT IT'S REALLY BORING THE LINE
BETWEEN LEGISLATION AND
MANAGEMENT THE WAY THAT IT
OUGHT TO WORK IS THAT WE OUGHT
TO HAVE. LEGISLATIVE GOALS FOR
THE TIMELY AND- ACCURATE
DELIVERY OF UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS AND WE OUGHT TO
PROVIDE OUR STATE AGENCIES WITH
THE TOOLS THAT ARE NEEDED FOR
EFFECTIVE MANAGEMENT BUT THE
STATE AUDITOR IN OUR HEARING ON
THIS ISSUE. I SAID THAT THE
MANAGEMENT AT THAT AGENCY IS A
PART OF THE PROBLEM AND THE
FACT OF THE MATTER IS WE HAVE
AN OUTDATED CIVIL SERVICE
SYSTEM- WITH. MANY. OTHER RISK.
LAYERED ON. PEOPLE WHO ARE
THRIVING TO TERMINATE PEOPLE
WHO ARE DOING THEIR JOBS TO PAY
PEOPLE MORE IF THEY'RE TAKING
ON MORE RESPONSIBILITY TO.
CONTRACT WITH THE BEST
PROVIDERS IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR
THAT'S WHAT IT'LL TAKE TO HAVE
A MORE MODERN- AND EFFECTIVE
AND EFFICIENT STATE BUREAUCRACY
AND THE FACT IS WITH THE AMOUNT
OF WEALTH AND HUMAN RESOURCES
AND TALENT THAT OUR STATE HAS
AT ITS DISPOSAL THERE IS SIMPLY
NO REASON THAT CALIFORNIANS
SHOULD HAVE TO SETTLE FOR
SUBSTANDARD SERVICE. MISS
VALLADARES YOUR RECORD MEMBERS
I RISE TODAY AS A PROUD CO
AUTHOR OF AB FIFTY SIX SINCE I
WAS SWORN IN AT NEARLY A
THOUSAND ONE THOUSAND
CONSTITUENTS HAVE REACHED OUT
TO ME TO HELP WITH THEIR EDT
CLAIMS FOR MORE THAN A YEAR
OVER A MILLION CALIFORNIANS
HAVE BEEN UNEMPLOYED AND UNABLE
TO RECEIVE A MUCH NEEDED
ASSISTANCE. WHY IS THIS
HAPPENING THE REASON IS SIMPLE
WE HAVE A BLOATED INSUFFICIENT
AND COMPLETELY MISSED
MANAGEMENT MISMANAGED
GOVERNMENT AGENCY THAT IS
INCAPABLE OF SELF REFORM. THE
GOVERNOR PUT OUT A TASK FORCE
THAT CAME BACK WITH NO
SIGNIFICANT OR DRASTIC REFORMS
EITHER AND GUESS WHAT. THE
PROBLEM GOT WORSE NOT BETTER.
MEMBERS IT IS WHY IT IS WAY
PAST TIME THAT WE START HOLDING
EDT ACCOUNTABLE THE LIVELIHOODS
OF MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS ARE
AT STAKE AB FIFTY SIX MAKES
COMMONSENSE REFORMS TO HELP THE
PEOPLE WHO NEED IT MOST I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK IMAGE RATHER.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS YES MS
GONZALEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU- MISTER SPEAKER I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AS
A PROUD JOINT AUTHORS ON THE
BILL I THINK THAT ALL OF THESE
EDIE REFORMS THAT WERE PASSING
THROUGH ARE NECESSARY AND
IMPORTANT- OBVIOUSLY IN MY
OFFICE WE'VE HELPED OVER SIX
THOUSAND PEOPLE IN THE LAST
YEAR ON IT WITH EDT AND I KNOW
ALL OF OUR STAFF. ARE WORKING
HARD I JUST WANT TO POINT OUT
THOUGH I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THOSE PEOPLE WHO ARE ACTUALLY
DOING THE WORK AT EDT. REALIZE
WE APPRECIATE THE WORK THEY ARE
DOING THIS IS NOT THEIR FAILURE
IT IS A FAILURE OF A SYSTEM IT
IS A FAILURE OF. US IT IS A
FAILURE OF THE STATE BUT THOSE
WORKERS GO TO WORK EVERY DAY
WORK EXTREMELY HARD. THAT THAT
EDT IN GENERAL IS UNDER STAFFED
NOT BLOATED NOT OVERSTAFFED IN
WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
RECOGNIZING THE HARD WRK OF
OUR STATE EMPLOYEES AS WELL IN
WITHOUT AYE ASPIRIN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS GONZALEZ SEE NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION. MR
SALIHUMAKE CLOSE THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER TO MY COLLEAGUES
I SPOKE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS- AND POOR PIECE
OF LEGISLATION YOU KNOW I LIKE
MANY CALIFORNIANS ARE
FRUSTRATED WITH WHAT'S
HAPPENING AT THE D. D. THIS ONE
ACT THOSE COMPREHENSIVE REFORM
SO THAT WE COULD BRING SOME
RELIEF TO SO MANY CALIFORNIANS
THAT ARE SUFFERING RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. FAMOUS
CELLS WITHOUT CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS. THE
SERVER ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THAT
A VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
ESERVER. WELL CLOTHES ARE ALL.
TYLER I SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE ARE GOING
TO MOVE TO TAKE A FILE ITEM
SEVENTY. THIS IS MR HOLDEN'S
MEASURE FILE ITEM SEVENTY AB
ONE HUNDRED. THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL ONE HUNDRED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN AND
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE INTO
DRINKING WATER MR HOLDING.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB ONE
HUNDRED WOULD ESTABLISH A LEAD
LEACHING PERFORMANCE STANDARD
FOR FAUCETS AND FIXTURES TO
ALLOW THEM TO BE CONSIDERED
LEAD FREE. THEY WERE REQUIRE IN
USE FIXTURES TO LEASE LESS THAN
ONE MILLIGRAM PER LITER OF
LEAD. RECENTLY AND S. F.
INTERNATIONAL TESTED FIVE
HUNDRED FAUCETS THAT MEET
CURRENT CALIFORNIA LEAD CONTENT
STANDARD AND FOUND THE 25% OF
THE FAUCETS LEACH NOTICEABLE
AMOUNTS OF LEAD. CALIFORNIA HAS
BEEN WORKING TO REDUCE
RESIDENTS EXPOSURE TO LED YET
IT IS STILL LEACHING INTO OUR
DRINKING WATER THROUGH FAUCETS
AND FIXTURES SCHOOLS INSTRUCTED
SCHOOLS AND CHILDCARE CENTRES.
ARE WORKING ESPECIALLY HARD AS
SPENDING PUBLIC DOLLARS TO
LOWER LEAD LEVELS IN THEIR
DRINKING WATER. THIS BILL WILL
REQUIRE ALL FAUCETS AND
FIXTURES TO LEECH AS LITTLE AS
POSSIBLE. LAST YEAR MY
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR BILL AB
TWENTY SIXTY PASSED THIS FLOOR
WITHOUT NO VOTES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE. THANK YOU
MISS HOLDEN. SAY NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM CARPOOL
OVER THE ROLE. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
THOSE. ALL MEMBERS OF. THE
SERVER. BURKE WELL. CLOSE ROLE
TELEVOTE SIZE FORTY FIVE. NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES. THE
TERM. THANK YOU. MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO GO BACK TO ONE OF THE
BATCH ITEMS THAT HAS AN URGENCY
CLAUSE TO MAKE PICK UP THAT
VOTE ON THE URGENCY THIS IS
FILE ITEM TO THIRTY SEVEN.
HARPER READ. SOME REAL OF AN
EIGHTY FIVE WITH URGENCY BY SIN
REMEMBER CERVNTES I SEVENTY
ONE NO ZERO ON THE URGENCY I
SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO ON THE
MEASURE. MEMBERS WE ARE BACK
IN. REGULAR FILE ORDER. THIS IS
FILE ITEM SIXTY THREE AB
SEVENTY TWO CORRECT ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVENTY TWO BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS AND OTHERS
AN ACCOLADE TO ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION IS PETRIE-NORRIS
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT FOR AB SEVENTY TWO
WHICH WILL CUT GREEN TAPE FOR
COASTAL ADAPTATION PROGRAMS ON
THE CALIFORNIA COAST. COASTAL
ADAPTATION EFFORTS FACE MANY
CHALLENGES INCLUDING A LACK OF
AVAILABLE RESOURCES HIGH COST
AND OFTEN A VERY HIGHLY
COMPLICATED APPROVAL PROCESS
FOR BECAUSE A LOT OF TATIAN
PROJECTS IN OUR OWN AGENCIES AT
THE GOAL OF THIS BILL IS TO CUT
BACK GREEN TAPE IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT TIME TALENT. AND
RESOURCES ARE SPENT ON
SOLUTIONS TO PROTECT THE
CALIFORNIA COAST INSTEAD OF
BUREAUCRACY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR I'VE EVER. THANK YOU THE
SPEECH IN OURS SAME
NOTIFICATION OF IT ON THE ADAM
QUICKLAW MORAL. DESERVE IT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRABLE. FOR
TWELVE CULTURAL TELEVOTE I.
SIXTY SIX KNOWS ONE. THAT
MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE GOING TO
PASS RETAIN UP OUT OF SIXTY
FOUR THIS IS FILE ITEM SIXTY
FIVE. AB SEVENTY EIGHT BY
MISTER O'DONNELL. ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER O'DONNELL AND OTHERS IN
THAT RELATING TO THE SAN
GABRIEL AND LOWER LOS ANGELES
RIVERS AND MOUNTAINS
CONSERVANCY. MISTER DALI MAY
OPEN MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE TO PRESENT AB SEVENTY
EIGHT WHICH WILL EXPAND THE
TERRITORY. OF THE SAN GABRIEL
RIVER IN LOWER LOS ANGELES
RIVERS AND MOUNTAINS
CONSERVANCY TO INCLUDE THE
DOMINGUEZ CHANNEL WATERSHED AND
CATALINA ISLAND. THIS WILL
ALLOW THE CONSERVANCY TO HELP
THESE TERRITORIES PRESERVE AND
INCREASE ACCESS TO THEIR OPEN
SPACE AREAS AND WILDLIFE
HABITATS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
DOWN SAYING NO DISCUSSION. ON
THE ADAM CARCLUB RURAL. THESE
ARE VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT
OF A- ALL MEMBERS OF. RESIDE
ABOUT. CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL
TIDE ABOUT I. SIXTY FOUR NO
ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES THIS
IS FILE ITEM SIXTY SIX. AB
NINETY TWO BY MS RAVES CORKERY.
SOME PEOPLE NINETY TWO BY
ASSUMING MARIA'S AND OTHERS AND
AFTER LEADING TO EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION MISS RAY S.
YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I PRESENT TO
YOU AB NINETY TO A BILL THAT
WILL MAKE CHILD CARE MORE
AFFORDABLE TO WORKING FAMILIES.
AB NINETY TWO WILL ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES BY UTILIZING
FEDERAL FUNDING TO WHERE YOUR
FAMILY FEES THROUGH SEPTEMBER
OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO FOR ALL
FAMILIES THIS BILL WILL ALSO
CONVENE A WORK GROUP TO DEVELOP
AN EQUITABLE SLIDING SCALE FOR
FAMILY FEES THAT BETTER
REFLECTS FAMILIES BUDGETS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. I THINK IT IS REYES
SENIOR DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM
CLICK LIBERAL. THIS WHAT IS
THAT A VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS OF.
RESETTABLE THE CLERK WILL THOSE
ARE ALL TIED BUT I SIXTY EIGHT.
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
THIS IS. MISTER IS THERE.
THAT'S NOT NECESSARY RUSSIA'S.
SORRY.
MEMBERS THIS IS FILE
ITEM SIXTY SEVEN. AB NINETY
SEVEN BY MISTER NAZARIAN
CORKERY SOME PEOPLE NINETY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AARON
AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE
HEALTHCARE COVERAGE MR THIS
AREA YOU MAY OPEN. MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES A. B.
NINETY SEVEN WOULD PROHIBIT
HEALTH HEALTH PLANS BEGINNING
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY TWO FROM
IMPOSING A DEDUCTIBLE ON AN
INSULIN PRESCRIPTION- WE KNOW
THAT OVER FOUR MILLION
CALIFORNIANS SUFFER FROM
DIABETES AND FOR MANY
CALIFORNIANS WITH DIABETES
INSULIN IS AN ESSENTIAL PART.
OF A HEALTHY LIFE HOWEVER
BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND AND SEVEN
AND TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
DURING THAT ELEVEN YEAR PERIOD
COLLEAGUES. THE PRICE OF
INSULIN HAS INCREASED OVER TWO
HUNDRED AND 62% YOU HEARD IT
CORRECTLY TWO HUNDRED AND 62%
THIS SKYROCKETING PRICE IS
UNTENABLE OFTEN CAUSING UNDUE
BURDEN ON OUR HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM AND FORCING MANY WHO
CAN'T AFFORD THEIR MEDICINE TO
SELF RATION. AND LATER BEING
ADMITTED TO EMERGENCY ROOMS
WHICH DRIVES UP OUR HEALTHCARE
COSTS WITHOUT COLLEAGUES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON A. B. NINETY SEVEN.
THANK YOU MISTER NAZARIAN
MISTER CUNNINGHAM YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES I JUST LIKE
TO SHARE PERSONAL ANECDOTES
THAT'S MAY BE RELEVANT TO YOUR
CONSIDERATION THIS BILL. I GET
THAT IMPOSES A COST- I DON'T
TALK ABOUT ON THE FLOOR MUCH
BUT ONE OF MY DAUGHTER'S TYPE
ONE DIABETICS USE DIAGNOSIS AT
AGE SIX SHE IS NOW FOURTEEN.
AND UNDERSTAND PLEASE THAT FOR
TYPE ONE DIABETICS INSULIN IS
NOT OPTIONAL. IF YOU DON'T GET
IT YOU DON'T LIVE. ROUGON PENCE
THE CONVERGENCE ONE WITH THE
SHOT IF YOU'RE HAVING SERIOUS
LOW ARE NOT OPTIONAL IF YOU
DON'T HAVE IT. YOU DIE. AND
MISTER IS THERE IS COMPLETELY
RIGHT ABOUT THE SKYROCKETING
PRICE AT ONE TIME I WENT TO
PICK UP A PRESCRIPTION AT
WALGREENS IT WAS AN ANTHEM
PRESCRIPTION. WAITED THROUGH
THIS FIFTEEN MINUTE LINE GET TO
THE FRONT OF IT THE PHARMACIST
SAYS THAT'LL BE NINE HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY DOLLARS. HELLO I AM
GOING TO SHARON'S AN LIKE YOU
GOT THE WRONG GUY- IT TURNS OUT
THAT. THE GENERIC THAT WAS
COVERED HAVE BEEN SWITCHED BY
THE INSURANCE CARRIER WITHOUT.
NOTICE TO US. AND WE GOT IT
WORKED OUT BUT I WAS THINKING
ABOUT THAT AS I WAS LOOKING AT
THIS BILL. AND WELL IT WOULDN'T
MAYBE FIX THAT. IT WILL HELP
OUT FAMILIES WHO ARE TRYING TO
RAISE KIDS AND OTHER PEOPLE
THAT HAVE AN INSULIN DEPENDENT
DIABETIC IN THEIR FAMILY. AND
HELP DEFRAY SOME OF THE
EXORBITANT COSTS AND MY HOPE IS
WE CAN CONTINUE THIS WORK TO
FIGURE OUT. WHY IT IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT HAS. BEEN ON THE
MARKET AND EXISTED FOR DECADES.
OKAY IS SEEN. TWO HUNDRED AND
60% PRICE INCREASES IN A DECADE
WHICH IS. ASTRONOMICAL
PHENOMENAL SO I APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL AND I THINK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING IT.
PERSONALLY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISS CUNNINGHAM MISS CLARK
SILVA IN THE REAR CHAMBER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. MEMBERS I ALSO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB NINETY
SEVEN THIS ISSUE AS FAR AS
BEING DIABETIC IS SOMETHING
THAT WE SAW FIRST HAND DURING
THE COLD AND WITH MANY MANY OF
OUR LATINO FAMILIES AND
NEIGHBORS NOT ONLY SUFFERING
FROM CHRONIC. CONDITIONS BUT
DYING DREAM KOVEN DIABETES IS
SOMETHING THAT PLAGUES OUR
LATINO COMMUNITY WE NEED MORE
EDUCATION BUT WE CERTAINLY NEED
TO FOCUS ON COST ADJUSTMENTS SO
THAT THOSE WHO ARE SUFFERING
CAN INDEED GET THEIR MEDICATION
AT A FAIR PRICE I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR AB NINETY SEVEN.
THANK YOU MISS CLARK SILVA.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION. MISTER NAZARIAN
YOU MAY CLOSE IF YOU WISH.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
WOULD ACTUALLY TAKE D. MY
CLOSING COMMENTS TO BE THE
WORDS OF MY COLLEAGUES FROM
ORANGE COUNTY AND FROM THE
CENTRAL COAST VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THEIR SUPPORT AND-
AT THEIR PERSONAL WORDS IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AS WELL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
NAZARIAN WITH THAT CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS ARE TO VOTE FOR TWELVE.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT. HIGHS
FIFTY EIGHT NO ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES. MOVING TO TAKE
A FILE ITEM. SEVENTY ONE THIS
IS B ONE OH ONE BY MR MEDINA
FOR COREY. ASSEMBLY BILL ONE A
ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA
AND OTHERS AND AFTER LETTING
THE PEOPLE INSTRUCTION. MR
MEDINA YOU MAY OPEN. THANK YOU
MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS TODAY I
RISE TO PRESENT AB ONE OH ONE.
TWO DAYS AGO MARK ONE YEAR.
SINCE THE DEATH OF GEORGE FLOYD.
AT THE HANDS OF THE MINNEAPOLIS
POLICEMAN. HAD IT NOT BEEN FOR
THE NINE MINUTE TWENTY NINE
SECONDS VIDEO OF THE POLICE
OFFICER WITH HIS KNEE ON GEORGE
FLOYD'S KNACK. WE WOULD NOT BE
HERE TODAY. TALKING ABOUT
MAKING ETHNIC STUDIES A
GRADUATION REQUIREENT FOR ALL
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS. THE MORE
THE MURDER OF GEORGE FLOYD.
LIKE THE MURDER OF EMMETT TEEL
SIXTY SIX YEARS AGO. FOREVER
CHANGE THE WAY THAT MANY
AMERICANS LOOK AT THIS COUNTRY
AND THIS COUNTRY'S PAST HISTORY.
AS TENS OF THOUSANDS OF YOUNG
PEOPLE MARCHED ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES. DECLARING THE
BLACK LIVES MATTER. CALLING FOR
JUSTICE AND POLICE REFORM HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA.
ORGANIZED IN GROUPS LIKE CHEN
UP. AND DEBT DIVERSIFY OUR
NARRATIVE RAISE THEIR VOICES
DEMANDING MORE THAN JUST THE
SAME EUROCENTRIC CURRICULUM.
THE HIGH SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA
HAVE ALWAYS TAUGHT. HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS TODAY LIKE YOUNG
CHICANO STUDENTS IN NINETEEN
SIXTY EIGHT WHO WALKED OUT OF
THERE HE'S STILL A HIGH SCHOOL.
WANT TO SEE THEMSELVES
REFLECTED IN HISTORY NOVELS
POETRY DRAMA THAT IS TAUGHT IN
HIGH SCHOOL. AFTER MORE THAN
FIFTY YEARS SINCE THE BEGINNING
OF THE FIELD OR DISCIPLINE OF
ETHNIC STUDIES OUR KNOWLEDGE
AND UNDERSTANDING OF THE PAST
IS MUCH RICHER. BUT WE INSIST
ON TEACHING THE SAME OLD EURO
CENTRIC. CURRICULUM. HOW MANY
TIMES HAVE WE HEARD COLLEGE
STUDENTS THAT'S WHY THEY HAVE
HAD TO WAIT TILL THEY GOT TO
COLLEGE TO LEARN MORE ABOUT
THEIR OWN HISTORY. AND CULTURE.
LAST WEEK IN AN ARTICLE IN THE
HILL. TITLED SPIKE IN ANTI
ASIAN HATE. COULD LEAD TO COULD
LEAD TO SYSTEMIC CHANGE IN
SCHOOLS. DR LOUIS ONE A
PROFESSOR AT AMERICAN
UNIVERSITY LAMENTED. HOW MANY
STUDENTS COME TO HER CLASSROOM
AND READ ASIAN AMERICAN
LITERATURE FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN THEIR LIVES. AND SON START
THE CLASS AND AWARE. OF THE
HISTORICAL EVENTS. SUCH AS THE
CHINESE EXCLUSION ACT FOR
JAPANESE INTERNMENT CAMPS. DR
WON SAID THAT THE LACK OF
KNOWLEDGE IS WHAT MAKES IT
DIFFICULT FOR MANY AMERICANS TO
CONCEPTUALIZE THE MANY IS SO
DENSE OF VIOLENCE THAT WE HAVE
RECENTLY WITNESSED. IT'S TIME
WE LISTEN. TO THE VOICES OF OUR
STUDENTS. AND TO THE PROFESSORS
CALLING FOR ETHNIC STUDIES. I
ASK YOU TO VOTE HI ON AB ONE OH
ONE. TO REQUIRE HIGH SCHOOLS TO
PROVIDE ETHNIC STUDIES
BEGINNING IN ACADEMIC YEAR.
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY SIX AND THAT STUDENTS
TAKE AT LEAST ONE SEMESTER OF
IT EIGHT THREE G. APPROVED
ETHNIC STUDIES COURSE TO
GRADUATE STARTING IN TWENTY.
TWENTY NINE THIRTY. REMEMBER IT
IS NEVER TOO LATE TO DO THE
RIGHT THING. MEMBERS ASK YOU
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MR
MEDINA MISTER DAVID CHIU YOUR
RECOGNITION THE REAR. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER COLLEAGUES I
RISE TODAY IS A PROUD JOIN
AUTHOR OF AB ONE A ONE AND LET
ME START BY THANKING THE DOCKET
LEADERSHIP OF OUR HIGHER
EDUCATION COMMITTEE CHAIR. FOR
API COMMUNITIES ASIAN AMERICAN
STUDIES HAVE BEEN CRITICAL TO
DISPELLING THE MODEL MINORITY
MYTH AND OTHER STEREOTYPES.
ALLOWED US TO SHARE THE
INCREDIBLE SPECTRUM OF
EXPERIENCES WITHIN OUR DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES EDUCATED THE NEXT
GENERATION OF CALIFORNIANS IN
THE HISTORY OF STRUGGLES THEIR
COMMUNITIES HAVE GRAPPLE WITH.
ETHNIC STUDIES HAVE INTRODUCED
NEW PERSPECTIVES HAVE HELP
STUDENTS DEVELOP CRITICAL
THINKING SKILLS HAVE HAD A
LASTING AND DEMONSTRATED
POSITIVE ACADEMIC AND SOCIAL
IMPACT ON STUDENTS. AND I WOULD
SAY LIKE MANY OF US ON THIS
FLOOR. THESE ARE DISCIPLINES
THAT HAVE SHAPED WHO I AM. I
WOULD HAVE BECOME AN ACTIVIST A
CIVIL RIGHTS ATTORNEY A RUN FOR
OFFICE IF I HAD NOT LEARNED
ABOUT THE CHINESE EXCLUSION ACT
AND JAPANESE AMERICAN
INTERNMENT OR THE MURDER
VINCENTIAN. AND DURING THIS
TIME PERIOD OF ANTI ASIAN HATE.
IT DEMONSTRATES HOW IMPORTANT
THIS EDUCATION S. HOW NECESSARY
IT IS IT'S NOT OPTIONAL IT'S
NECESSARY. FOR REPEALING THE
MULTI ETHNIC FOR REPAIRING THE
MULTI ETHNIC SOCIAL FABRIC OF
OUR SOCIETY. IN OUR DIVERSE
STATE THIS BILL IS THE NEXT
STEP. TO MORE INCLUSIVE SOCIETY
ONE THAT IS REFLECTIVE AND
SUPPORTIVE OF STUDENTS OF ALL
BACKGROUNDS AND COMMUNITIES IN
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MISTER RAMOS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE AS A PROUD-
PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR ON THIS
BILL OF ETHNIC STUDIES IS
NEEDED IN PARTICULARLY TO THE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN-
PEOPLE HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE ALSO RISE. AS THE
CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA NATIVE
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN TWO
THOUSAND AND ONE IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE TEACH THE HISTORIES OF
VARIOUS CULTURES AND THE PEOPLE
THAT CONSTITUTE OUR GREAT
STATE. IN RECENT TIMES
ESPECIALLY OVER THE PAST YEAR
WE HAVE EXPERIENCE THE VENTS TO
SHOW US HOW LITTLE WE ALL
UNDERSTAND ABOUT THE
FRUSTRATIONS AND INEQUITIES OF
OUR STATE AND COUNTRY. VERY
LITTLE IS TAUGHT ABOUT
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICANS IN
OUR STATE SCHOOL SYSTEM THE
LITTLE INFORMATION THAT IS
TAUGHT IN THE CLASSROOMS ABOUT
NATIVE AMERICAN PEOPLE IS
PRIMARILY INACCURATE OR
INCOMPLETE. AND ONE IN
PARTICULAR CASE THAT WE WENT
THROUGH HERE IN THE PANDEMIC
SOME OF THAT INFORMATION OF
HESITANCY FOR OUR ELDERS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO TAKE THE
VACCINE WAS DUE TO PAST
TREATMENT OF THOSE HERE IN THE
STATE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
THAT MOVED FORWARD AS LATE AS
THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES. ON THE
STERILIZATION PROCESS TOWARDS
THE NATIVE AMERICAN WOMEN NOT
ONLY IN THE NATION BUT ALSO
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THESE TYPES OF EDUCATION IS
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO GET IN
FRONT OF THOSE IN OUR SCHOOL
SYSTEMS BY SUPPORTING AB ONE OH
ONE AND ETHNIC STUDIES WE START
TO MOVE THAT PENDULUM IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION. TO START TO
TEACH THE TRUE AND FCTUAL
ACCOUNTS OF CALIFORNIA HISTORY
AND CALIFORNIA'S FIRST PEOPLE I
URGE AND I VOTE FOR AB ONE OH
ONE. THANK YOU MYSTERON US MR
KILEY HERE RECOGNITION THE REAR
CHAMBER. WHEN THE FIRST DRAFT
OF THE- CURRICULUM- THAT THIS
BILL SEEKS TO MAKE A GRADUATION
REQUIREMENT WAS RELEASED IT WAS
UNIVERSALLY CONDEMNED- THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE JEWISH
CAUCUS TO TAKE ONE EXAMPLE THIS
IS FOURTEEN. MEMBERS OF THIS
LEGISLATURE I WROTE A LETTER
SAYING THAT IT ECHOES THE
PROPAGANDA OF THE **** REGIME.
ECHOES THE PROPAGANDA. OF THE
**** REGIME. THANK YOU THANK
OUR RESPONSE WOULD BE TO
IMMEDIATELY SCRAP THE WHOLE
THING AND BRING ACCOUNTABILITY
TO WHOEVER WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR
THIS AFTER ALL PEOPLE HAVE LOST
THEIR JOBS THEIR CAREERS FOR
THINGS FAR LESS SERIOUS THAN
TRYING TO TEACH **** PROPAGANDA
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS. BUT
THAT'S NOT WHAT HAPPENED.
INSTEAD WE SAID OKAY WE'LL MAKE
A FEW TWEAKS WILL MAKE A FEW
EDITS WILL TONE DOWN THE ****
PROPAGANDA AND THEN ONE POSE
THIS ON EVERY HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENT. IN CALIFORNIA. THE
INADEQUACY OF THIS RESPONSE IS
REFLECTED. IN THE CONTINUING
OPPOSITION OF JEWISH AMERICAN
GROUPS EVEN ON THE FOURTH
VERSION OF THE CURRICULUM THE
ALTERNATIVE. FOR EXAMPLE SAYS
THAT IN A TIME WHEN ANTI JEWISH
SENTIMENT HOSTILITY AND
VIOLENCE HAS REACHED TRULY
ALARMING LEVELS. THIS BILL IS
TANTAMOUNT TO PUTTING AN EVEN
LARGER TARGET ON THE BACK OF
EVERY JEWISH STUDENT. BUT THE
ANTISEMITISM. IS JUST ONE
MANIFESTATION OF WHAT IS SO
FUNDAMENTALLY WRONG. WITH THIS
PROPOSED CURRICULUM. AND IT'S
NOT JUST THE EXCLUSION OF
GROUPS THE DENIGRATION OF
GROUPS. IT'S THAT SEEKS TO
IMPOSE A PARTICULAR WORLD VIEW
ON STUDENTS RATHER THAN GIVING
THE ANALYTICAL AND CRITICAL
THINKING TOOLS TO CONSTRUCT
THEIR IDENTITY FOR THEMSELVES.
AND I PARTICULARLY OBJECT TO
THE NOTION THIS CURRICULUM IS
SOMEHOW IN SERVICE OF EQUITY.
THERE CAN BE NO DOUBT THAT
EQUITY IS AN ENORMOUS PROBLEM
IN CALIFORNIA PUBLIC EDUCATION.
WE HAVE SOME OF THE WORST
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS IN THE COUNTRY
ALONG RACIAL LINES ALONG SOCIO
ECONOMIC LINES. BEFORE COVE IT
EDUCATIONAL ACHIEVEMENT IN LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES WAS FORTY
NINTH AT A FIFTY WAS CALIFORNIA
STANDING COMPARED TO THE REST
OF THE COUNTRY. AND THE
SITUATION WAS SO BAD THAT YOU
HAD A LAWSUIT BROUGHT. BY
STUDENTS AGAINST THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR VIOLATING THEIR
CIVIL RIGHTS. BASED UPON THEM
NOT BEING TAUGHT HOW TO READ
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SETTLED
THAT LAWSUIT. FOR FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS LAST YEAR. I CAN SPEAK
TO THIS ISSUE FIRSTHAND. I
TAUGHT HIGH SCHOOL IN LOS
ANGELES I THOUGHT TENTH GRADERS
AND WHEN MY TENTH GRADERS GOT
TO MY CLASSROOM THE AVERAGE
READING LEVEL. WAS FIFTH GRADE.
WHEN I CAME TO THE LEGISLATURE.
MY BIGGEST PRIORITY WAS TO
FIGHT FOR TRUE EDUCATIONAL
EQUITY. YET EVERY ATTEMPT I
MADE TO EXPAND EDUCATIONAL
EQUITY AND OPPORTUNITY HAS BEEN
SNUFFED OUT. BY THE MOST
POWERFUL SPECIAL INTEREST IT IS
CAPITAL. WHOSE BUSINESS MODEL
IS TO KEEP KIDS TRAPPED IN
FAILING SCHOOLS. AND OVER THE
LAST YEAR THAT BUSINESS MODEL
HAS BECOME KEEPING KIDS OUT OF
SCHOOL ALTOGETHER. MISTER
MCCARTY PLEASE STAGE FOR ORDER
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER CAN WE
HAVE THE OPPONENT TO THIS
MEASURE SPEAK TO THE MERITS OF
THE BILL AND NOT GET
SIDETRACKED THINKING. MR
MCCARTY THE POINT IS WELL
TAKEN. THIS READ MR KILEY
PLEASE CONFINE YOUR COMMENTS TO
THE MERITS OF THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. THAT IS BEFORE THE
BODY. YOU MAY PROCEED. THE
CONSEQUENCES AS FAR AS
EDUCATIONAL EQUITY. WERE WELL
UNDERSTOOD IN ADVANCE RICHARD
ROTHSTEIN AUTHOR OF THE COLOR
OF LAW A FORGOTTEN HISTORY OF
HOW OUR GOVERNMENT SEGREGATED.
SAID THE CLOSING SCHOOLS WILL
TAKE EXISTING ACADEMIC
ACHIEVEMENT DIFFERENCES BETWEEN
MIDDLE CLASS AND LOW INCOME
STUDENTS AND EXPLODES EXPLODE.
AND YET THERE'S A STILL MORE
FUNDAMENTAL ISSUE HERE. AS
CURRICULUM LIKE THIS CURRICULA
LIKE THIS ARE BEING PROPOSED
NOT JUST IN CALIFORNIA BUT IN
OTHER PARTS OF THE COUNTRY AS
WELL. IN SOME CASES THEIR WELL
INTENDED ANOTHER CASES THEY'RE
NOT. BUT IN ALL CASES. IT IS
EXPLOITING WHAT I BELIEVE IS A
VOID. THAT HAS COME TO EXIST IN
PUBLIC EDUCATION NOT JUST IN
THE STATE BUT ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND THAT IS WE'VE LOST
TOUCH. WITH WHAT EDUCATION IS
SUPPOSED TO BE ABOUT YOU KNOW
THE UNIFYING THREAD. OF
EDUCATION THIRTY SECONDS. YOUNG
PEOPLE TO BE CITIZENS TO BE
ACTIVE AND PRODUCTIVE MEMBERS
OF SOCIETY. THAT'S WHAT BOUND
EDUCATION TOGETHER IT WAS THE
LINCHPIN OF SELF GOVERNMENT
BILL WE DON'T REALLY THINK
ABOUT EDUCATION THAT WAY
ANYMORE AND SO I THINK A
CURRICULUM LIKE THIS IS COMING
ALONG. AND IS TRYING TO FILL
THAT VOID IT'S LIKE THE ANTI
CIVICS. RATHER THAN HAVING THE
UNIFYING THREAD OF EDUCATION
THE BUILDING COMMUNITIES UP
IT'S TEARING COMMUNITIES DOWN
SO I THINK THAT WE NEED TO
OPPOSE THIS MEASURE TODAY. AND
WE NEED TO HAVE A RENEWAL IN
THIS STATE OF THE TRUE CIVIC
PURPOSE OF EDUCATION THANK YOU.
MICHIGAN APRIL YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE TODAY IS TEARING
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
JEWISH CAUCUS MAYBE JUST TO
HELP SET THE RECORD STRAIGHT A
LITTLE BIT WANT TO RESPOND TO
SOME OF THE COLLEAGUES FROM-
COMMENTS FROM A COLLEAGUE FROM
ROCKLAND WASN'T PLANNING TO
SPEAK TODAY BUT- JUST WANT TO
HELP CORRECT A FEW THINGS SO
FIRST- ON BEHALF OF THE
EIGHTEEN MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE JEWISH
CAUCUS. WANT TO KNOW THAT EVERY
MEMBER OF OUR CAUCUS SUPPORTED
THIS BILL LAST YEAR. NOW
THERE'S TWO ISSUES HERE THAT
ARE BEING CONFLATED. THERE WAS
A MODEL CURRICULUM IN INITIAL
DRAFT OF WHICH CAME OUT THAT
ARE CAUCUS OBJECTED TO. THERE
ARE SOME VERY DEEPLY BIGOTED
MATERIAL IN THAT. INFORMATION
SONG LYRICS ABOUT HOW JEWS
CONTROLLING MANIPULATE THE
MEDIA THINGS THAT OUR
COMMUNITY. FOUND ABSOLUTELY
UNTENABLE BUT WE WORKED WE CAME
TO THE TABLE WE ENGAGE WITH
STAKEHOLDERS. THERE WAS A
ROBUST PROCESS THAT THE
INSTRUCTIONAL QUALITY
COMMISSION. APPROVED BY THE
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION WE HAD
CURRICULA MODEL CURRICULUM.
THERE WAS VIRTUALLY UNANIMOUSLY
ADOPTED. BUT A LOT OF PEOPLE
CAME TOGETHER THAT SAID THAT.
THE PEOPLE INSTRUCTIONAL
QUALITY COMMISSION LIKE OUR
FORMER COLLEAGUE DR SHIRLEY
WEBER. PRAISE THAT THAT THE
LORD SWEAR TO PRAISE THAT
LEADERS IN THE JEWISH COMMUNITY
STOOD UP AND PRAISED. NOW THERE
ARE VOICES WITHIN OUR COMMUNITY
SOME THAT THAT ARE STILL
CONCERNED ABOUT ETHNIC STUDIES
THAT STILL. HAVE OBJECTIONS TO
IT. BUT THE VAST MAJORITY OF
JEWISH COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS
THAT HAVE LARGER MEMBERSHIP
THAT SPEAK FOR OUR COMMUNITY.
ARE PROUD OF WHAT'S IN THE
MODEL CURRICULUM. THEY
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT
INCLUDES LESSON PLANS ON ON THE
JEWISH AMERICAN EXPERIENCE. WE
APPRECIATE THE APPROACH THAT IT
TAKES. AND SO WE ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO ENGAGE IN THIS
CONVERSATION BUT I LOOK FORWARD
TO VOTING FOR THIS BILL TODAY I
WANT TO COMMEND. THE AUTHOR FOR
THE SENSITIVE WAY THAT HE HAS
HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH THAT
SOMEONE UP COMMAND A LOT OF OUR
COLLEAGUES TO COME UP AND ASK
ME ABOUT THIS. BECAUSE THESE
ARE THE KIND OF TOUCH THINGS
THAT CAN START OUT AND USUALLY
BE TOUGH CONVERSATIONS. BUT I
THINK WITH THE MODEL CURRICULUM
WE HAVE SET THIS IN A DIRECTION
THAT THE OVERWHELMING MAJORITY
OF CALIFORNIANS CAN FEEL GOOD
ABOUT. SO WHAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK IS THAT IF
PEOPLE WANT TO KNOW WHERE THE
JEWISH COMMUNITIES OUT IN THE
JEWISH CAUCUSES THAT COME TALK
TO US. WE DON'T NEED ANYBODY TO
SPEAK FOR US WE CAN SPEAK FOR
OURSELVES AND SO WITHOUT
RESPECTFULLY URGE MY COLLEAGUES
TO VOTE ON THIS BILL. THANK YOU
MISS GABRIEL. DR WEBER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB ONE OH ONE AS A
PROUD CO AUTHOR OF THIS VERY
IMPORTANT MEASURE. WHEN I WAS
IN SCHOOL I WAS TAUGHT THAT
CHRISTOPHER COLUMBUS DISCOVERED
AMERICA. AND THAT THE ONLY
THING SIGNIFICANT AND BLACK
HISTORY WAS THE I HAVE A DREAM
SPEECH GIVEN BY MARTHA KING
JUNIOR. I HOWEVER WAS FORTUNATE
THAT BOTH OF MY PARENTS WERE
VERY KNOWLEDGEABLE ABOUT BLACK
HISTORY. SO I LEARNED MY
HISTORY FROM THEM AND FROM THE
MANY HOURS I SPENT AS A CHILD
SITTING IN MY MOTHER'S BLACK
STUDIES CLASSES AT SENEGAL
STATE UNIVERSITY. KNOWING WHO
YOU ARE AND YOUR HISTORY IS
IMPORTANT AND HOW YOU SEE
YOURSELF AND YOUR PLACE IN THIS
WORLD. CALIFORNIA IS THE MOST
DIVERSE STATE IN THIS NATION
AND OUR KIDS SEE EVERY DAY THE
DIFFERENT RACIAL AND ETHNIC
BACKGROUNDS FROM WHICH THEIR
FRIENDS CLASSMATES AND
TEAMMATES COME FROM. THROUGH
ETHNIC STUDIES ARE HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS WILL RECEIVE ACCURATE
INFORMATION BASED ON CURRENT
AND CONFIRMED RESEARCH THAT MAY
HELP EXPLAIN FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN SOME CASES THE DIFFERENT
BACKGROUNDS FROM WHICH THEIR
FRIENDS COME FROM. AND FOR THE
FIRST TIME WILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HELP THEM NOT
ONLY UNDERSTAND THOSE
DIFFERENCES. BUT ALSO CELEBRATE
AND EMBRACE THEM. AT THE MOST
ONE OF THE MOST FORMATIVE TIMES
IN THEIR LIVES. WITH TODAY'S
VOTE WE WILL BEGIN TO CHART A
NEW COURSE FOR OUR KIDS ONE OF
INCLUSIVITY AND ACCEPTANCE.
PRESIDENT THEODORE ROOSEVELT
STATED THE MORE YOU KNOW ABOUT
THE PAST THE BETTER PREPARED
YOU ARE FOR THE FUTURE. MEMBERS
LET US PREPARE OUR CHILDREN FOR
A BETTER FUTURE BY EMPOWERING
THEM WITH THE KNOWLEDGE OF
THEIR HISTORY AND THE HISTORY
OF THEIR CLASSMATES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON AB ONE OH ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DR WEBER. MISS GARCIA
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. I THANK YOU
IRATE RICE AS A MATH TEACHER
FOR THIRTEEN YEARS- BUT THEIR
CREDENTIAL AND A LOT OF
PRACTICE- IT'S NOT ENOUGH TO
SAY WE WERE IN THE CLASSROOM TO
SPEAK FOR ALL TO YOURSELF THERE.
BUT LET ME JUST SAY THIS I WAS
A MATH TEACHER BUT I KNOW THIS
MIGHT SAID OF MY STUDENTS SAW.
THEMSELVES REFLECTED IN THEIR
SCHOOLS THEY WOULD'VE BEEN MUCH
MORE EXCITED TO COME TO SCHOOL
THEY WOULD HAVE BEEN MUCH RIGHT
HAD IT TO DO THE WORK THAT WE
ASK THEM TO DO OUT THERE. WHEN
WE TEACH THEM ABOUT THEIR
HISTORY TEACHER ABOUT THEIR
STRENGTH WITH THE TIME ABOUT
THE RESILIENCY WE TEACH THEM
ABOUT THE FACT THAT WE HAVEN'T
ALWAYS BEEN STRUGGLING AND THAT
THIS WITH ONCE OUR LAND.
ANYTHING THAT PRIDE IS WHAT WE
MIGHT BE TO CARRY FORWARD IN
pTHERE. AND SO IF WE'RE GONNA
STUDENTS TO BE SUCCESSFUL IN
MATH AS WE ELEVATES THEM OUT
THERE IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
TEACH IN THIS HISTORY AND THAT
THEY SEE. THE GOOD THE BAD AND
THE UGLY WE NEED OXYGEN THE
UGLY SO THAT WE DON'T WE
PEOPLE'S TALENTS AS THEY GET
OUT THERE. AND SO AS A TEACHER
I KNOW HOW IMPORTANT THIS
CURRICULUM IS AND HOW IMPORTANT
IT IS TO OUR STUDENTS OUT
THERE. YOU KNOW WE'RE GONNA
HAPPEN TO BE SUCCESSFUL
STUDENTS IN ALL SUBJECT MATTERS
IT'S TIME IT'S LONGER WE DO
THAT WE DO. THIS SINCE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I WILL.
THANK YOU MS GARCIA. MS
GONZALEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
AS A PROUD JOIN AUTHOR OF THIS
BILL. AND I HAVE TO SAY I'VE
BEEN HERE SINCE TWENTY THIRTEEN
AND EVERY SINGLE YEAR WE'VE HAD
A BILL A PRIORITY BILL THE
LATINO CAUCUS. TO TRY TO
MANDATE ETHNIC STUDIES IN OUR
HIGH SCHOOL. AND EVERY YEAR
WE'VE BEEN TOLD NOW. MOST OF US
AREN'T SURPRISED BECAUSE MOST
OF THE LATINO CAUCUS AT SOME
POINT LEARNED OUR HISTORY AND
REALIZE THAT'S NOT SO UNCOMMON.
THERE WERE OFTEN TOLD NO THEY
WERE OFTEN MISREPRESENTED THAT
OUR POSITIONS ARE OFTEN
MISREPRESENTED BY PEOPLE WHO DO
NOT COME FROM A BACKGROUND. AND
SO WE PERSIST AND SO THANK YOU
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
PERSISTING IF I WANT TO POINT
OUT SOMETHING I TO BELIEVE.
THAT WE SHOULD GIVE STUDENTS A
CRITICAL THINKING SKILLS TO
CONSTRUCT THEIR IDENTITY THAT
IS ESSENTIAL FOR HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS. BUT YOU CANNOT
CONSTRUCT YOUR IDENTITY IF YOU
DON'T KNOW YOUR HISTORY. AND I
WENT TO A SCHOOL LIKE MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO ALSO
IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY. ON STOLEN
LAND FROM THE COOLEY I NEVER
LEARNING THT. ON LAND THAT WAS
THEN BELONGING TO THE COUNTRY
OF MEXICO BUT BEING TOLD BY
TEACHERS. THAT MY FATHER WAS AN
ILLEGAL ALIEN IT DIDN'T BELONG
HERE IN NEVER BEING TOLD THAT
THIS WAS ONCE THE COUNTRY HE
CAME FROM. THESE ARE REAL
THINGS THAT STUDENTS GO
THROUGH. AND WE KNOW NOT ONLY
LIKE MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS
ANGELES STATED THE ANECDOTAL
EVIDENCE THAT HER STUDENTS
WOULD DO BETTER WITH ETHNIC
STUDIES BUT A TWENTY SIXTEEN
STUDYING ARE STANFORD
UNIVERSITY PROVED. THAT AT RISK
STUDENTS WERE LESS LIKELY DROP
OUT INCREASE THEIR MTH AND
SCIENCE SCORES IF THEY HAD
ETHNIC STUDIES. TELL PEOPLE
THEY'RE WORTH LET THEM LEARN
ABOUT THE HISTORY OF STRUGGLE
AND OVERCOMING STRUGGLE LET
THEM APPRECIATE WHERE THEY ARE
AND HOW WE GOT HERE AND THEY
WILL DO BETTER IN SCHOOL
STUDIES PROVE IT. IT IS
SHAMEFUL THAT FOR SEVEN YEARS
WE SAT ON THE FLOOR AND ARGUED
ABOUT ETHNIC STUDIES. IN IT
SHAMEFUL THAT IT'S BECOME
WEAPONIZED IN A WAY THAT WE SAW
TODAY AND WE SEE ON NATIONAL
TELEVISION AND WE SAW BY A
PREVIOUS PRESIDENT'S. BECAUSE
OUR STORIES MATTER. IN REAL
HISTORY SHOULD BE TAUGHT THIS
ISN'T EVEN ABOUT SOME SPECIAL
CATEGORICAL HISTORY THIS IS THE
HISTORY OF CALIFORNIA IN THE
HISTORY OF THE UNITED STATES IT
IS THE TRUTH AND WHY WOULD WE
EVER FIGHT TEACHING CHILDREN.
ABOUT THE TRUTH ABOUT HISTORY.
WHETHER IT'S TALKING ABOUT OUR
FOUNDING FATHERS IN THE FEET
THREE FIFTHS COMPROMISE THAT
THAT SAID THAT BLACK
INDIVIDUALS WERE NOT WORTHY OF
A FULL PERSON AT A FULL VOTE OR
THEIR WHETHER TALKING ABOUT OUR
BEAUTIFUL CATALINA ISLAND WHICH
BY A TREATY ACTUALLY TODAY
STILL BELONGS TO MEXICO BUT WAS
TAKEN. BY CAPITALIST WHO
DECIDED HE COULD PURCHASE IT.
THAT IS THE TRUTH IT'S HISTORY.
IT'S NOT JUDGMENTAL IT'S
SOMETHING PEOPLE HAVE THE RIGHT
TO LEARN AND OUR KIDS AND OUR
STUDENTS HAVE THE RIGHT TO
LEARN IT NOT EVERY STUDENT
PUBLIC SCHOOL HAVE THE BENEFIT
OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM FROM SAN
DIEGO. I DIDN'T HAVE THAT
BENEFIT TO SIT THROUGH ETHNIC
STUDIES CLASS IN COLLEGE I DID
HAVE THE BENEFIT OF A MOTHER
WHO CARED SO DEEPLY ABOUT ME
UNDERSTANDING MY HISTORY THAT
SHE DID HER BEST TO TEACH ME
DESPITE. HAVING NEVER TAKEN
ETHNIC STUDIES CLASS HERSELF.
BUT WHEN I GOT STANFORD AND I
WAS ABLE TO TAKE COURSES THAT
SPECIFICALLY TALK TO THE
HISTORY OF MY PEOPLE OF MY
IMMIGRANT FATHER OF MY MOTHER
OF MY CLASSMATES AND MY
COLLEAGUES. AWAKENING THAT
CAUSES AN A STUDENT TO WANT TO
LEARN MORE. TOOK TO DESIRE TO
CHANGE THINGS TO MAKE THINGS
BETTER FOR THE NEXT GENERATION.
IS SECOND TO NONE. I HOPE
PEOPLE WILL REALIZE HOW
IMPORTANT THIS DISCUSSION IS.
NOT JUST TO COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. BUT TO ALL COMMUNITIES
TO LEARN TRUE HISTORY I HAVE NO
UNDERSTANDING OF WHY ANYONE.
WOULD NOT VOTE FOR THIS BILL I
WOULD NOT VOTE AGAINST THIS
BILL AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
NINE. THANK YOU IN SCHEDULES
MYSTERY THIS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER IN IS
A VICE CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
LATINO LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS. IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL
ONE A ONE WHICH IS A PRIORITY
BILL OF OUR CAUCUS. AND I THINK
MANY OF US WOULD AGREE THAT
THIS LEGISLATION WILL IMPROVE
IT'S GOING TO IMPROVE. THE
QUALITY OF EDUCATION WE DELIVER
TO OUR STUDENTS. IT IS
ESSENTIAL THAT OUR STUDENTS BE
AFFORDED EVERY OPPORTUNITY TO
LEARN ABOUT THE HISTORY. THE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES AND LEADERS. THAT
CALL CALIFORNIA HOME. LEARNING
ABOUT UR DIVERSE POPULATIONS
INCREASES OUR EMPATHY AS PEOPLE.
AND HELPS TO FOSTER A MORE
EQUAL IN JUST COMMUNITY.
ESPECIALLY WITH THE RECENT
CIVIL UNREST WE'VE EXPERIENCED.
THE RISE IN HATE CRIMES THIS
LEGISLATION WILL PROVIDE OUR
SCHOOLS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
FOSTER FUTURE GENERATIONS OF
LEADERS THAT EMBRACE DIVERSITY
AND INCLUSIVITY. AND AS WE KNOW
NO BILL NO BILL IS PERFECT AND
THIS BILL THE PREVIOUS
ITERATIONS OF IT HAD BEEN
DEBATED FOR YEARS. AND THIS
CURRENT BILL IS A GREAT DEAL.
S. R. LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AND
YEARS OF INPUT FROM
STAKEHOLDERS FROM OF
LEGISLATORS FORMER AND PRESENT.
HAVE MADE IT A GREAT BILL. THE
AUTHOR OF THIS BILL ARE CALLING
FROM RIVERSIDE IS AN EXPERT ON
THIS ISSUE. HAVING SPENT OVER
THIRTY YEARS IN EDUCATION.
TEACHING ETHNIC STUDIES. OUR
COLLEAGUE RIVERSIDE UNDERSTAND
THIS ISSUE HE'S BEEN A CHAMPION
FOR STUDENTS HIS ENTIRE CAREER.
AND HAS SEE HOW ETHNIC STUDIES
CAN ENRICH THE STUDENT
EXPERIENCE. I AM PROUD TO STAND
WITH HIM PROUD TO STAND IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL ONE A
ONE AND REGION AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER. I THINK IT
WAS RIVAS MR COOLEY. IN THE
REAR CHAMBER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
COLLEAGUES I'M VERY PLEASED TO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
AND- I ACTUALLY FEEL THAT IT'S
A RED LETTER DAY FOR ME AS A
DEMOCRAT BECAUSE IT'S THE FIRST
TIME- USE A WERE OFTEN HEAR
FROM MY COLLEAGUES IN THE FOR
OF THIS CHAMBER. EXISTENTIAL
EXISTENCE RELATIONS EXIST AS WE
TALK ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE IS AN
EXISTENTIAL CHALLENGE. BUT
THERE IS NO GRAVER CHALLENGE
ACROSS THE GLOBE. THEN THE
ABILITY OF PEOPLE. TO LOOK AT
OTHERS NOT LIKE THEM WITH
EMPATHY. WITH RESPECT WITH
UNDERSTANDING. WE ARE SEEING
THIS THIS IS THE MOMENT A
HISTORY WHICH WERE STANDARD
WHERE WE HAVE BROADENED
CONNECTIONS THE GLOW. BUT WHAT
WE SEE IS A GREAT OUTPOURING OF
HOSTILITY AND DIVISION FOCUSED
ON DIFFERENCES. AND YES OUR
GLOBAL. OPPONENTS FOMENT THIS
USING ONLINE TOOLSOTHER SORTS
OF THINGS THIS IS A PROFOUND
IRAQ. FOR THE EXPERIMENT IN
DEMOCRACY THE START WITH OUR
NATION. TO SEE HOW IT WILL END
DOOR IN AN ERA OF SUCH DIVISION
OF SUCH HOSTILITY OF SUCH A
READINESS TO CASTIGATE AND
DENIGRATE. OTHERS WHO MAY BE
DIFFERENT. I THINK FOR US IN
CALIFORNIA A GLOBAL. NATION
STATE. TO STAND ON BEHALF OF
PROMOTING AN UNDERSTANDING AND
EMPATHY. IT IS INDEED A
RESPONSE TO WHAT IS A PROFOUND
ACCIDENTAL STRESS EXISTENTIAL
THREAT TO DEMOCRACY AND IF I
MAY BRING IT HOME SEVERAL
DECADES AGO. RON THE TIME OF MY
CITY FORMED. RANCHO CORDOVA WAS
IDENTIFIED BASED ON THE U. S.
CENSUS AS THE MOST RAPIDLY
DIVERSIFYING COMMUNITY AND ALL
OF CALIFORNIA LITTLE WRENCH
OVER OVER HERE AND CHECK ON A
COUNTY WHERE I LIVE WHERE MY
KIDS GREW UP. AND I KNOW THAT
MY HIGH SCHOOLERS BECAUSE WE
WOULD TALK ABOUT THIS. FELT
THAT. THEY WERE ALWAYS HAPPY
WITH THE EDUCATION THEY GOT
THEY HAD GRIPES ABOUT THE
SCHOOLS BUT THEY TOTALLY
BELIEVE THAT THEY WERE BETTER
EQUIPPED TO GO INTO THE
WORKFORCE IN THE MODERN WORLD.
BECAUSE THEY UNDERSTOOD HOW TO
LIVE WITH DIFFERENCES TO
RESPECT OTHERS TO FUNCTION AMID
DIVERSITY. SO I FEEL THAT THIS
IS A VERY IMPORTANT BILL A VERY
IMPORTANT UNDERTAKING FOR
CALIFORNIA AS A GLOBAL NATION
STATE. TO START LOOKING AT HOW
WE- PEOPLE IN THE QUALITY OF
EMPATHY UNDERSTANDING AND- YOU
KNOW IT BRINGS TO MIND THE
MERCHANT OF VENICE SCHAEFER WHO
SAYS A QUALITY OF MERCY IS NOT
STRAINED IT FALLS A MEMBER LIKE
A GERMAN RAIN IT IS TWICE A
BLESSING FOR THOSE RECEIVE IT
AND THOSE WHO GIVE IT I THINK
THOSE WHO WORKED ON THIS
CURRICULUM AND THOSE WHO
RECEIVE THE BENEFIT WILL INDEED
FIND THEM ALL TWICE BENEFITTED.
AND I BELIEVE IS VERY IMPORTANT.
FOR OUR AREA. I REGION AYE VOTE.
THANKS COOLEY MR LOW YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER
AND COLLEAGUES I WANT TO
COMMEND THE AUTHOR FROM
RIVERSIDE FOR HIS TENACITY AND
ALSO COMMENDED VARIOUS LEADERS
OF THE RESPECTIVE ETHNIC
CAUCUSES FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO
DIDN'T HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
VISUALLY SEE THIS ON THE FLOOR
THERE WAS A DEMONSTRATION OF
INCREDIBLE SOLIDARITY AND THE
JEWISH CAUCUS AND I THANK YOU
ON BEHALF OF THE- LGBT
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS MYSELF AND
AS VICE CHAIR OF ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS.
FOR DEEP EMPATHY AND SOLIDARITY
ESPECIALLY RIGHT NOW.
COLLEAGUES I AM A PRODUCT OF
ETHNIC STUDIES. AND ALL SHARE A
MOMENT OF VULNERABILITY GROWING
UP AS A FOURTH GENERATION
CALIFORNIAN THAT I HATED MYSELF.
I HATED BEING ASIAN I WAS
ASHAMED OF BEING ASIAN GROWING
UP BORN AND RAISED IN SAN JOSE.
AN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL I WOULD
BRING MY LUNCH PAIL OPEN UP MY
BOX OF LUNCH AND PEOPLE YOUNG
KIDS WOULD CRINGE AND SAY YOU
THAT STINKY. WHY ARE YOU SO
FOREIGN. THAT'S NOT AMERICAN
FOOD. I GO HOME TRYING. TO MY
PARENTS SAYING I WANT TO SPEAK
ENGLISH ONLY. MY PARENTS SAID
YOU KNOW YOU NEED TO UNDERSTAND
CULTURE YOUR OWN IDENTITY. THIS
IS IMPORTANT TO AMERICA I SAID
I REFUSE. SO THAT'S WHY SPEAK
ENGLISH ONLY TODAY. I FEEL LOST.
A PERPETUAL FOREIGNER. ASIAN
PROVIDERS DON'T SEE ME AS
CHINESE BECAUSE I DON'T SPEAK
THE LANGUAGE AND HERE IN MY OWN
HOME COUNTRY AS A FOURTH
GENERATION CALIFORNIA I STILL
FEEL. LIKE A FOREIGNER.
THOUGHTS OF SUICIDE. IT WASN'T
UNTIL I TOOK ETHNIC STUDIES. I
START TO LEARN ABOUT MY OWN
HISTORY. SAID WHY DID I NOT
LEARN ABOUT THIS IN SCHOOL.
THAT CHINESE AMERICANS HAVE
MUCH TO CONTRIBUTE TO THE
FABRIC. OF CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY
AND THE RAILROADS AND BY THE
WAY LABOUR'S WITHIN KICKED OUT
WHY DID I NOT KNOW ABOUT THIS
ON MY OWN HISTORY. GROWING UP
IN HIGH SCHOOL AND COLLEGE. I
THOUGHT WE WERE SUPPOSED BECOME
PRODUCTIVE MEMBERS OF SOCIETY
AFTER GROWING UP AND GETTING A
HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA. THAT'S IT
WE'RE DONE. STAMP OF APPROVAL
YOU'RE A GOOD ACTIVE CITIZEN.
HOW DO WE EXPECT TO BE TALKING
TO EACH OTHER WITHOUT LEARNING
ABOUT EACH OTHER'S CULTURE AND
IDENTITY WE OPERATE IN SILOS IN
TRIBALISM WE DON'T TALK WITH
EACH OTHER WE TALKED TOWARDS
EACH OTHER AND ESPECIALLY IN
THIS MOMENT RIGHT NOW TO STOP
AP I HATE. THAT IS THE CALL FOR
ACTION THE DEMAND THE REQUEST.
FOR ETHNIC STUDIES SO THAT WE
CAN TO LEARN ABOUT OUR OWN
AMERICAN HISTORY AND BY THE WAY.
WE LEARN ABOUT THE STRENGTH OF
DIVERSITY FROM EVERYONE. SO
COLLEAGUES THINK ABOUT IT FROM
THE FRAMEWORK OF A YOUNG CHILD.
GROWING UP SIMILAR TO ME HATING
THEMSELVES BECAUSE THEY DON'T
FEEL AMERICAN. THERE'S
SOMETHING TO PROVE NOT TRULY
PATRIOTIC AND THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO TALK WITH
EACH OTHER TO LEARN ABOUT OR
CALIFORNIA AND OUR OWN AMERICAN
HISTORY IT'S GOING TO
STRENGTHEN THE DIVERSITY THAT
WE HAVE IN OUR STATE AND WE
DON'T KNOW ABOUT OUR OWN
HISTORY WE DON'T KNOW. THE
FUTURE AND WE'RE GOING I THANK
THE AUTHOR AGAIN FROM RIVERSIDE
FOR HIS COMPASSION I HOPE ALL
OF YOU BUT ALSO VOTE AYE ON
THIS MEASURE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MITCHELL- MISS CAREER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FROM HER DESK.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THE
MEMBERS I STAND IN PROUD
SUPPORT OF AB ONE OH ONE. I AM
ETHNIC STUDIES. I BELIEVE THAT
THIS BILL IS FUNDAMENTAL FOR
THE FUTURE OF OUR STATE AND THE
FUTURE OF OUR NATION AND I JUST
WANT TO SHARE A FEW THINGS. I
DON'T LEARN ABOUT ETHNIC
STUDIES OR CHICANO STUDIES
UNTIL I GOT TO COLLEGE. AND
THAT'S ONLY BECAUSE I MADE AN
ACTIVE DECISION TO GO TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND I DIDN'T
GO TO COLLEGE RIGHT AWAY I
ACTUALLY WENT TO A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE TWO YEARS AFTER. I
BARELY GRADUATED FROM HIGH
SCHOOL WHICH IS A STORY THAT I
HAVE SHARED ON THIS FLOOR
BEFORE. BUT IT IS THROUGH
ETHNIC STUDIES AND CHICANO
STUDIES IN PARTICULAR NIGHT
HAVE A MINOR INTO CATTLE
STUDIES BECAUSE I. LOVED AND
BELIEVED IN WHAT I WAS BEING
TAUGHT AT THE COLLEGE LEVEL AND
I SHOULD HAVE LEARNED ALL THOSE
THINGS. IN HIGH SCHOOL. TO THE
POINT OF KNOWING WHO I WAS
ETHNIC STUDIES CHICANO STUDIES
TAUGHT ME ABOUT CELLS ARE
TRAVIS THE LOTUS WETA. CORKY
GONZALEZ BEAT CRUSADE FOR
JUSTICE. I AM JOAQUIN LOST IN A
WORLD OF CONFUSION. CONFUSED BY
RULES SCORNED BY ATTITUDES
SUPPRESS. BY MANIPULATION AND
DESTROYED BY A MODERN SOCIETY I
AM BLOCKED THEM OAK PROUD. AND
NOBLE. IT WAS THROUGH CHICANO
STUDIES THAT I LEARNED ABOUT
THE AUDIENCE HOW DO A AND
CHERRY MORAGA. AND IS A BRIDGE
CALLED MY BACK AND POWERFUL
WOMEN OF COLOR WHO ARE BOLDLY
TELLING THEIR STORIES IN A WAY
THAT HAD NEVER BEEN TOLD
BEFORE. IT WAS THROUGH CHICANO
STUDIES THAT I LEARNED ABOUT
CHICANOS AND FILM AND THE OSCAR
STATUE MODELED AFTER A MEXICAN
AMERICAN. NAMED EMILIO
FERNANDEZ WHO WROTE ABOUT
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE IN HOLLYWOOD
AND WHO LIVED IN AUSTIN LOS
ANGELES. IN EXILE. BECAUSE OF
WHO HE WAS AND WHAT HE WAS
DOING. IT WAS THREE CHICANO
STUDIES AND ETHNIC STUDIES THAT
I LEARNED. A PATHWAY INTO MY
OWN CULTURE OF SENT BEING
CENTRAL AMERICAN AND CENTRAL
AMERICAN STUDIES WHERE I
LEARNED. ABOUT JOSE CASTELLANOS
WHO HELPED. IN THE BOOK THE MAN
WHO STOP THE TRAINS TO
AUSCHWITZ GEORGE MANTEO AND
SOME OF THE LORD. AND
SWITZERLAND'S FINEST HOUR AND
HOW IS HOW DO I LOAD PLAYED A
ROLE. AGAINST THE HOLOCAUST IN
HELPING JEWISH PEOPLE FIND
FREEDOM IN THIS TINY LITTLE.
PLACE THAT I AM FROM IN CENTRAL
AMERICA IT IS THROUGH ALL OF
THESE. EFFORTS IT IS THROUGH
THIS MOVEMENT FOR ETHNIC
STUDIES AND CHICANO STUDIES AND
CENTRAL AMERICAN STUDIES. THAT
I LEARNED AND UNDERSTOOD. WHO I
WAS. AND I MUST'VE BEEN TWENTY
FOUR YEARS OLD AT THAT TIME.
AND IT SHOULDN'T HAVE TAKEN
THAT LONG FOR ME TO FIND OUT
WHERE I COME FROM. AND WHO I
AM. AND WHAT I STAND FOR AND
WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO MOVE FOR
AND HOW I COULD ACTUALLY FIND.
AROUND AND FOUNDATION AS TO WHO
I WAS AND MY ROLE IN SOCIETY.
THIS IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT IT
IS IMPACTFUL IT IS NECESSARY IT
IS NEEDED IN AN EFFORT TO
ENSURE THAT EVERY CHILD. IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN ABOUT
THEMSELVES AND TO LEARN ABOUT
OTHERS. IT IS ABOUT TIME. TIME
HAS PASSED THIS IS THE MOMENT
AND IF NOT NOW WHEN. AND IF NOT
US WHO. WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
HERE AND IT IS ABOUT AN
OPPORTUNITY THAT WE SHOULD NOT
WASTE AND I WANT TO THINK IT
PROFIT SO IT. WHO HAS BEEN IN
THIS FIGHT FOR YEARS THIS IS A
FUNDAMENTAL MOMENT FOR US. FOR
YOU AND I AM SO GRATEFUL AND
THANKFUL FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND I STRONGLY URGE AN AYE VOTE
ON AB ONE OH ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS CARILLO. MISTER
GIBSON IN THE REAR THE CHAMBER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I WAS NOT PREPARED TO
SPEAK ON THIS ITEM BUT ALTHOUGH
ON THE JOINT AUTHOR OR CO
AUTHOR SOMETHING I'M
SUPPORTING- THIS BILL I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS CONVERSATION TO THIS FLOOR
BECAUSE THIS IS WHERE EXACTLY
WHERE THIS CONVERSATION NEEDS
TO TAKE PLACE BUT I KNOW THAT
THIS AUTHOR HAS BEEN LABORING
OVER THIS SUBJECT MATTER IN
TERMS OF BRINGING ETHNIC
STUDIES. HERE AND HOPEFULLY ON
THE GOVERNOR'S DESK I'VE SEEN
THIS AUTHOR LABOR AND STRUGGLE
I'M TO TRY TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
BRING PEOPLE TOGETHER TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION TO HAVE AND TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
ARE TALK ABOUT THE HISTORY NO
ONLY IF CALIFORNIA BUT ALSO THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA ALSO
THEY WILL ALSO GET A REFLECTION
OF TERMS OF WHO THEY ARE SO
I'VE SEEN HIM AND I WANT TO
THANK. STAYING STEADFAST- ON
THIS PARTICULAR TOPIC ALSO ONE
ECHO- ON THE VOICES OF THOSE OF
MY COLLEAGUES HAVE ALREADY
SPOKEN IT'S ABOUT SELF IDENTITY
IT'S ABOUT OUR HISTORY AND WHAT
BETTER PLACE SHOULD WE HAVE
THAT CUT DISCUSSION NOT ONLY
HERE BUT ALSO MAKING SURE IS
CHRONICLED IN OUR HISTORY BOOKS
AND THAT YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
TAUGHT THEIR HISTORY SO THAT WE
WON'T HAVE PEOPLE GROWING UP
NOT UNDERSTANDING THEIR HISTORY
SO WE WON'T HAVE PEOPLE GROWING
UP NOT KNOWING WHO THEY ARE SO
WE WILL HAVE PEOPLE GROWING UP.
NOT UNDERSTANDING THE STRUGGLES
OF OUR FOREFATHERS THAT HELP
MAKE AND BUILT THIS COUNTRY AND
SO I BELIEVE THE TIME IS NOW
FOR US TO DO THIS THE TIME IS
NOW IN THE ATMOSPHERE FOR
CHANGE AND I BELIEVE THAT
CALIFORNIA CAN ABSOLUTELY LEAD
THE WAY IN THIS SPACE AND SO I
AM VERY ENTHUSIASTICALLY- I'M
VERY ENCOURAGED ABOUT AB ONE OH
ONE ENCOURAGE EACH AND EVERYONE
OF YOU WHICH ARE STRONG AYE
VOTE TO SEOUL TO SHOW SUPPORT
FOR NON OUR COLLEAGUE BUT ALSO
AT THE NEXT. IN THE STATE OF.
THANK YOU. FAMOUS GIPSON.
SENIOR MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM MR
MEDINA YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. FIRST LET ME
THANK ALL MY COLLEAGUES WHO
SPOKE AND WHO'S SPOKEN SO
ELOQUENTLY HERE TODAY AND WHO
HAVE ECHOED THE VOICES OF
STUDENTS. I HAVE IN FRONT OF ME
HERE. TWENTY THOUSAND STUDENTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHO'VE SIGNED THE
PETITION IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE
OH ONE GEN UP. IS DOING
FANTASTICWORK IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS AND MAYBE
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS TODAY
UNLIKE HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS IN
THE NINETEEN SIXTIES ARE NOT
MARCHING AND MAYBE THEY'RE NOT
BEING ABLE TO MARCH BECAUSE OF
COLD IT BUT THEY ARE USING
TECHNOLOGY. TWENTY THOUSAND
NAMES ON THIS PETITION IN
SUPPORT OF AB ONE OH ONE HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT. TO MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE JEWISH
CARCASS THANK YOU. I AM PROUD
TO HAVE BEEN AND AM A FOUNDING
MEMBER OF THE JEWISH CAUCUS
THANK YOU FOR STANDING WITH US.
TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM ROCKVILLE.
AS YOU HEARD. MY COLLEAGUE I'M
SALINAS SAY I WAS IN THE
CLASSROOM FOR THIRTY FOUR YEARS.
I SAW FIRSTHAND HOW THIS
CURRICULUM CHANGES THE LIVES OF
STUDENTS. I WALKED AROUND
RIVERSIDE TODAY AND STUDENTS
COME UP TO ME. AND THEY DON'T
THANK ME MR MEDINA FOR SHOWING
ME HOW TO CONJUGATE. IRREGULAR
VERBS IN SPANISH THEY SHOULD
BUT THEY DON'T. OR TEACHING
SUBJUNCTIVE. WHICH IS STRICTLY.
THEY THANK ME AND THEY CONTINUE
TO THANK ME FOR WHAT THEY LEARN
IN MY CHICANO STUDIES CLASS.
BECAUSE STUDENTS TEACH
THEMSELVES STUDENTS BRING IN
SUCH A RICH HISTORY WHETHER
THEY'RE BEING NATIVE AMERICAN
STUDENTS ASIAN AMERICAN
STUDENTS. LATINO STUDENTS THEY
BRING AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDENTS
THEY BRING THEIR CULTURE TO
CLASS. AND IF THEY SEE
THEMSELVES REFLECTED IN THE
BOOKS IN THE CURRICULUM THEY
SEE THEMSELVES REFLECTED IN THE
TEACHERS TO STAND IN FRONT OF
THEM THEY LEARN AND THEY TEACH
EACH OTHER. AND THEY CAN TEACH
US. THAT IS WHAT I LEARNED. TO
MY COLLEAGUE. FROM ROCK WITH.
AND WHEN STUDENTS ARE ENGAGED
THEY ARE NOT ONLY ENGAGE IN
ETHNIC STUDIES. AS MY COLLEAGUE
SAN DIEGO MENTION STEADY'S FROM
STANFORD UNIVERSITY OF SHOWN
THAT STUDENTS ENROLLED IN
ETHNIC STUDIES DO BETTER NOT
ONLY IN ETHNIC STUDIES BUT IN
ALL CLASSES. THERE AFTER THEIR
ABS ABSENTEEISM DROPS GPAS HAVE
GONE UP. AND THAT IS FOR ALL
STUDENTS. NOT ONLY STUDENTS OF
COLOR. BUT ALL STUDENTS. TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN JOSE.
REMINDS ME OF ONE OF MY HEROES.
WHOSE ANNIVERSARY OF HIS DEATH
IS TODAY TWELVE YEARS AGO TODAY.
NASSAR RONALD TAKAKI OF
BERKELEY OF CAL UNIVERSITY.
PASSED AWAY. HIS BOOKS ARE
BEING TAUGHT IN OUR HIGH SCHOOL.
I BELIEVE THAT RONALD TAKAKI
SMILES ON US TODAY. BECAUSE
RONALD TAKAKI SAID THIS STORY
HE WAS IN WASHINGTON DC. TO
GIVE A CONFERENCE. AND HE'S
RIGHT IN THE TAXI GOING TO GIVE.
HIS SPEECH AT THE CONFERENCE
AND THE TAXI DRIVER. YOU KNOW
JUST MAKING SMALL TALK. ASKED
HIM WHERE ARE YOU FROM. THANK
RONALD TAKAKI THEY'VE ANSWERED
CALIFORNIA. BUT THE TAXI DRIVER
WASN'T HAPPY WITH THAT ANSWER
HE SAID NO ARE YOU REALLY FROM.
I DON'T KNOW IF HE SAID HAWAII
BECAUSE RONALD TAKAKI GREW UP
IN HAWAII. BUT THAT IS BEEN MY
EXPERIENCE AS WELL. MANY OF US
HAVE HAD THAT EXPERIENCE TO BE
SEEN AS THE OTHER. TO BE SEEN
AS A FOREIGNER IN THIS COUNTRY.
WHETHER WE'VE BEEN HERE FOR
GENERATIONS AND IT IS IN
CLASSES LIKE ETHNIC STUDIES
THAT WE LEARN ABOUT THE TREATY
OF GUADALUPE HIDALGO. THAT WE
LEARN ABOUT THE CHINESE
EXCLUSION ACT. THE ASIAN LAND
LAW IT AFFECTED RIVERSIDE THE
WE LEARN ABOUT. THE MASSACRE OF
NATIVE AMERICANS. I THANK YOU
ALL FOR SUPPORTING THIS BILL I
THANK YOU ALL FOR GOING VOTING
I. WHAT WE ARE DOING IS
IMPORTANT FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. URGE YOU TO VOTE BY
AN EIGHTY ONE OH ONE. THANK YOU
MISS MEDINA CLERK LEVEL THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS OF. DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
A. ALL MEMBERS VOTE. DESIRABLE.
CLARK WELL. A CLOSER ALL CALVET
EYES FIFTY SIX NO SIX THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS. MISTER
KALRA YOU MAY OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AS A
PRINCIPAL COOPER ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR KAMLAGER. I'M HONORED
TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
EIGHTEEN WHICH WOULD ESTABLISH
THE COMMUNITY RESPONSE
INITIATIVE. TO STRENGTHEN
EMERGENCY SYSTEMS OR CRISIS ACT
WHICH THE PILOT PROGRAM TO
SUPPORT COMMUNITY BASED
RESPONSES TO LOCAL EMERGENCY
SITUATIONS. EVERY DAY IN
COUNTIES ACROSS THE STATE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
ARE SUCCESSFULLY RESPONDING TO
EMERGENCY SITUATIONS SUCH AS
PEOPLE DEALING WITH
HOMELESSNESS. PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING A MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS INTIMATE PARTNER
VIOLENCE PEOPLE EXPERIENCE
SUBSTANCE ABUSE OR IMPACTED BY
NATURAL DISASTERS. AB ONE
EIGHTEEN IS A REINTRODUCTION OF
THE VETOED BILL FROM LAST
SESSION. THE AUTHOR HAS SINCE
ENGAGE WITH STAKEHOLDERS AND
HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO IDENTIFY THE
APPROPRIATE STATE AGENCY TO
OVERSEE THE PILOT PROGRAM IN
RESPONSE TO THE GOVERNOR'S VETO
MESSAGE. THE CRISIS ACTORS
GARNERED NATIONAL ATTENTION
EVEN INSPIRED INNOVATIVE
FEDERAL LEGISLATION WHICH ALSO
SEEKS TO CATALYZE THE
INVOLVEMENT. OF COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS IN EMERGENCY
RESPONSE. INTERACTION PLEASE
CAN BE SCARY AND TRAUMATIZING
FOR MANY PEOPLE. BY
PRIORITIZING COMMUNITY
INTERVENTIONS THE CRISIS ACT
WILL HELP PROTECT THE PEOPLE
MOST AT RISK FROM USE OF FOR
CENTURIES AND UP. INCLUDING
THOSE OF MENTAL AND PHYSICAL
DISABILITIES PEOPLE ARE BLACK
LATINO OR INDIGENOUS MEMBERS OF
THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY AND ON
HEALTH INDIVIDUALS. IN MARCH OF
THIS YEAR AS THEIR CERVANTES A
TWENTY FIVE YEAR OLD MAN WITH
AUTISM. AND HARD OF HEARING WAS
SHOT IN THE BACK BY LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SHERIFF'S DEPUTIES AT
HIS HOME IN KENTUCKY. HIS
MOTHER CALLED THE COUNTY
SHERIFF'S OFFICE FOR ASSISTANCE
AND WITHIN THREE MINUTES OF
BEING CALLED TO HELP IDEAS AND
HIS FAMILY. HE WAS SHOT ON THE
FLOOR OF HIS LIVING ROOM. THE
FAMILY WILL NEVER KNOW THIS
TRAGIC TRAGEDY COULD HAVE BEEN.
DE ESCALATED WITH COMMUNITY
BASED INTERVENTION. TODAY
POLICE KILL PEOPLE WITH
UNTREATED MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS SUCH AS
SCHIZOPHRENIA SIXTEEN TIMES
MORE OFTEN. THAN PEOPLE WITHOUT
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES. ALTHOUGH
WE HAVE. WITH A GREATER
EMPHASIS ON. MENTAL HEALTH IN
TRAINING OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
THEY ARE NOT MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS. THERE ARE
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS
RESPONDING SUCCESSFULLY TO
EMERGENCY SITUATIONS BUT THEIR
IMPACT HAS LIMITED RESOURCES.
AB ONE EIGHTEEN BUILT ON
SUCCESSFUL EFFORT FROM LA THE
BAY AREA SACRAMENTO AND OTHER
CITIES LOOKING TO A SMARTER WAY
TO DEAL WITH THE PERSON'S
INDIVIDUAL CRISIS. IN THE
COMMUNITY. DESPITE THE POSITIVE
IMPACT AND COST SAVINGS AND
COMMUNITY ORIENTED RESPONSES TO
EMERGENCIES THE STATE HAS DONE
LITTLE TO SUPPORT AND SCALE
THESE EFFORTS. INSTEAD LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS ARE FORCED
TO RESPOND TO EMERGENCIES
BETTER SUITED FOR PEER SUPPORT
EXPERTS MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDERS
OR COUNTY CRISIS COUNSELORS
TRAINED TO DE ESCALATE AND
RESOLVE CRISES. AB ONE EIGHTEEN
THE CRISIS ACTORS INVESTING IN
THE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
THERE ARE ALREADY SUCCESSFULLY
RESPONDING TO MANY TIMES TO
EMERGENCY SITUATIONS AND HAVE
THE EXPERTISE. RELATIONSHIPS
NETWORKS ENTRUSTS TO BEST MEET
THE NEEDS OF THE COMMUNITY.
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
DANISH CAR. SEEING NOTED DEBATE
ON THE ITEM. CARCLUB RURAL.
RESERVE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT
OF A. ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIGN
OF A. THE CLERK WILL. CLOSE
ROLL TIDE ABOUT I SHOULD DO SO
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
BACK IN THE FILE TO ALLOW THE
ASSISTANCE SPEAKER PRO TEM TO
TAKE HER ITEMS UP. SHE HAS TWO
ITEMS. WE'RE GOING TO START
WITH FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY FOUR
THIS IS FILE ITEM. ONE FIFTY
FOUR EIGHTY SIX TWENTY FOUR.
QUACKERY. ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
TWENTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OF OUR QUE HAN ANOTHER SNACK
LIVING JUVENILES MS BARRICADE
HAND THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY REPRESENT AB SIX
TWENTY FOUR A TECHNICAL BUT
HUGELY IMPACTFUL PROCEDURAL
BILL THAT WILL HAVE AN ENORMOUS
EFFECT FOR YOUTH WITHIN OUR
JUSTICE SYSTEM IN THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM THE FOCUS IS ON
REHABILITATION AND IT IS
CENTERED ON WHAT IS BEST FOR
YOU. AND ENSURING POSITIVE
OUTCOMES. IN SOME CASES
PROSECUTORS MAY ARGUE THE YOU'D
BE TRANSFERRED TO ADULT COURT
FOR GOING THE JUVENILE COURT
PROCESS. CHILDREN AS YOUNG AS
SIXTEEN HAVE BEEN TRIED IN
ADULT COURT FACING LIFE WITHOUT
PAROLE. FIFTY SIX SHOW THE
BLACK AND BROWN YOUTH ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY SENT TO
ADULT COURT COURT WELL THEIR
WHITE COUNTERPARTS ARE MORE
OFTEN ALLOWED TO REMAIN IN
JUVENILE JURISDICTION.
SHOCKINGLY IN CURRENT LAW THE
TRIAL HAS NO RIGHT TO APPEAL
THE DECISION TO GO TO ADULT
COURT THERE IS ONLY A
DISCRETIONARY RATE THAT IS
OFTEN SUMMARILY DENIED AND NOT
REVIEWED ON THE MERITS. THE
BILL YOU BEFORE YOU TODAY DOES
NOT UP AND THECURRENT PROCESS
BUT AT THE CLEAR PATH REVIEW OF
THESE TRANSFER DECISIONS. SB
SIX TWENTY FOUR CREATES AN
APPEAL PROCESS OF THE DECISION
TO TRANSFER YOU TO DAHLE COURT
AND REQUIRES THAT IT BE DONE IN
A TIMELY MANNER. AS NOT TO
DELAY THE USE RIGHT TO A SPEEDY
TRIAL. THE BILL IS IN LINE WITH
THE VALUES OF THIS BODY AND IT
IS TRULY IN THE BEST INTEREST
OF THE YOUTH AT THIS PIVOTAL
JUNCTURE TO HAVE THE RIGHT TO
APPEAL THIS DECISION. YOU CAN
CHANGE THE TRAJECTORY OF THEIR
LIVES. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
EITHER. FAME IS BACKING HIM
SEEING. NO DISCUSSION OF A ON
THE ITEM OVER THERE ARE.
MEMBERS RESIDE IN THE HOME VOTE
OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS OF. BUT
IS THAT VOTE. OKAY IN WELL
CLOSE ALL TIED OUT SIXTY SIX
KNOWS YOUR- THAT MEASURE. NOW
WE'RE GOING TO BE TAKING A-
FILE I. ONE SIXTY EIGHT. THIS
IS FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY EIGHT BY
MISTER HAND. IT IS AB SO THIRTY
CORKERY. SOME WRIGGLE SEVEN
THIRTY ONE BUYS MEMBER OF QUE
HAN AND OTHER MEDICAL IN THE
COUNTY. MS BARAKAT THANK YOU
SPEAKER AND MY EIGHT SEVEN ONE
IS A GOVERNMENT MEASURE THAT
WILL REQUIRE COUNTY STATEWIDE
TO AND SUBMIT. ON OFFENDERS
PROGRAM PROVIDED TO INMATES IN
COUNTY. AND THE SIX RATES
REDUCE RISK OF PRO. EACH YEAR
SINCE REALIGNMENT WAS ENACTED
APPROPRIATIONS IN THE STATE
BUDGET HAVE PROVIDED MONEY FOR
COUNTIES TO IMPLEMENT DIVERSE
APPROACHES FOR SUPERVISION AND
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS THAT
AIM TO REDUCE RECIDIVISM SEND
SEND INFORMATION ABOUT
CALIFORNIA'S RECIDIVISM
PROGRAMMING SPECIFIC TO WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN THESE COUNTY JAILS
IS FRAGMENTED AND DIFFICULT TO
DIGEST. IT IS SIMPLY
NONSENSICAL TO CONTINUE TO
INVESTIGATE DOLLARS IN
PROGRAMMING IF WE HAVE NO CLUE
OF WHETHER THEY'RE SUCCESSFUL
OR WHETHER THEIR FAILURES TO
THAT POINT OUR STATE AUDITOR
CONDUCTED A COMPREHENSIVE AUDIT
AND SEVERAL COUNTING. AND FOUND
THAT THE COUNTIES LACK ADEQUATE
PLANNING AND OVERSIGHT FOR
REALIGNMENT SPENDING AND ARE
HOLDING EXCESSIVE REALIGNMENT
SURPLUSES WHICH COULD BE USED
TO IMPROVE PUBLIC SAFETY SHE
ALSO SAID IT IS INCUMBENT UPON
THIS LEGISLATURE TO BRING FULL
TRANSPARENCY THE TO THESE
PROGRAMS AND OUR SPENDING WE
HAVE SPENT OVER SIX. BILLION
DOLLARS IN STATE FUNDS AND HAVE
VERY LITTLE INFORMATION ON THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THIS
INVESTMENT THE AUDITOR'S REPORT
ALSO WENT TO SAY ON THAT THE
PRACTICES IN PROGRESS REPORTS
TO LAWMAKERS HAVE BEEN
INCONSISTENT AND INCOMPLETE.
THIS BILL WILL STANDARDIZE A
LOOK AT THESE PROGRAMS AND
PROVIDE VALUABLE INFORMATION
ABOUT THE SUCCESS. OF A
REHABILITATIVE SERVICES. MY
OFFICE IS WORK WITH THE IN.
DEVELOPED REPORTING WHICH GIVE
THE LIE. THE INFOR WE NEED TO
MAKE SOUNDS GOVERNING DECISIONS
AS WELL AS HAVE CLARITY FOR THE
COUNTIES AND HOW TO GATHER AND
SUBMIT THE DATA. MEMBERS THIS
BILL WILL ENSURE THAT WE CAN
HAVE THESE PROGRAMS WORK THAT
WE WILL HAVE BETTER OUTCOMES
REDUCE THE SIZE OF THE
INCARCERATED POPULATIONS. AND
MORE EFFECTIVELY SPEND STATE
DOLLARS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE. THANK YOU IS BURKE A
HEY MISTER COOPER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE AND SUPPORT THIS
BILL AND THINK MY COLLEAGUES TO
BRING IT FORWARD. IT'S
IMPORTANT THINK ABOUT
RECIDIVISM MOST FOLKS SINCE THE
COUNTY JAIL RIGHT NOW SOME AS
LONG AS FOURTEEN YEARS. WE HAVE
NO IDEA WITH RECIDIVISM RATE IS
WE KNOW IT'S HIGHS PROBABLY 70%
AT LEAST. VALUE BETTER PROGRAM
TO BE MORE EFFECTIVE WITH THIS.
AND I KNOW IT'S BIG RIGHT NOW
HOPEFULLY IT WORKS MORE ON IT'S
KIND NEARLY. BUT I KNOW FOR
STATE PRISON IF YOU'RE IF YOU
GO BACK AFTER TWO YEARS THAT'S
NOT CONSIDER RECIDIVISM. SO
HOPEFULLY WE NARAL THAT DOWN
AND GET IT MORE WORDS WERE
DEFECTIVE SO WE CAN STOP THE
VICIOUS CYCLE SO. THE BILLING
THIS BRING THIS BILL FORD AND
I- I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THEY WHICH COULD. SEEING OTHER
MEMBERS RECOGNITION. CLARK WELL
THE ROLE. THE DESIGN VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OF THOSE. THE
FIRM IS MAKING. ALL MEMBERS OUT
OF WELL. CLOSER TIDE OF A HIGHS
FIFTY NINE KNOWS. THAT MEASURE
PASSES. MISTER MAY FOR A CHANGE
YOUR RESIDENCE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER SPEAKER VOTE AB
SICK SIX NINE- I TO. BURKE
CHANGE THE SOME MEMBER MAIN
SHOW ASSEMBLY SIX NINE I TO
KNOW. MISTER. OF HOPE CHANGE AB
FOUR EIGHTY THREE I KNOW. FOR
CHANGE ASSEMBLY LIVING SOME OF
FORTY THREE I TO. MISTER
BENNETT. THE CHANGE SIMPLY BY A
FIVE FIVE NINE NO T<c.cyan>. VOCE</c>
ASSUMING THE BENNETT ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE NINE NO. TO MISS
PETER NORRIS- THAT CHANGE
PETRIE-NORRIS AB FOUR FOUR
THREE NOTE TO AYE AND FIVE
CHANGE PETRI. BOETSCH SUMMER
YOU KNOW ASSEMBLY BOTH FORTY NO
TO A- BUT BETWEEN OUR- AB SIX
OH TWO YES NOT THIRTY. BURKE
CHANGE ASSEMBLY REPEAT YOUR
DOORS SOME PEOPLE SIX OF TWO I
DO NOT KNOW. MISS DAVIES. VOTE
CHANGE AB.
SEVENTY TWO TO FIVE.
AB SEVEN TO CHANGE FROM OPPOSED
BY. PRO CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DAVIES ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY
TWO NO TIE. MISTER SERRA. MODE
CHANGE SB SIX OH TWO FROM HIGH
TO OBTAIN. BOTH CHANGE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SAY OUR TOES SOME WIGGLE
SIX OF TWO I TO NOT VOTING.
MODE CHANGE AB TEN EIGHTY TWO
FROM HIGH. TO NOT VOTING.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAY ARE TO SOME
LEGAL TEN EIGHTY TWO I TO NOT
VOTING.
MOVING BACK INTO FILE
ORDER WE ARE ON FILE ITEM
SEVENTY SEVEN. AB ONE TWENTY
THREE THE CLERK. SUMMER ONE
TWENTY THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LORENA GONZALEZ AN ACT RELATING
TO PAID FAMILY LEAVE A MAKING
AN APPROPRIATION- FOR ITS
GONZALES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB ONE
TWO THREE WOULD ALLOW WORKERS
USING THE STATE'S PAID FAMILY
LEAVE PROGRAM TO RECEIVE 90% OF
THEIR INCOME WHILE ON LEAVE.
ALTHOUGH EVERY SINGLE WORKER
PAYS INTO THIS PROGRAM TOO MANY
AT ESPECIALLY LOWER INCOME
WORKERS IN MIDDLE INCOME
FAMILIES CAN'T ACTUALLY ACCESS
IT THE REASON FOR THAT IS
BECAUSE WE PAY SIXTY SUPPOSEDLY
270% OF AN INDIVIDUAL'S INCOME.
YET EVEN IF YOU'RE A FULL TIME
MINIMUM WAGE WORKER MAKING
FOURTEEN DOLLARS AN HOUR YOU
WOULD ONLY RECEIVE EIGHT
DOLLARS AND FORTY CENTS THAT'S
NOT SOMETHING ESPECIALLY A NEW
PARENT CAN LIVE ON WHEN YOUR
EXPENSES ARE THE HIGHEST
THEY'VE EVER BEEN AND YOU'RE
ACTUALLY BEING PAID FAR LESS
THAN THE MINIMUM WAGE. I WOULD
ASK THAT ON THIS FLOOR WE'VE
DONE A LOT FOR PAID FAMILY
LEAVE WE'VE EXTENDED IT IN A
VARIETY OF FORMS BUT THE ONE
THING WE HAVEN'T DONE AND WE
NEVER DO. IS ENSURE THAT OUR
LOWEST INCOME WORKERS CAN
ACTUALLY ACCESS THE BENEFITS
THAT WE APPROVE. THAT'S WHAT'S
HAPPENING HERE. THE PEOPLE WHO
I WOULD ARGUE PROBABLY NEED
THIS THE MOST. AREN'T ABLE TO
ACCESS A BENEFIT THAT THEIR
PAIN UNTIL. IT'S TIME THIS
CHANGES WE'VE WAITED IN
INTRODUCED THIS BILL MULTIPLE
TIMES BINTA TOLD WE HAVE TO
EXTEND FAMILY WE HAVE TO DO
MORE PAID FAMILY LEAVE WE HAVE
TO MAKE SURE MORE WORKERS. CAN
ACTUALLY ACCESS FAMILY LEAVE
AND IT BE PROTECTED WE'VE DONE
ALL THOSE THINGS THIS IS
ACTUALLY THE EASIEST PORTION OF
IT. BECAUSE EVERY WORKER PAYS
INTO THIS. EVERY WORKER SHOULD
GAIN ENOUGH OUT OF IT THAT THEY
CAN ACTUALLY UTILIZE IT. I ASK
THAT YOU JOIN ME IN SUPPORTING.
PAID FAMILY LEAVE FOR EVERY
WORKER IN CALIFORNIA IN VOTE I.
THANK YOU MISS GONZALES SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THEIR ALL. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THIRTY VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THIRTIES ARE A. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY
THOSE FIVE FIFTY EIGHT
NOOSPHERE THE MEASURE PASSES.
WE WILL PASS AND RETAIN AND
FILE ITEM SEVENTY EIGHT.
THROUGH EIGHTY THREE WE HAVE
DISPENSED WITH FILE ITEM EIGHTY
FOUR WILL PASS THIRTEEN ON FILE
ITEMS EIGHTY FIVE THREE SEVEN
MOVING TO FILE ITEM EIGHTY
EIGHT EIGHTY TWO SIXTY EIGHT
THE CLERK WILL READ SOME OF
ROOM TO SIXTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IRWIN AND OTHERS
NAZARIAN RECORDS IF THERE WHEN
YOU ARE. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
AB TWO SIX EIGHT WHICH WILL
PROTECT THE PRIVACY OF MY
MURDERED CONSTITUENTS WHO DIED
IN THE BORDERLINE MASS SHOOTING
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN EXISTING LAW
ALLOWS FAMILIES THE OPTION TO
SEAL THE AUTOPSY RECORDS OF
THEIR MURDER CHILDREN. AB TWO
SIX EIGHT SIMPLY EXTENDS THE
PRIVILEGE TO VICTIMS OF ALL
AGES AFTER CONVICTION IS
SECURED OR THE CASE IS CLOSED
AFTER THE EVENTS OF THE
BORDERLINE MASS SHOOTING THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT INVESTIGATION
THE PUBLISHED REPORTS BY THE DA
AND THE SHERIFF IN MULTIPLE
NEWSPAPER STORIES THESE
FAMILIES CONTINUE TO BE
TORMENTED BY CONSPIRACY
THEORISTS. REQUESTING AUTOPSY
RECORDS IT'S LONG PAST TIME TO
LET THEM GRIEVE IN PEACE I WANT
TO STRESS THAT AB TWO SIX EIGHT
ONLY APPLIES TO THE DEATH THAT
IS THE RESULT OF A CRIMINAL
ACT. AND NOT OF NATURAL CAUSES
AN ACCIDENT OR ONE THAT IS SELF
INFLICTED THE VAST MAJORITY OF
AUTOPSY RECORDS WILL REMAIN
PUBLIC. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR IPHONE THANK YOU MISTER
AND MISTER. BENNETT YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIR THE I WOULD LIKE TO WRITE
IN- STRONG SUPPORT- AND
APPRECIATION OF MY COLLEAGUE
FROM THOUSAND OAKS WHO IS STATE
AFTER THIS ISSUE- FOR A COUPLE
OF YEARS NOW- TO TRY TO BENEFIT
THE FAMILY MEMBERS THAT ARE
LEFT BEHIND AFTER THE TRAGEDY
OF BORDERLINE SHE HAS DONE A
REMARKABLE JOB OF NARROWING THE
SCOPE OF THIS BILL DOWN TO THE
POINT WHERE IT TRULY APPLIES TO
THOSE SITUATIONS THAT I THINK
ALMOST ALL OF US WOULD AGREE A
DESERVE SOME EXTRA HELP. IN
TERMS OF PROTECTING THEM FROM
THE OF THE ABUSE OF PEOPLE THAT
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF- THESE
AUTOPSY RECORDS SO ISIS
STRONGLY- ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
MISTER BENNETT MISTRESS AFTER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
FOR SPEAKER MEMBERS THIS EMILY
HI STRAP STAND IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWO SIXTY EIGHT.
OVER MY TIME IN THE FIRE
SERVICE I INTERACTED WITH MANY
GRIEVING FAMILIES WHO HAVE LOST
A LOVED ONE. IN SOME OF THE
MOST DRAMATIC IN GRUESOME WAYS
YOU CAN IMAGINE. THEY WOULD
FINALLY LAY THEM TO REST. AND
GO THROUGH TRIALS. AND THEN
ONLY TO BE CONTINUALLY RE
TRAUMATIZED BY THE
SENSATIONALIZING OF THEIR DEATH
AND EXPLOITATION OF THEIR
AUTOPSY. THESE INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES DESERVE TO HAVE THEIR
MOST VULNERABLE MOMENTS
PROTECTED FROM INTERNET FOR
LAWYERS AND THOSE LOOKING TO
GAIN NOTORIETY. AT THE EXPENSE
OF GRIEVING FAMILIES. I'M PROUD
TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
THE DAY AND BRING SOME PEACE
BACK TO THESE FAMILIES AND
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR- HER
BRINGING THIS TO OUR- ARE THE
ASSEMBLY. IT IS FOR THOSE
REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER TERACO SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER IS OR WHEN WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. JUST ASK FOR DR
A CLERK WILL OPEN. MEMBERS
VOTED EITHER TO VOTE. HOME
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIGN TO
VOTE. OUR MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. BURKE WELL CLOSE ROLE
TALITHA I THINK FOUR NO ZERO
MEASURE PASS WILL PASS A RETAIN
A FILE A EIGHTY NINE ITEM
NINETY HAS BEEN JUST WITH
LITTLE CATHARINE ON FILE ITEM
NINETY ONE MOVING TO FILE ITEM
NINETY TWO. AB TWO NINETY THREE
THE CLERK WILL READ SOME PEOPLE
TO THREE BY SOMEONE RECALL AND
OTHER MACALIN THE FUNERAL LAW
IF YOUR CAR YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU. MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB TODAY THREE LIKELY
THE- WAS. FOR A- ABOUT FUNERAL
CHESTER. OUTLINED TRIGGERS FOR.
THE OF THE- AND ESTABLISH KERR
FOR. WITH THE OWNER OF THE
TRUCK. THE TONIGHT THREE
RESPONSE BY STICKING. BUT YEE.
HASN'T BY PART SUPPORT REFLECTS
WITH THE- AND MORTUARY.
ASSOCIATION ON OUR- AND REYES
OF THE BILL. BY DRESDNER'S LONG
SENATE ISSUE A TONIGHT THROUGH
A PART CONCERN. ANDERSON LOW
ONES OF PROVIDING. WAY T
LOCATE. AND CLAIM UNUSED
PREMIUM FUND. TYPICALLY
ASTRONOMICAL. THANK YOU MISTER
KALRA SINGING OVER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE WILL THE ROLE.
THERE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED AYE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE ARE.
TO GLOBAL THE ROLE AND HOW THE
VOTE I SIXTY KNOWS THE MEASURE
PASSES. PASS AND RETAIN A FILE
ITEM NINETY WE HAVE TO WITH
ITEM NINETY FOR NINETY PASS AND
RETAIN ON FILE NINETY SIX. WE
HAVE TO SPEND WITH FILE ITEM
NINETY THREE NINETY NINE MOVING
TO FILE I ONE. AB THREE FORTY
TO THE CLERK WILL READ SOME OF
THREE FORTY TWO BY. GIVE ACT
HEALTH COVER MISTER GIBSON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAMS MEMBERS I AM I RISE
TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
FORTY TWO WHICH SEEKS TO REMOVE
COST BARRIERS FOR PATIENTS. WHO
NEED A COLONOSCOPY IS REMOVING
THESE BARRIERS WILL HELP CATCH
CASES OF COLORECTAL CANCER
EARLY AND IMPROVE SURVIVAL
RATES I RISKS ALSO WANT TO
TAKE. THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT RESPECTFULLY.
ASK BUT I VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER GIBSON SEEING AND
HEARING NO DEBATE THE MATTER
WILL- OPEN THE ROLE. VERITABLE
ALL MEMBERS VOTE ARE. TO SOME
MEMBERS VOTED TO VOTE. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND HOW IT
AYE FIFTY SEVEN NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES WE DISPENSE WITH
FILE ITEM ONE OH ONE WE WILL
PASS RETAIN ON FILE ITEM ONE OH
TWO WE DISPENSED WITH FILE ITEM
ONE OF THREE WILL PASS AND
RETAIN A FILE ITEM WONDERFUL.
FILE ITEM ONE OF EIGHT THREE SO
NINE QUICK OVER SO MIDDLE
THREES NINE FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KAMLAGER AND
OTHER MEDICAL AMERICA. MR
SANTIAGO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THE MATTER. THANK YOU MAN
SPEAKER I RISE UP I RISE TO
PRESENT AB THREE SIXTY NINE THE
STREET MEDICINE ACT ON BEHALF
OF SENATOR KAMLAGER. ON AVERAGE
THERE IS ON AVERAGE PEOPLE
EXPERIENCE A HOMELESS
HOMELESSNESS HAVEN'T LIFE
EXPENSES OF THIRTY YEARS. AND
SHORTER. THAN THE HOUSE PEERS.
MOST CALMLY DO PREVENTABLE
ENTRY AND TREATABLE MEDICAL
CONDITIONS. THE PROGRAMS WERE
ADVOCATING FOR HAVE SHOWN TO
REDUCE AVOIDABLE EXPENSIVE
HOTELS EMISSIONS BY TWO THIRDS.
AND INCREASE HOUSING PLACEMENTS
FOR INDIVIDUALS. BASICALLY FOR
TRYING TO GIVE MEDICINE WHERE
PEOPLE ARE AT NO MATTER WHERE
THEY'RE AT THEY SHOULD READ
THEY DESERVE. ADEQUATE
HEALTHCARE COVERAGE AND
TREATMENT. AB THREE SIXTY NINE
WOULD ALLOW FOR STREET MEDICINE
TEAMS TO PROVIDE. THE
REIMBURSED CARE- WHENEVER IT'S
PROVIDED WHETHER IT'S AN IN
CAMERA AND A CAR OR UNDER
BRIDGE. RESPECTFULLY. ASK AN
ADULT. THANK YOU MAY SANTIAGO
SEEING AND HEARING NO DELAY ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. MEMBERS VOTED. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE ARE IT. OUR
MEMBERS OUT OF A. CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE TELLING VOTE I
SIXTY KNOWS THEM PASSES. WE
HAVE THE BEST A LETTER ONE OF
SIX PASS AND OF ITEM TO SEVEN
WE HAVE TO SPEND WITH FILE ITEM
ONE WAIT PASSERIDAE OUR FILING
ONE AND FIVE ITEM ONE TEN EIGHT
FOUR OH THIRDS WILL READ SOME
LEGAL TO BIAS AEROBICS AND
OTHER MEDICALLY ON AND SURE
MAKING APPROPRIATION- FOR NEXT
WEEK YOU ARE. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBER AB FOR TO A AND
AD FOR UNEMPLOYED CAL WITH ANY
BY CREATING THE OF HAVE. AND
THE CLAIMANTS BILL RIGHTS THIS
ALL IS CHARGED WITH A THE BILL
OF RIGHTS ANNUALLY REPORTING
SPACE IN FOR REAL TO REYES. AND
PAYMENT ASSISTANCE IDENTIFYING
MAKING RECOMMENDATIONS TO SOLVE
SYSTEMAX SYSTEMATIC ISSUES-
WITH NET I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU MISS
WHERE X. SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN. OWN
MEMBERS VOTED. TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED ARE. ALL MEMBERS
OF THE TO THEIR OF. BURKE CLOSE
THE ROLE IN THEM I SEE SIX ZERO
MEASURE PASS WILL THIRTY AND
FIVE ITEM ONE ELEVEN ITEM
TWELVE EIGHTY FOUR TWELVE WILL
READ SOME PEOPLE FOR TWO BY
REMEMBER ISN'T RELATING OF THIS
RACE YOU ARE. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS I PRESENT AB
FOR TWELVE WOULD STOP THE CAL
COME ON HUMAN RIGHTS. THE
COMMISSION SERVICE ADVISE BOARD
THERE WERE REVIEW THE STATUS OF
HUMAN ACROSS CALIFORNIA THE
BILL PASS ASSEMBLY COUNTY BILL
THE MINISTER REVIEW WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. HUMAN
RIGHTS IS THE CORNERS ASSIST IN
A GOVERNMENT. THIS COMMISSION
WOULD SERVE AS A TOOL TO ENSURE
A CALIFORNIA FOR ALL. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS RARE
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS GO
TO DESERVE A- ALL MEMBERS VOTE
MADERA. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
OBSERVER. ALL BURKE WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE AND TALITHA I FIFTY
NINE IS HERE THE MEASURE WE
DISPENSED WITH FILE ITEM ONE
THIRTEEN MOVING TO FILE ITEM
ONE FOURTEEN EIGHTY FOUR TWENTY
FOUR THE CLERK WILL READ SOME
PEOPLE FOR TWENTY FOUR BY SIN
REMEMBER STONE AND OTHERS
MEDICALLY THE STUDENT LOANS
IT'S JUST DOWN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS WHAT AB FOR
TWENTY FOUR DOES A SET SPECIFIC
EVIDENTIARY STANDARDS FOR
COLLECTION AGENCIES BRINGING
CASES AGAINST DEBTORS WHO HAVE
PRIVATE STUDENT LOANS TOO OFTEN
THOSE DEBTORS WHO ARE NOT
REPRESENTED BY COUNSEL. RECEIVE
INFORMATION THAT THEY ARE BEING
SUED BUT DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO
WITH IT AND WHAT HAPPENS IS
THAT THERE IS A DEFAULT
JUDGMENT ENTERED AGAINST THEM
BUT TOO OFTEN THE EVIDENCE THAT
IS BROUGHT TO THE DEFAULT
JUDGMENT IS WOEFULLY LACKING
AND OFTENTIMES THE COLLECTION
AGENCY CAN'T EVEN PROVE THAT
THEYOWN THE DEBT THIS WILL
SOLVE A LOT OF THE PROBLEMS IN
THAT PROCESS IN ENSURING THAT
THERE ARE INIMUM EVIDENTIARY
STANDARDS FOR BRINGING A CASE
SUCH AS THAT. SO THAT SHOULD
THERE BE A DEFAULT JUDGMENT IT
WILL BE ABLE TO BE CORRECTLY
APPLIED TO THE CORRECT BETTER
IN THAT. SITUATION I ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK MR STERN.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FOR
DEBATE ON THE CLERK WILL OPEN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO GO. OUR
MEMBERS TO THEIR OF THE. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THAT ICE NINE KNOWS THIRTEEN
THAT MEASURE PASSES. WE HAVE
DISPENSED WITH FILE ITEM. ONE
FIFTEEN. WE WILL PASS A
RETAINER VIOLATE ONE SIXTEEN
MOVING- HIGHLIGHTED. ONE
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY FOUR FORTY SIX
THE PERCHLORATE. FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTEEN IS AB FOUR FOUR SIX
FOR PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS. MR
MAYS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
PURPOSES OF THE CORPORATION
SOME PEOPLE FOR FORTY SIX FOR
THE MINUTES BY SEMIRAMIS.
SURVEYS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN
THE MINUTES I THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE PRESENTE- ALL
MEMBERS TO EIGHTY FOUR FOUR
SIX. WHICH DRAFTED BY SECRETARY
STAYING CONSULTATION WITH THE
ASSEMBLY ELECTIONS COMMITTEE
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL ON THESE
AMENDMENTS. WITHOUT AND- WE
WILL A BOY VOTE ON THE CEMENT.
ALL IN FAVOR SAY AYE. I OPPOSED
SAY NO. MAN MENTOR DOT OUT TO
PRINT IMPACT ON FILE. WE HAVE
DISPENSED WITH FIVE ITEM
EIGHTEEN MOVIE TO VIOLATE ONE
NIGHT EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY SEVEN
CLERK WILL READ SOME OF THE
FOUR FIFTH SEVEN SOME OF SANTI
WHEN I. TO HEALTH SANTIAGO YOU
ARE. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB
FIFTY A FORTY SEVEN WHICH THAT
THE OF PATIENT CHOI. TELEHEALTH
TO PROVIDE ACT TO ENSURE THAT
PATIENTS RECEIVE ADEQUATE IF
THIS TELEHEALTH SERVICES. AS
TELEHEALTH EXPAND THIS BILL
WOULD PLACE IMPORTANT
SAFEGUARDS THE PATIENT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY GET THE
CONTINUITY OF CARE I DID THEY
DESERVE. THANK YOU MR SANTIAGO
IS AGUIAR-CURRY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR CHAMBER.
I WANT TO THANK THE GENTLEMAN
FROM LOS ANGELES RINGING FOR AB
FOUR FIFTY SEVEN FORD. IT IS NO
SECRET HOW PASSIONATELY I FEEL
ABOUT PROVIDING GREATER ACCESS
TO TELEHEALTH. ESPECIALLY FOR
WORKING FAMILIES FOLKS AND
COMMUNITIES WITH LESS ACCESS TO
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS.
ESPECIALLY SPECIALISTS AND
PEOPLE WITH MOBILITY ISSUES.
BUT THE POINT OF THIS EFFORT IS
TO EXPAND PATIENTS ABILITY
CONSULT VIRTUALLY WITH THEIR
DOCTOR OR NURSE OR ANOTHER THEY
CHOOSE. NOT ONE CHOSEN BY A
HEALTH PLAN FROM A THIRD PARTY
CORPORATE TELEHEALTH PROVIDER.
I ASK THE ARRIVAL. THANK YOU
MISS AGUIAR-CURRY SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER MR SANTIAGO WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THE THUNDER
WAS TAKEN BY MY COLLEAGUE WHO
DID A THE A- REALLY GOOD
CLOSING FOR ME. SO I
RESPECTFULLY WOULD ASK WHEN I
VOTE THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
OUT OF THE MONEY. WHERE WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE AND HOW THAT I
FIFTY KNOWS THE MEASURE PASSES.
PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE ITEM
ONE TWENTY FIVE ITEM TWENTY ONE
AB FOR SEVENTY QUICKLY SOME OF
THE FORCE OF BY SOME MEMBER
KERR AND OTHERS AND I IN ABOUT.
THIS CAREER YOU ARE. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS IT IS A
BUSY DAY ON THE FOR TODAY. I AM
A PROUD PRESENT THEM FIRST FOR
SOME WHICH ALLOW LOW IN SENIORS
AND PEOPLE WITH THAT THE WHO
ARE MOST READ SPARKLE NINETEEN
TO ACCESS SERVICES WHILE
MAINTAINING THEIR DIGNITY AND
FINANCIAL STABILITY BY
ELIMINATING THE OUTDATED
MEDICAL ASSETS TEST THE KERN
MEDICAL ASSETS LIMITS
WRONGFULLY PREVENT SENIORS FROM
HAVING ADEQUATE RESOURCES TO
WHETHER A CRISIS SUCH AS AN
EVICTION A LEAKING ROOF OR A
MAJOR VEHICLE REPAIR ONCE AN
ADULT'S EARNS SIXTY FIVE OR
BECOMES MEDICA MEDICARE
ELIGIBLE. THEIR MEDICAL
ELIGIBILITY IS DETERMINED BY
THIS RESTRICTED SET OF RULES
THAT REQUIRES THEM TO HAVE
MINIMAL ASSETS TO REMAIN
ELIGIBLE BE UNINTENDED RESULT
IS THAT PEOPLE WHO WANT TO
REMAIN MEDICAL L. ELIGIBLE
DEPLETE ALL OF THE RESOURCES TO
CONTINUE TO RECEIVE THESE
BENEFITS I WOULD LIKE TO SHARE
A STORY OF AN OLDER ADULTS WITH
AN ANNUAL INCOME OF SEVEN
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED WHICH
UNDER THE NON MODIFIED ADJUSTED
GROSS. INCOME. MEDICAL INCOME
LIMIT UNFORTUNATELY. I THIS
INDIVIDUAL AS ABLE TO. FOR
MEDICAL DURING THE PANDEMIC
BECAUSE YOU TOOK OUT RESERVISTS
OUT OF HER MORTGAGE ON HER HOME
TO PAY FOR BASIC NECESSITIES.
AND MAKE ESSENTIAL HOME REPAIRS
THIS AVERAGE THIS REVERSE
MORTGAGE COMBINED WITH HER
EXISTING ASSETS TOTALED ABOUT
TWENTY TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS.
CONSEQUENTLY DISQUALIFYING HER
FROM MEDICAL SERVICES UNDER THE
CURRENT ASSETS LIMIT AND LEAVE
IT LEAVING HER WITH ONLY ONE
VIABLE OPTION. TO SPEND DOWN
HER MONEY TO TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
THIS IS JUST ONE OF MANY
STORIES OF INDIVIDUALS FACING
SUCH CHALLENGES WE'RE LIVING
DURING A TIME WHETHER WHERE
OLDER ADULTS AND PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES. ARE FACING HIGHER
RISK BECAUSE OF PUBLIC PUBLIC%
NINETEEN COMPLICATIONS. IT IS
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT TO THAT
MEDICAL PROGRAMS TO NOT IMPOSE
ADDITIONAL BARRIERS TO ENTRY
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
HAS RECEIVED. BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTED TO VERIFY. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS TO THEIR TO VOTE. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE AND THE ICE SIX
ZERO MEASURE PASS WILL PASS AND
RETAIN AND FILA ONE TWO TWO
WE'VE TO WITH FILE ITEM ONE
THREE PASSED. ON FILE ONE TWO
FOUR WE DISPENSED WITH BY ITEMS
WERE TWENTY FIVE ONE TWO SIX TO
FILE ITEM ONE TWO SEVENTEEN
FORTY EIGHT THE COURT WILL READ
SOME A BILL FOR EIGHTY EIGHT BY
MEMBER AND INSURABLE- WHEN YOU
ARE A- THANK YOU SPEAKER TODAY
PRESENT AB FOR ABA. OF THAT
WILL- UPDATE OUR STATE LAWS ON
CHARITABLE GIVING TO ACCOUNT
FOR NEW ONLINE METHODS OF
DONATING WHILE PROVIDING
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS TO BOTH
DONORS AND CHARITIES
CONVERSATIONS ARE STILL ONGOING
WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO MAKE
REFINEMENTS TO THE BILL. AND
THIS BILL IS A WORK PRODUCTOF
NEARLY FOUR YEARS A AN EFFORT
BY MY OFFICE AND THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE I.
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER ABOUT.
THANK YOU MISS IRWIN C. IN
HEARING NO. DEBATE ON THE
MATTER CLERK WILL OPEN THE- ALL
MEMBERS VOTED VERA. ALL MEMBERS
HE FIRED ABOUT. YOU HAVE YET
ALL MEMBERS VOTED OF A. THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE AND THAT
FOR SIX NEW FIFTEEN THAT
MEASURE PASS. CATHERINE ON FILE
ITEM TWENTY EIGHT DISPENSED
WITH FILA ONE TWENTY NINE
MOVING TO FILE A ONE THREE AB
NINETY A QUICK WILL RAISE SOME
OF FOR NINETY NINE BY OF OUR OF
AND I WILL SOURCE. THIS RUBIO
YOU ARE A- IN THE THIRD DESK.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON I THE
SPEAKER THE ANDTHANK YOU FO
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL FOUR NINETY NINE
LEGISLATION WILL WALK. CONSUMER
AT SEEN KERR RIFF A-
RESIDENTIAL CARE FOR THE
ELDERLY ARE NON MEDICAL FOR.
THAT'S BY IN HOUSING PRINT
PERSONAL SUPPORT SERVICE IN
THIS IN A OF DAILY. SUCH AS THE
DRESSED WALKING AND SO ON RCF
EASE OUR LIFE INSPECTED AND
REGULATED BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
THIS LEGISLATION WOULD ALLOW
FOR MORE TRANSPARENCY IN THE
AXIS OF INFORMATION FOR
CONSUMERS SEEKING PLACEMENT AT
A RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITY THE
BILL HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS. THANK YOU MAYES RUBIO
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. THIS VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS TO THEIR TO VOTE. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND HOW
THAT I SIXTY KNOWS THE MEASURE.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE ONE A
FIVE THE COURT WILL READ. SOME
PEOPLE FIVE HUNDRED BY SOME WAR
AND OTHERS HOUSING THROUGH OUR
NEW IRAQ. THANK YOU MANSKE AB
FOR HUNDRED WILL HELP US
MYSTERY THE REGULATORY SOCIAL
DEVELOPMENT PERMIT PROCESS FOR
EIGHTY YEARS JUNIOR EDUS IN
SUPPORT OF HOUSING WITHIN THE
COASTAL ZONE I AM WORKING WITH
THE COASTAL COMMISSION TO MAKE
SURE THEIR REQUIREMENTS SELF A
SIMPLE AN EXPEDITIOUS. AB FIVE
HUNDRED WILL ALSO REINSTATE
COSTA LOCKED AFFORDABLE HOUSING
POLICIES REPEAL FORTY YEARS AGO
AND WILL GIVE THE COMMISSION
THE AUTHORITY TO PROTECT
EXISTING AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
ENSURE THAT NEW AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IS CONSISTENT WITH
COASTAL ACT POLICIES WE KNOW
THAT CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO
EXPERIENCE A SEVERE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CRISIS WITH THE
DEFICIENCY OF THREE MILLION
HOMES AND GROWING. THIS ISSUE
IS EXACERBATED IN RESIDENTIAL
AREAS OF THE COASTAL ZONE WHERE
THE DEVELOPMENTS FACE
ADDITIONAL CHALLENGES THE BILL
RETAIN SUPPORT FOR EVALUATION
AND PROTECTIONS OF SENSITIVE
AND NATURAL RESOURCES AND TO
ENSURE THAT NOT JUST VISITORS
SERVING ACCOMMODATIONS BUT ALSO
RESIDENTIAL ACCESS TO THE COAST
IS BETTER AFFORDED TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS. I AM COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS
OF THE BILL MOVES TO THE SENATE
AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST- I
BUILT ON EIGHTY FIVE HUNDRED.
THANK YOU MISTER. SEEING NUMBER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER WILL- THE-
MEMBERS VOTED TO VOTE. HOME
VOTED THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MY
VOTED ARTICLE. HI MOM BURKE
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE TALITHA I
FORTY TWO NEWS THAT MEASURE.
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY TWO FIVE
OH ONE CORPORATION SOME PEOPLE
FIVE OH ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
UNIVERSE AND I RELATING REMAINS
IN MAKING APPROPRIATE- FOR. ITS
GARCIA YOU ARE. MEMBERS FIVE A
ONE PROVIDE A ADDITIONAL OPTION
FOR K. RESIDENTS. THAT IS
ENVIRONMENT FRIENDLY GIVES AN
CHOI FOR BURKE. THE MEASURE
WILL ALLOW AND- TO BE OR GET.
THE ALSO TO AS THE READ F
REMAINS. AFTER THIS NATURAL
PROCESS IS COMPLETE FAMILY I
LOVE ONE OF THE- MAYBE
INTEGRATED MAY ENTER THE REMAIN
OF THE SAUDI WHEN. A TREE OR A
GARDEN EVERY MEMBERS OF THE
LOVE ONE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER.
C. HEARING NO DELAY ON THE
MATTER CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR IT.
ALL MEMBERS OF ARE VOTE. WORK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND HOW THE
VOTE I FIFTY NINE NEWS HERE
THAN A PASSES WE'RE GOING TO
PASS A AND FILING ONE THIRTY
THREE WE'VE WITH ITEM ONE
THIRTY FIVE ITEM WHEN THEY FIVE
FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ. SOME
PEOPLE FIVE TWENTY BY SOME
GIPSON AND ACT THE TEACHER
DEVELOP IT'S A GOOD THING YOU
ARE. THANK YOU FOR MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS YOU FOR ME TO
PER ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE TWIN
WHICH LOOKS A CARE TO. TEACHER
WORK WORK I GRANT PRO THIS HAS
ENJOYED YOU KNOW BY SUPPORT
BOTH INNOCENTLY AS A COMMITTEE
AND THE COMMITTEE TODAY
STUDENTS OF MAKES UP SEVENTY
PER OF. STUDENT POPULATION BUT
MEN OF COLOR REPRESENTS LESS
THAN 10% OF CALIFORNIA'S
TEACHING WORKFORCE OF THAT 10%
AFRICAN AMERICANS AND LATINO
BAND MAKES UP ONE TO TWO
PERCENT. THESE ARE STARTLING
NUMBERS THE REASON IS THAT-
BLACKS AND LATINO EDUCATORS
FILL OUT NOT VALUE THIS BILL
SEEKS TO SUPPORT DIVERSITY IN
THE TEACHING WORKFORCE TO HELP
BENEFIT OUR STUDENTS WHEN
STUDENTS CAN IDENTIFY WITH
THEIR STE WITH THEIR TEACHERS
AND SEE THEMSELVES AS ROLE
MODELS THEY ARE ULTIMATELY MORE
SUCCESSFUL IN SCHOOL. THIS IS
TRULY WHERE THE POWER COMES
FROM AB FIVE TWENTY WOULD
PROVIDE SCHOOLS WITH TOOLS TO
HELP THEM BUILD A MORE DIVERSE
TEACHER POPULATION AND RETAIN
TEACHERS IN THIS PROFESSION FOR
STUDENTS SO THEY CAN SEE
THEMSELVES AS ROLE MODELS AS
WELL AS IN THE TEACHING
PROFESSION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
THAT I VOTE ON A. B. FIVE
TWENTY. THANK YOU MISTER GIPSON
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE ALL MEMBERS
VOTED EITHER TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VERY TO VOTE. HOME GO
TO THE ART OF A. WHERE CLOSER
ROLE AND HOW THE ICE EIGHT NO
THEIR THEM PASSED. YEAH MOVING
THE FILE. WE'RE GONNA FILE ITEM
ONE THIRTY SIX EIGHTY FIVE
TWENTY THREE THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE TWENTY
THREE BY ZIMMERMAN'S ARIAN AND
ACCOLADE TO THE ELDERLY MISTER
THEREIN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER. AB
FIVE TWENTY THREE MAKES
PERMANENT THE FLEXIBILITIES
THAT HAVE ALLOWED FOR PEACE
ORGANIZATIONS TO RESPOND TO THE
COVERED NINETEEN CRISIS AND AT
THE SAME TIME PROVIDE CARE TO
MORE PARTICIPANTS THE STATUTES
THAT STATUTORY CHANGES PROPOSED
BY THE BILL WILL ALLOW THESE
FLEXIBILITIES TO CONTINUE
FOLLOWING. AT THE END OF THE
HEALTH EMERGENCY SIMPLY PACE IS
A STANDOUT MODEL AS WE
REIMAGINE HEALTHCARE IN
CALIFORNIA THIS BILL HAS
ENJOYED UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER NAZARIAN
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN. ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. YEAH YEAH-
THREE FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN
THROUGH WHERE WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE AND HOW YOU THAT I SIXTY
KNOWS THE MEASURE THEM WE ARE
MOVING BACK UP IN FILE TO FIVE
ITEM ONE. EIGHT FOUR THIRTY
EIGHT THE CLERK WILL READ SOME
REAL FOURTH EIGHT BY C. RAILS
AND I SCHOOL EMPLOYEE MR IF YOU
ARE A THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
REMEMBER I'VE HEARD EIGHT FOUR
EIGHT AND I PRETTY MUCH WOULD
STEP WOULD STANDARD THE LAYOFF.
AND EXTENSIVE HEARING RIGHTS TO
CLASSIFY THEM SAID THE SAME PER
ARE FOR ALL SCHOOLS IN. THIS
BILL PAY OUT OF A SOME PER
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT
WITH BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
ENSURES THAT ALL SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES REGARDLESS OF THE JOB
TITLE ARE GRANTED THE SAME
LAYOFF NOTICE AND WORKER
PROTECTIONS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
RESI IN HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
ABOUT TO VOTE. ON AVERAGE
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE CLERK WILL
LOSE THEIR ROLE AND HOW IT IS
FORTY FOUR KNOWS NINE THAT
MEASURE PASSES. WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO FILE OR- WE WILL BE AND
RETAIN VIOLATE ONE THIRD.
SEVEN
WAIT S. STRIKE THAT WE WILL BE
TAKING UP FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY
SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE TWENTY FIVE
THE CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE TWENTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHIU AND OTHERS
AN ACTIVITY TO ENERGY. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES WE DON'T
HAVE THAT MANY OPPORTUNITIES TO
WORK ON MATTERS THAT WILL
HOPEFULLY HAVE AN IMPACT LONG
AFTER WE'RE GONE. BUT AS THE
NINETEEN CO AUTHORS WERE BILL
OF DISCUSS THIS IS HOPEFULLY
ONE OF THEM. AB FIVE TWENTY
FIVE WILL JUMP START A NEW
CLEAN ENERGY INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA BY DIRECTING THE
STATE TO PREPARE A STRATEGIC
OFFSHORE WIND. THIS YEAR IN THE
MIDST OF COVER NINETEEN OF THE
LOSS OF OVER A MILLION JOBS.
OUR STATE HAS EXPERIENCED
INTENSE CLIMATE CONDITIONS.
HEAT WAVES WILDFIRES ROLLING
BLACKOUTS. TO ADDRESS CLIMATE
CRISIS AND PUT PEOPLE BACK TO
WORK WE HAVE A ONCE IN A.
GENERATION OPPORTUNITY JUST
TWENTY TO THIRTY MILES OFF OUR
COAST. CALIFORNIA'S ACCESS TO
ONE OF THE WORLD'S GREATEST
UNTAPPED SOURCES OF RENEWABLE
ENERGY. OFFSHORE WIND WITH THE
POTENTIAL TO COMBAT CLIMATE
CHANGE MEET CLEAN ENERGY GOALS
AND PROVIDE GOOD PAYING JOBS.
IN EUROPE AND ASIA MANY
COUNTRIES ARE FAR AHEAD OF THE
UNITED STATES. BUT FORTUNATELY
THE BY DEMONSTRATION HAS
ANNOUNCED BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
OF INVESTMENT IN THIS AREA.
WELL EAST COAST STATES OF
ALREADY ESTABLISHED TWENTY NINE
GIGAWATTS OF TARGETS IN
OFFSHORE WIND. CALIFORNIA HAS A
CHANCE TO CATCH UP PARTICULARLY
WITH THIS WEEK'S ANNOUNCEMENT
BY THE WHITE HOUSE AND OUR
GOVERNOR TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
LEASE OPTIONS OFFER COAST. WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
STATE'S NOT LEFT BEHIND.
OFFSHORE WIND CAN ENSURE A
DIVERSE RELIABLE PORTFOLIO OF
CLEAN POWER. COMPLEMENTING
SOLAR WITH WIND ENERGY AT NIGHT
WHEN THE SUN IS DOWN. IT WILL
ADD THOUSANDS OF HIGH SKILLED
JOBS IN SUPPLY CHAIN
DEVELOPMENT CONSTRUCTION
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE.
THIS BILL WILL MAKE SURE THAT
WE TAP INTO ALL OF THE BENEFITS
OF OFFSHORE WIND WHILE GIVING
CONSIDERATION CAREFULLY TO OUR
STATES MARINE AND COASTAL
ECOSYSTEMS AND PRIORITIZING
DEVELOPMENT IN AREAS OF THESE
CONFLICT. AS WE TALK ABOUT A
JUST TRANSITION I WANT TO THANK
THE COALITION OF LABOR
ENVIRONMENTAL AND CLEAN ENERGY
ORGANIZATIONS AS WELL AS A
STRONG BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
THROUGH THIS PROCESS BY
ESTABLISHING A PLAN TO HARNESS
THE POWER OF OFFSHORE WIND THIS
BILL WILL ALLOW US TO JUMP
START THE NEW CALIFORNIA
INDUSTRY. AND MEET THE CLEAN
ENERGY GOALS OF OUR STATE AND
COUNTRY WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER SHIRO MISTER
CUNNINGHAM YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
AS A PROUD JOIN AUTHOR OF AB
FIVE TWENTY FIVE AND I JUST
WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS MADE
BY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM SAN
FRANCISCO. AND ALSO ADD A
LITTLE BIT OF URGENCY TO THIS.
IN TWENTY TWENTY FIVE THE LAST
NUCLEAR POWER PLANT IN
CALIFORNIA THE OUTLOOK AND
NUCLEAR POWER PLANT WILL CLOSE
IN MY DISTRICT. WITHOUT CLOSURE
WE WILL LOSE 9% OF THE STATE'S
CARBON FREE ENERGY OVERNIGHT.
IF WE DON'T START INVESTING AND
INVESTING NOW. IN NEW CLEAN
ENERGY TECHNOLOGIES LIKE THE
PROMISE OF OFFSHORE WIND. WE
ARE GOING TO BE IN A DIRE
CIRCUMSTANCE HALFWAY THROUGH
THIS DECADE WITH RESPECT TO
ENERGY PROCUREMENT IN OUR
STATE. WE ALL MAY REMEMBER THE
TWO THOUSAND ONE ENERGY CRISIS
AND NONE OF US WANT TO RELIVE
IT. SO LET'S VOTE FOR THIS
TODAY I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST.
YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
AND LET'S MOVE TOWARDS A
CLEANER FUTURE WHERE WE PRODUCE
THE NUMBER OF ELECTRONS WE NEED
FOR OUR STATE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER CUNNINGHAM SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER. CLERK WILL OPEN
THEIR OWN. VOTED OUT OF IT. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THIRTY DESERVE A-
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TWO THOUGH TO SIXTY ONE KNOWS
HERE THAN I PASSES WILL PASS
AND RETAIN A FILER ONE THIRTY
EIGHT THROUGH FORTY TWO PASSED.
ON FILE ITEM ONE FORTY THREE
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE FORTY
FOUR EIGHTY FIVE SIXTY TWO THE
BURGLARIES ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
SIXTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LO
AND OTHERS AND ACCORDING TO
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AND TO
CLEAR THE HERE OF THICK THICK
IMMEDIATELY HELLO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
COLLEAGUES AND MEMBERS THS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE SIXTY TWO
ON. MENTAL HEALTH RESILIENCY
AND HELPING SUPPORT OUR FROM MY
RESPOND AS I'D LIKE TO THANK
OUR PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR FROM
RIBBON FOR HIS ADVOCACY IN THIS.
AREA I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU MAY. WERE SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
ALL MEMBERS GO TO VERIFY. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED THIRD OF A. ALL
MY RESEARCH TO THEIR TO THE.
OKAY WELL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
HOW OUT I FIFTEEN NEWS ON THE
URGENCY FIVE FIFTY NINE ZERO
THE BILL THAT MEASURE PASSES
MOVIE A FILE ITEM ONE FIVE
EIGHTY FIVE SIX THREE OF PURPLE
RAIN SOME FIVE SIXTY THREE BY
MEMBER BERMAN OTHERS NATALIE
SCHOOL HOW MR BERMAN YOU ARE.
THANK THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
GOT A GREAT TRIBE. SUPPORTED
HERE- SCHOOL BASED SERVE PLAY
KEY ROLE IN THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS ARE RIGHT TO LEARN. K.
THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOLS ARE ALL
OF TO RECEIVE FEDERAL. FOR
HEALTH SERVICES. PROVIDED AS
SITES THE REPORT CALLED THE LOW
AND AGE MEDIC BILLING OPTION
FOR. SET UP THREE TIMES.
HOWEVER IN CALIFORNIA THERE'S
NO INSTITUTIONALIZED
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE
DEPARTMENT HEALTHCARE SERVICES
WHICH OVERSEES MEDIC AL AND THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO COORDINATE HEALTH
SERVICES DELIVERED THROUGH
SCHOOLS. TO FILL THIS GAP
EIGHTY FIVE SIXTY THREE WOULD
ESTABLISH AN OFFICE OF SCHOOL
BASED HEALTH PROGRAMS WITHIN
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO ENSURE GREATER
ACCESS TO HEALTH SERVICES IN
SCHOOLS. AND DRAW DOWN MORE
FEDERAL FUNDS A WIN WIN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MR BERMAN SINGING OVER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER WILL THE
ROLE. MEMBERS VOTED. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED DESERT OF THE.
WHERE WELL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TELEVOTE EYES FIFTY NINE NEWS
HERE THAT MEASURE PASSES AND WE
ALL LEARNED A NEW WORD TRY
PERSON. WE HAVE DISPENSED WITH
FIVE ITEM ONE FOR SIX ONE FORTY
SEVEN WILL MOVE TO FILE ONE
FORTY EIGHT AB FIVE SEVENTY
NINE THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE SEVENTY NINE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FLORA AND
ABILITY TO FIRE PREVENTION.
MISTER FOR NOW YOU'RE READY YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I APOLOGIZE- AS ONCE
THEY COME. I THINK THAT'S A
RESOURCE APPROPRIATIONS FOR AND
THEIR STAFF FOR THEIR EFFORT ON
THIS BILL- CAL FIRE OVER THE
LAST NUMBER OF YEARS AND FOR
THOSE OF YOU KNOW THAT WE WERE-
WERE PUBLISHED WORK WITH THE
ORGANIZATION. THEY HAVE A
PROCUREMENT ISSUE AND A LOT OF
TIMES WE NEED TO BUY OUTSIDE OF
THE STATE THIS BILL JUST SIMPLY
ALLOWS THEM TO PURCHASE
EQUIPMENT. OUTSIDE OF. THE M.
THE PRISON INDUSTRY SO
BRIDGEPORT. THANK YOU MR FOR A
SINGLE HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THEIR- MEMBERS VOTED
TO THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
GO TO DESERVE A. CALL ME VOTED
TO THEIR VOTE. THE CLERK WILL
CLOSE ROLL INTO THEIR THINK
KNOWS THAT MEASURE PASS. WE
WILL PASS AND RETAIN AND BY
ITEMS WERE FORTY NINE AND ONE
FIFTH WE DISPENSED WITH FILE
WANTED ONE WILL PAY THIRTEEN A
PILOT ONE FIFTY FIVE ITEM ONE
TWO THREE SIX. CIRCLE REYES
SOME OF SIX BY SOME THREE AND I
HIGH EDUCATION POINT. MISTER
RODRIGUEZ YOU ARE. RECOGNIZED
THE YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBER. SB SIX FIFTEEN SIMPLY
PER MANY APPOINT RIGHTS TO ME
IN DENTAL WHO WORK A HIGHER IN
EMPLOYER. THESE AND WHO WORK
HIRED TO GET THIS GOES AND- FOR
LICENSING ARE NOT OF BASIC
RIGHT DISCIPLINE OR- OF A THAT
COULD NEGATIVELY IMPACT FUTURE
OPPORTUNITIES TO SOMETHING
MINOR THE UNRELATED TO THE
CLINIC PRACTICE PATIENT OR ARE.
THE SPONSORS ARE WORK WITH THE
POINT ON MY WAY TO ADDRESS THE
CAN. AND ANTICIPATE COMPANY WE
WORK ON THE SAN ARE STILL AS
PRIVATE. US RODRIGUEZ SEEING IN
HERE NO FURTHER DEBATE ON A THE
CAR WILL- OPEN THE- ALZHEIMER'S
VOTE OR TO VOTE. HOME MEMBERS
VOTE TO GUARD A. JUST ALL
MEMBERS SAID HE DESERVE A.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLLING TALLY
VOTE I FORTY KNOWS THAT PASSED
WE'VE THIS WITH ITEM FIFTY FOUR
MOVING UP ITEM. FIFTY FIVE. TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK
YOU MR GARCIA THING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTED A VERITABLE. HOME
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE A.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESERVE A.
CLERK WILL. LOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTES I FIFTY FOUR
NOTES TO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
LIVING A FILE WE WILL PASS A
RETAINER FILE AND ONE FIFTY SIX
MOVING TO VIOLATE ONE FIFTY
SEVEN EIGHTY SIX FORTY TO THE
CLERK WILL READ SOME PEOPLE SIX
FORTY TWO BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN AND OTHERS
IMMACULATELY TO WILDFIRES THREE
MEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
EIGHTY SIX FORTY TWO IS AN
OMNIBUS WILDFIRE BILL. THAT
MAKES VARIOUS CHANGES TO
SUPPORT CULTURAL PRESCRIBED
BURNS ARE PROTECT MUNITION
WILDFIRE BESIDES MAKING IT
EASIER TO PERMIT FOR PRESCRIBED
BURNS BETWEEN ORDER PORTENT
PART OF PREVENTING WILDFIRES
THE BILL ALSO HELPS ENCOURAGE
AND SUPPORT HOME HARDENING
ACROSS OUR STATE MEMBERS WITH
THAT I WOULD. REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
FRIEDMAN WAS FOR YOU RECOGNIZE.
THE MAN SPEAKER I RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND
IF YOU TALK TO ANYBODY COMING
OUT OF THE WILD FIRE- INDUSTRY.
WHILE PUTTING THE LIVE FIRE ON
THE GROUND AS ONE THE BEST WAYS
YOU CAN DO VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT IT'S VERY VERY
PRACTICAL WHEN DONE SAFELY THIS
BILL ALLOWS US TO DO THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MR FOR US SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
MISS FRIEDMAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED AMERICA.
ALL MEMBERS GO TO THIRD OF. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED VERY VOTE. WHERE
WILL. CLOSE THE ROLLING TALLY
THE VOTE I FIFTY FOUR NEWS HERE
THE MEASURE PASSES WE HAVE
DISPENSED WITH FILE ITEM ONE
FIFTY EIGHT WILL PASS AND
RETAIN A FILE ITEMS ONE FIFTEEN
NINETY ONE SIXTY MOVING TO
VIOLATE ONE SIXTY ONE EIGHTY
SIX SEVENTY THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY RULE SIX SEVENTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON
ACTIVITIES CHILD ABUSE OR
NEGLECT CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS SB SIX
SEVENTY SIX PROVIDE PROTECTIONS
FOR PARENTING FOSTER MINORS AND
NON MINOR DEPENDENTS. PARENTING
FOSTER YOU STRUGGLE TO ACCESS.
BASIC SUPPORTS NEEDED FOR THEM
AND THEIR CHILDREN TO THRIVE.
CONSEQUENTLY THESE YOUNG
PARENTS ARE AT HIGH RISK OF
LOSING TEMPORARY OR EVEN
PERMANENT CUSTODY OVER THEIR
CHILDREN. EIGHTY SIX SEVENTY
SIX TO CLOSE GAPS IN EXISTING
LAW. TO SUPPORT THE
PRESERVATION OF THESE FAMILY
UNITS. THIS BILL THAT HAS THUS
FAR RECEIVED UNANIMOUS SUPPORT
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER CALDERON SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHO DESERTED THE. WELL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE I
SIXTY NEWS ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. WILL PASS THIRTEEN AND
FILE ITEMS ONE SIXTY TWO
THROUGH ONE SIXTY FIVE MINUTE
FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY SIX EIGHTY
SEVEN SIXTEEN THE CLERK WILL
CREATE SOME MIDDLE SEVEN
SIXTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BENNETT AND I BELIEVE IN THE
COURTS. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU CHAIR. I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN ONE SIX IT
WOULD REQUIRE COURTS TO PROVIDE
REMOTE ACCESS TO HEARINGS VIA
AUDIO STREAM TO OPEN
PROCEEDINGS AND IT STRIKES A
BALANCE BETWEEN MEDICAL
MEANINGFUL ACCESS AND COURT
FLEXIBILITY. WITHOUT LIMITING A
JUDGE'S ABILITY TO HOLD CLOSED
PROCEEDINGS THE BILL'S RECEIVE
NO- NO VOTES AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION ON RECORD. I'VE
THANK YOU BENNETT SEEING
HEARING NO FURTHER DELAY ON THE
MATTER THE CLERK WILL THE ROLE.
MEMBERS. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TELL YOU THAT I SIXTY
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES. WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO FILE ITEM ONE
SIXTY SEVEN AB SEVEN SEVENTEEN
FOR PURPOSES OF AMENDMENTS THE
CLERK WILL READ. SOME OF THOSE
SEVEN SEVENTEEN WITH A MINUTES
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE SYSTEM
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR PURPOSES
OF AMENDMENTS THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THESE CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS. SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL IN
FAVOR SAY AYE. ALL OF HIS SAY
NO. MAN MENTORED OPTED OUT TO
PRINT IMPACT ON FILE MEMBERS WE
WILL BE TAKING UP A SERIES OF
AMENDMENTS RIGHT NOW SO WE WILL
BE MOVING. IN FILE ORDER TO
FILE ITEM. TO NINETY SIX. AB
TWENTY SIX THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY SIX WITH A
MEMBERS BY SUMMER HOLDEN.
TWENTY SIX MISTER HOPE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR PURPOSES OF
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS THESE ARE
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
REQUESTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL STATING THAT
THEY ARE NOT REQUIRED TO
PURCHASE BODY CAMERAS FOR THE
PURPOSES OF ESTABLISHING. THAT
THEY HAVE INTERVENE. THE OTHER
AMENDMENT CLARIFIES THAT
OFFICERS REQUIRED TO INTERCEDE
WHEN PRESIDENT OBSERVING
ANOTHER OFFICER SING FORCE
THAT IS CLEARLY BEYOND THAT
WHICH IS NECESSARY TAKING INTO
ACCOUNT THE POSSIBILITY THAT
OTHER OFFICES MAY HAVE
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
REGARDING THE THREAT. POSED BY
A SUBJECT THESE MEMBERS ABROAD
CHT PORAC AND SEVERAL SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATIONS TO NEUTRAL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MR HOLDEN SEEN HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS THAT OBJECTION WILL
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
ALL OPPOSE SAY NO THE AYES HAVE
AT THE AMENDMENTS ADOPTED OUT
TO PRINT IN BACK ON FILE.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM A THREE
THIRTY FOUR AB FIVE TWELVE FOR
PURPOSES AMENDMENTS THE CLERK
WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
TWELVE WITH LIMITS MY SUMMER
HOLDEN. MR HOLDING YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED AGAIN. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER I TAKE THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT
THESE AMENDMENTS THEY CLARIFIED
THAT IS INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO PROMOTE THE USE
OFSKILLED AND TRAINED LABOR
INSTEAD OF REQUIRE IT. I ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU MR
HOLDEN SEEING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THESE AMENDMENTS WITHOUT
INJECTION WILL TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE AMENDMENTS ALL IN
FAVOR SAY AYE. ALL OPPOSED SAY
NO. THE AYES HAVE AT THE MOMENT
THIRD OPTED OUT TO PRINT AND
BACK ON FILE. MOVING TO FILE
ITEM THREE SEVENTY FOUR FOR
PURPOSES OF AMENDMENTS. AB NINE
FORTY EIGHT THE CORPORATION
SOME OF THE- NINE FORTY EIGHT
WITH A MINUTES BY SOME REMEMBER
HOLDEN MR HOLDING YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS THESE ARE
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
REQUESTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
BANKERS ASSOCIATION. THE
AMENDMENTS ARE WIDELY USED
INDUSTRY TERMS THAT ALIGN WITH
STATE AND FEDERAL TERMS USED IN
LENDING PRACTICES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MR HOLDEN SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THESE AMENDMENTS WITHOUT
OBJECTION WILL TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE AMENDMENTS ALL IN
FAVOR SAY AYE. ALL OPPOSED SAY
NO. THE AYES HAVE IT THE
AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED OUT TO
PRINT AND BACK ON FILE. FILE
ITEM THREE SEVENTY FIVE FOR
PURPOSES OF AMENDMENT AB NINE
FIFTY THE CLERK WILL READ. SOME
PEOPLE NINE FIFTY WITH A
MINUTES BY SOME REMEMBER WARD.
MISTER WARD YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR PURPOSES OF AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER THE
MEMBERS OF THE DESPERATE TO
DRAFTING AREAS FOR EITHER THE
BILL BE PUT OUT TO PRINT THESE
BACK ON FILE. THANK YOU MR
WARDEN SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS THAT OBJECTION WILL
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENTS ALL IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
ALL OF SAY NO THE AYES HAVE IT
THE AMENDMENTS ADOPTED OUT TO
BRING HIM BACK ON FILE. IN THE
LAST SET OF AMENDMENTS FILE
ITEM FOR TWENTY TWO. SB FIFTY
ONE FOR PURPOSES AMENDMENTS THE
KERKORIAN. SENATE BILL FIFTY
ONE WITH THE MINUTES BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO IF YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED UNEVENNESS THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
PROUD TO PRESENT AMENDMENTS TO
SB FIFTY ONE MODIFY THE DATE OF
EMERGENCY REGULATION CALTRANS
WOULD BE REQUIRED TO FILE
EMERGENCY REGULATIONS WITH THE
OFFICE OF ADMINISTRATIVE LAW NO
LATER THAN SIX MONTHS AFTER SB
FIFTY WANT TO SIGN INTO LAW IT
ADDS HOMEOWNERSHIP TO THE FIVE
FIFTY FIVE YEAR AFFORDABILITY
COVENANT PROVISIONS. AND
INCLUDE THE SKILLED AND TRAINED
A PREVAILING WAGE REQUIREMENT
ON HOUSING UNITS OF TEN OR MORE
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT THE
AMENDMENTS TO BE ADOPTED THE
BILL BE SENT OUT TO PARENTS AND
PLACED BACK ON THE FILE THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISS CARILLO
SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THESE AMENDMENTS
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE
A VOICE VOTE. ON THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
ALL OPPOSING. THE AYES HAVE IT
THE AMENDMENTS ADOPTED OUT TO
PRINT AND BACK ON FILE. MEMBERS
WE'RE GONNA MOVE BACK UP IN
FILE ORDERED TO TAKE A MISTER
TEAMS BILLS. FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY FOUR SEVENTY
EIGHT THE CLERK WILL READ. SOME
PEOPLE FOR SEVENTY EIGHT BY
SOME WE WERE PUTTING ANOTHER
SNACK LAYING SOLID PLEASE
THIRTEEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB FOR
SEVENTY TO SALVAGE THE TIMELINE
FOR THE REFORM THROUGH
CONTAINER MANUFACTURERS. THE
REFORMS ARE MANY OF THE CLAM
SHELLS OR TAKE OUT CONTAINERS
THAT WE GET ARE QUITE OFTEN WE
GO TO RESTAURANTS ESPECIALLY
DURING THIS PANDEMIC. AND WE
WANT TO USE A MINIMUM RECYCLED
CONTENT IN THE PLASTIC
CONTAINER STARTED WITH 10% AND
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. 20% TWENTY
TWENTY SEVEN AND 30% BY TWENTY
THIRTY APPROXIMATELY TWO
HUNDRED MILLION POUNDS OF
THERMOFORM WASTED DISCARDED
EACH YEAR IN CALIFORNIA IF YOU
COULD IMAGINE TWO HUNDRED.
MILLION POUNDS WHILE MANY OF US
THINK BY PUTTING THESE ARE BLUE
BINS OR RECYCLING BINS THAT YOU
GET RECYCLED MOST OF THESE CLAM
SHELLS MOST OF THESE FOOD
CONTAINERS ACTUALLY END UP IN
OUR LANDFILLS. LAST YEAR MYSELF
AND MY JOINT AUTHORS FROM
THOUSAND OAKS WE PASSED SB
SEVEN NINETY THREE TO SET A
MINIMUM RECYCLED CONTENT
STANDARD FOR PLASTIC BEVERAGE
BOTTLES. AT 50% THE HIGHEST
PERCENTAGE IN THE ENTIRE WORLD
VERY PROUD TO BUILD ON THAT TO
HAVE A MINIMUM RECYCLED CONTENT
FOR REFORMS WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE ON
THE BEFORE SEVENTY EIGHT. THANK
YOU MR KING MR WHEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I RISE AS A JOINT AUTHOR OF AB
FOUR SEVEN EIGHT MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN FRANCISCO AND I WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO ADDRESS SUPPLY
ISSUES TO HELP ASSIST THE
INDUSTRY TRANSITION. TO RECYCLE
THERMOFORM. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR DR OF. THANK YOU MISTER
WHEN SEEING AND HEARING FURTHER
ON THE- MISTER KING YOU LIKE TO
PLAY. WELL THE ROLE. MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED VERY VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THIRTY THIRD OF THE-
CLERKENWELL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALITA HIGHS FORTY THREE KNOWS
TO THAT MEASURE PASSES MOVING
TO FILE ITEM. ONE FORTY THREE.
AB FIVE SIXTY ONE THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
SIXTY ONE BY SOME INTERPRETING
AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE IN
HOUSING. THIRTEEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED AGAIN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SB FIVE SIXTY ONE
AUTHORIZES THE TREASURER'S
OFFICES ON EDIE YOU FINANCING
PROGRAM THAT THE POTENTIAL.
DEGREE FIFTY THOUSAND
ADDITIONAL HOMES OVER FIVE
YEARS BY PROVIDING BRIDGE
LOANS. TO HOMEOWNERS THAT DON'T
QUALIFY FOR TRADITIONAL
FINANCING. I KNOW THAT MANY
FOLKS HAVE APPROACHED ME ABOUT
HOW TO GET THERE AT YOU BUILT
THIS STRUGGLE WITH GETTING.
FINANCING AND WE BELIEVE THAT
AS A STATE WE NEED TO STEP IN
TO REALLY HELP PROVIDE THE
SECURITY AND THOSE BRIDGE
LOANS. THE THOUSANDS OF
HOMEOWNERS WHO REALLY WANT TO
THE NEXT STEP TO BUILD EIGHTY
YEARS. WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE ON A. B. FIVE
SIXTY ONE THANK YOU MR TANG
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. BOTH OF
THOSE. ALL MEMBERS BOTH WHO
DESERTED VOTES. ALL MEMBERS
RESERVE A. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY THE ICE FIFTY
KNOWS FIVE AMATEUR PASSES.
MITHRAS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER THERE
IS A LIST OF SIX ADDITIONAL
BILLS ON THIRD READING TODAY
THAT HAVE BEEN THAT HAVE THE
SUPPORT OF BOTH CAUCUSES AND
WE'VE AGREED TO TAKE THEM UP IN
ONE BATCH AND THEN APPLY THE
FIRST ROLL CALL VOTE TO THESE
BILLS I WOULD ASK THE CLERK TO
READ THE BILLS ON THIS BATCH
LIST AND THEN OPEN THE ROLE ON
THE FIRST BILL. MEMBERS PLEASE
PAY CLOSE ATTENTION AS THE
CLERK READ THE LIST OF BILLS
HAVE BEEN APPROVED TO BE PASSED
AS A BATCH. AGAIN THESE BILLS
HAVE THE SUPPORT OF BOTH
CAUCUSES. YOU WILL NOT NEED TO
PRESENT ON THESE ITEMS THE
CLERK WILL READ. ON A NINETY
THREE ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
TWELVE SAY ARTURO I'M THREE
FORTY EIGHT A SINGLE SIX SIX
SIX JUNE. I DON'T THINK ANYONE
IS INTEGRAL EVAN LOW THREE DALY
AND ITEM THREE OH EIGHT
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE FOURTEEN
MAIENSCHEIN. WITHOUT OBJECTION
THE THIRD WHEN I READ THE FIRST
BILL AND WE WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
SOME OF THE- NINETY THREE BY
SOME MEMBERS SAY ARTO.
INOCULATING TEACHER
CREDENTIALING CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHERE TO VOTE. HOME MEMBERS
VOTED OUT OF THE. WORK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TELEVOTE I
SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES THE CLERK WILL NOW READ-THE REMAINING ITEMS SOME OF
THOSE SIX SIX SIX FIVE SIXTY
FIVE NO ZERO SUM OF ELEVEN OH
THREE FIVE SIX TWO FIVE NINE
ZERO IN THE SUMMER ONE FORTY.
FIVE FIFTY FIVE NO ZERO. THIS
RACE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. I
MOVED TO SUSPEND JOINT RULE
SIXTY TWO AA THE FINAL NOTICE
REQUIREMENT TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE TO MEET TODAY
UPON ADJOURNMENT OF SESSION IN
ROOM FOUR TWO OH TWO TO HEAR AB
ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE CRISTINA
GARCIA. YOU CAN. PRIOR TO
TAKING UP THE MOTION PURSUANT
TO ASSEMBLY RULE SEVENTY SEVEN
POINT TWO I'M REFERRING THE
FOLLOWING BILLS TO COMMITTEE AB
ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE GARCIA THE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE ANTI
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE AND SB
FIFTY ONE TO THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE AND DEVELOPING
COMMITTEE NOW ON MISS RACES
MOTION MISTER FLORA FOR WHAT
PURPOSE REST. WE WITHHOLD IN
ASKING SENT US ROLL CALL VOTE.
MISS RASK. MR GABRIEL SECONDS
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE THIS IS A PROCEDURAL
VOTE MISS REYES IS ASKING FOR
AN AYE VOTE AND MR FLOOR IS
ASKING FOR A NO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTER TO VOTE.
WHERE TWELVE CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THAT ICE FORTY SEVEN NEWS
EIGHTEEN ON THE MOTION THE
MOTION PASSES.
YES YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE FIFTY SIX TO ALLOW OTHER
PREPARATIONS COMMITTEE TO SEPT
ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE CRISTINA
GARCIA FOR HEARING ON TUESDAY
JUNE FIRST. PENDING RECEIPT
FROM THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER. WE
HAVE DISPENSED WITH FILE ITEMS
ONE SIXTY EIGHT AND ONE SIXTY
NINE. MOVING THE FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTY AB SEVEN FIFTY THE
CLERK WILL READ SOME MIDDLE
SEVEN FIFTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JONES SAWYER AND ACTIVATING THE
CRIMES. MISTER JOHN HOW ARE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE TO PRESENT
EIGHTY SEVEN. FIVE ZERO CLEAN
UP BILL TO CLOSE THE LOOPHOLE
REGARDING FILING FALSE POLICE
OFFICER REPORTS BY CLOSING THIS
IS EXISTING STATUTORY
OVERSIGHT. AB SEVEN. FIVE ZERO
INSURERS OFFICER ACCOUNTABILITY
FOR FALSE STATEMENTS OF POLICE
OFFICER REPORTS FOR THESE FOR
THOSE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MISTER JONES SAWYER SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS GO
TO THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THIRTY THIRD OF BOTH
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TELLING VOTE I SIXTY TWO
KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
WILL PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE
ITEMS ONE SEVENTY ONE FOR ONE
SEVENTY THREE MOVING A FILE
ITEM ONE SEVENTY. FOR THE CLERK
WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN
SEVENTY EIGHT BY SOME MEMBERS
WATER GARCIA AND OTHERS AN ACT
LEADING TO AGRICULTURE FOOD
PRODUCS. MR GARCIA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES AB SEVEN
SEVEN EIGHT IS A BIPARTISAN
BILL THAT WOULD DIRECT. OUR
STATE INSTITUTIONS AND SCHOOLS
TO PURCHASE CALIFORNIA GROWN
FOOD. WHEN AVAILABLE AND WE'RE
NOT. THEY WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
GIVE PREFERENCE TO US GROW FOOD
OVER FOREIGN. AGRICULTURAL
MARKETS I WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIR OF AG. OF OUR AGRICULTURE
COMMITTEE AND THE CHAIR OF THE
CAL BILLION MINISTER TO REVIEW.
COMMITTEE FOR ASSISTING US IN
SHAPING THE POLICY THAT'S
BEFORE YOU. TODAY IN CLOSING.
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY BENEFITS
WHEN STATE INSTITUTIONS DIRECT
PURCHASING POWER TORQUE
CALIFORNIA GROWN PRODUCTS. AND
FARMERS AND FARM WORKERS
REINVEST THEIR MONEY. IN THE
AGRICULTURAL IN THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY AND OUR LOCAL
ECONOMIES. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR RIVAL. THANK YOU MR GARCIA
SEEING AND HEARING. MISTER
MATHIS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AT AS THE
VICE CHAIRMAN OF THE
AGRICULTURAL COMMITTEE. I TO
STAND IN SUPPORT. OF THIS GREAT
PIECE OF LEGISLATION MEMBERS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE NEED TAKE
GREAT. PRIDE IN THE PRODUCT
THAT WE PRODUCE. THE FACT WE
HAVE THE HIGHEST AND MOST
STRICTEST ENVIRONMENTAL
CONTROLS ON THE PLANET. GOES TO
SEE A LOT AND WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT OUR PRODUCTS ARE SEEN
HERE IN OUR BEING USED HERE AND
ARE COMING BACK INTO OUR
ECONOMY. AS WE KNOW EVERY
DOLLAR SPENT THE LOCAL ECONOMY
GETS SPREAD FOR FULL AS IT
MOVES ALONG MEMBERS ASHFORD AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER MATHIS SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
CALL MEMBERS VOTER TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE.
OKAY A LOT OF OUR MEMBERS VOTED
OUT OF AT THE CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE AND TALLY THE I. SIXTY
FOUR NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
WE HAVE DISPENSED WITH FILE
ITEM ONE SEVENTY FIVE AND ONE
SEVENTY SIX MOVING TO FILE ITEM
ONE SEVENTY SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN
NINETY SIX THE CORPORATE SYMBOL
SEVEN NINETY SIX BY SUMER
BERMAN AND OTHERS ENACTED IN
THE VOTER VOTER REGISTRATION.
BERMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I WAS JUST
CONFERRING WITH. THE WISE ONE
FROM SAN DIEGO. AB SEVENTY SIX.
SIX TO IMPROVE AND REFINE THE
CALIFORNIA NEW MOTOR VOTER
PROGRAM TO ENSURE ITS CONTINUED
SUCCESS AND EFFECTIVENESS
BETWEEN APRIL TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN IN JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE MORE THAN TWELVE
MILLION NEW OR UPDATED VOTER
REGISTRATIONS RESULTED FROM NEW
MOTOR VOTER. DESPITE THE
SUCCESSES CHALLENGES WITH
MODERNIZING THE MOTOR VOTER
REGISTRATION PROCESS CONTINUE
TO LIMIT THE PROGRAM'S
EFFECTIVENESS. SB SEVEN NINETY
SIX WOULD APPLY LESSONS LEARNED
AN ADOPTED FEDERAL MOTOR VOTER
TIMELINE FOR TIME THE
TRANSMITTAL OF VOTER
REGISTRATION INFORMATION FROM
THE DMV TO THE SECRETARY OF
STATE AS WELL AS QUALIFYING
NUMBER OF BEST PRACTICES FROM
AN ONGOING LEGAL SETTLEMENT.
INCLUDING DATA REPORTING STAFF
TRAINING AND MAINTAINING
COMPLIANCE COORDINATORS AT THE
DMV AND SECRETARY OF STATE. SB
SEVEN NINETY SIX WILL ENSURE
THAT THE PROGRAM IS AVAILABLE
TO ASSIST THE MORE THAN THREE
MILLION ELIGIBLE BUT
UNREGISTERED CALIFORNIANS TO
REGISTER TO VOTE THANK YOU
CALIFORNIA'S VOTER ROLLS
ACCURATE UP TO DATE I THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO. FOR
DOING THE HEAVY LIFTING ON THIS
A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MR BERMAN.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED VERY VOTE.
BURKE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TALLY THOSE EYES FORTY EIGHT
KNOWS FOURTEEN THAT MEASURE
PASSES WILL PASS AND WE
DISPENSED WITH FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTY EIGHT WILL PASS AND
RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS ONE
SEVENTY NINE TO ONE EIGHTY
MOVING A FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY
ONE EIGHTY EIGHT SIXTEEN THE
CLERK WILL READ SOME PEOPLE
EACH SIXTEEN BY SOME MEMBER
CHIU AND OTHERS IN EQUITY IN
THE HOME SINCE IF YOU'RE SURE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES WE'RE ALL TOO
FAMILIAR WITH HOMELESSNESS ON
OUR STREETS OVER A HUNDRED
SIXTY THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS
EVERY NIGHT THE NUMBER ONE
ISSUE FOR CONSTITUENTS WHO BEEN
ON SATISFIED WITH THE RESPONSE
OF GOVERNMENT THUS FAR. ARE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED A RECORD
TWELVE BILLION DOLLARS IN THE
MAY REVISE THAT WE SPEND IN
THIS AREA AND ARE LEGISLATURE
IDEAS I BELIEVE WILL AT LEAST
MATCH THAT IF NOT REYES THAT
WHATEVER WEEK RETURN THE BUDGET
WE NEED REAL ACCOUNTABILITY AND
A CLEAR STRATEGY TO ENSURE
THESE INVESTMENTS WORK. AS OUR
GOVERNOR HAS SAID THIS IS A
ONCE IN A LIFETIME INVESTMENT
BUT O MAKE IT COUNT WE HAVE TO
BE STRATEGIC AT THIS TIME STATE
AGENCIES AND MANY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HAVE LACKED
COORDINATION TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY IN THIS AREA AS
WELL AS COMPREHENSIVE DATA
DRIVEN APPROACHES. THIS BILL
WOULD HOLD STATE AGENCIES AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ACCOUNTABLE
FOR PROGRESS BY REQUIRING
CITIES AND COUNTIES AND STATE
AGENCIES TO COMPLETE CAPS IN%
NEEDS ANALYSIS TO DETERMINE THE
RESOURCES NEEDED TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS BASED ON THESE
ANALYSES STATE AGENCIES AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO CREATE ACTUAL PLANS
TO REDUCE HOMELESSNESS BY 90%
BY THE BEGINNING OF TWENTY
THIRTY. AND THE BILL WOULD ALSO
ESTABLISH A HOMELESSNESS
INSPECTOR GENERAL THAT COULD
HOLD STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ACCOUNTABLE FOR
FAILING TO SUBMIT PLANS ARE NOT
FOLLOWING PLANS BY ENSURING
ACCOUNTABILITY BASED ON
BENCHMARKS THIS BILL WOULD MOVE
CALIFORNIA TOWARD HOPEFULLY
FINALLY ADDRESSING THE MORE
CRISIS OF OUR DAY. AND WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR OUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MISTER TO
MISS WORK SILVA YOU ARE. IN THE
READY TO. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER. COLLEAGUES I
RELICENSED SUPPORT OF AB. EIGHT
SIXTEEN AS MANY OF YOU KNOW.
THIS BODY HAS VOTED ON MANY
MANY HOUSING POLICIES AND YET.
WE ARE STILL. STEPS AWAY FIRST
SOLVING THE CRISIS THAT WE SEE
RIGHT OUTSIDE THESE DOORS.
PEOPLE LINE AND ALLEYS. PEOPLE
ON THE STREETS. THAT ARE HUNGRY
THAT ARE DIRTY AND NEED OF
HEALTH CARE AND SHELTER. WE
DEBATE MANY MANY TIMES ABOUT
ISSUES OF IMPORTANCE BUT
THERE'S ONLY ONE ISSUE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT THIS
BODY AGREES ON ACCORDING TO
RECENT POLLS. FROM REPUBLICANS
TO DEMOCRATS TWO INDEPENDENTS
THAT WE MUST. ADDRESS OUR
HOMELESS CRISIS AND WE MUST DO
A BETTER JOB RELATED TO
ACCOUNTABILITY RELATED TO DATA
AND RELATED TO THE INVESTMENT
TO ADDRESS THIS CRISIS IT IS A
MORAL CRISIS TO WALK OUT OF
THESE CHAMBERS WALK RIGHT DOWN
A FEW BLOCKS FROM HERE OR EVEN
ACROSS THE N. STREET HERE IN
THIS GREAT STATE. AND SEE
PEOPLE. EITHER COLD OR HUNGRY
OR DYING ON OUR STREETS IT'S
NOT ACCEPTABLE. AND WE NEED TO
DO MORE AND I STRONGLY URGE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR AB. EIGHT
EIGHT SIXTEEN. THANK YOU MISS
KIRK SILVA. MR SANTIAGO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER. AND I DON'T WANT TO
REPEAT WHAT HAS BEEN SAID BUT I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
STRESS THE ACCOUNTABILITY THAT
WE NEED ONE MORE DRESS IN THE
ISSUE OF HOMELESSNESS. NOW IN
THE STATE WE HAD A LONG
CONVERSATION SPENT MANY OF
DOLLARS DATING BACK FROM NO
PLACE LIKE HOME HE HAPPENED
WE'RE NOW HAVING A CONVERSATION
ABOUT SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS OF
DOLLARS. AND THAT WILL BE SPENT
ON BEHALF OF THE STATE. SO WE
CANNOT EMPHASIZE ENOUGH. THE
ABSOLUTE NECESSITY PART IRON
CLAD ACCOUNTABILITY. SO THAT WE
BEGIN TO ATTACK TO TACKLE THE
ISSUE OF HOMELESSNESS. BECAUSE
WHAT'S AT STAKE. IS IT IS THE
AMOUNT OF PEOPLE THAT DIE ON
THE STREET EVERY SINGLE DAY. SO
AT SOME POINT TIME NOT JUST A
QUESTION OF MONEY. AND WE
CANNOT CONTINUE TO DO THE SAME
THING OVER AND OVER AND
EXPECTING DIFFERENT RESULTS WE
HAVE GOT TO LAY DOWN IRONCLAD
ACCOUNTABILITY SO THAT WE BEGIN
TO ADDRESS. A POPULATION THAT
HAS BEEN LONG WAITING AND IS
SUFFERING GREATLY ON THE
STREETS. OUR ON HOUSE COMMUNITY
DESERVES BETTER THAN THAT AND
FOR THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK AND
I'VE- THANK YOU MR SANTIAGO
MISTER WHAT DOCTOR WOULD YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I RISE TO MISTER SPEAKER
AMANDA SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL BUT I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO. ADD THAT. A
LOT OF THE- A LOT OF WHAT WE
SEE OUT THE SIDE THESE DOORS.
HAS THE LOOK OF MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES HAS THE APPEARANCE OF
SUBSTANCE ABUSE ISSUES AS WELL.
AND AS YOU TALK ABOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY. MY HOPE IS THAT
THAT WE ARE LOOKING AT THOSE
THOSE ISSUES HOLISTICALLY AS
WELL. JUST PUTTING PEOPLE IN
HOUSING DOESN'T NECESSARILY
SOLVE THEIR PROBLEMS FOR THEM
WITH OUT THESE WRAPAROUND
SERVICES. SO IN ADDITION THE
ACCOUNTABILITY YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT COORDINATION I FEEL LIKE
WE NEED. AN AIR TRAFFIC
CONTROLLER TO. MANAGE ALL OF
THIS AND RIGHT NOW- I DON'T SEE
IT AND I HOPE I HOPE THAT COMES
TO BE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
DOCTOR WOULD. SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER MR CHIU WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU LET ME
JUST THANK OUR COLLEAGUES HAVE
JUST SPOKEN- WE OFTEN
IDENTIFIER COLLEAGUES FROM
WHERE THEY REPRESENTS BUT OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM ORANGE COUNTY
SHE KNOWS. THE HOMELESSNESS
THAT WE SEE ON RIVER
ENCAMPMENTS IN HER COUNTY OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM LA HE REPRESENTS
SKID ROW WHICH HAS SEEN A
RECORD LEVEL OF JUST
HEARTBREAKING TRAGEDIES OUR
COLLEAGUE REPRESENTING OUR
NORTH COAST KNOWS THAT WE SEE
HOMELESSNESS NOT JUST IN URBAN
AREAS BUT IN RURAL AREAS AND I
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE MANY
CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD IN THIS
AREA. I DO WANT TO DRESS ARE
CALLING FROM HILLS FOR AGAIN
LET YOU KNOW THAT WHAT YOU'VE
LAID OUT IS EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO GRAPPLE WITH IN THIS
BILL AND BY THAT I MEAN WE KNOW
THAT HOMELESSNESS IS
COMPLICATED THERE ARE MANY MANY
CAUSES FOR THEIR MANY MANY
SOLUTIONS WHAT THIS BILL DOES
IS IT SAYS THE CITIES AND
COUNTIES YOU HAVE TO DO AN
ASSESSMENT. OF WHO'S HOMELESS
IN YOUR COMMUNITY WHY ARE THEY
HOMELESS AND WHAT ARE YOU GONNA
DO GIVE US A CONCRETE PLAN OVER
THE NEXT DECADE TO REDUCE SAID
IN AN EFFECTIVE WAY AND WHAT WE
SAY TO THEM IS NOT ONLY DO YOU
HAVE TO DO THIS ANALYSIS INTO
THIS PLAN BUT AS A STATE WE'RE
GONNA HOLD YOU ACCOUNTABLE TO
THAT AS WE GIVE YOU MONEY WE'RE
GOING TO WANT YOU TO TELL US
WHAT YOU'RE DOING IN THAT AREA.
WE GIVE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS THE
FREEDOM TO PROPOSE HOW THEY
WANT TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS IS
SEAT IN THEIR DISTRICTS AND
IN THEIR CITIES AND COUNTIES IN
CAN HYMNS OF CARE BUT
ULTIMATELY THIS BILLS ABOUT
HOLDING THEM ACCOUNTABLE FOR
ACHIEVING THOSE RESULTS AND MY
HOPE IS THAT THIS IS THE FIRST
OF A SIGNIFICANT CONVERSATION
AROUND ACCOUNTABILITY AS WE ARE
ABOUT TO VOTE IN THE NEXT MONTH
ON BILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT ARE
GOING TO GO. TO SUPPORT OUR
DISTRICTS WHEN IT COMES TO THE
MORE CRISIS OF THE DAY SO
WITHOUT REALLY RESPECT AND
APPRECIATE THE MANY
CONVERSATIONS WE'VE. HAD ABOUT
THIS AND ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
BURKE WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS THIRD OF A- ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRED VOTE. ALMER
SAID HE DESIRED TO VOTE. WHERE
WERE THE CLOTHES THE ROLE IN
TALENT ABOUT ICE FIFTY KNOWS
THIRTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE UP FILE ITEM
THREE NINETY EIGHT. AB ELEVEN
NINETY FIVE BY MS GARCIA THIS
IS FILE ITEM. THREE NINETY
EIGHT. A. B. ELEVEN NINETY
FIVE. AND THE CLERK OR-
SAMEGRELO NINETY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA
AND ACTIVATING THE WATER. MS
GARCIA YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS AB
ELEVEN NINETY FIVE CREATES A
REGIONAL WATER COMMISSIONER FOR
SOUTHEAST L. A. COUNTY WHICH
INSERTED MYSELF REPRESENTED BY
MYSELF IN THE SPEAKER WITHIN
THE STATE WATER BOARD TO
COLLABORATE WITH LOCAL WATER
SYSTEMS THE CREATING A PLAN FOR
SUSTAINABLE DRINKING WATER
SYSTEM IN OUR REGION. THE
COMMISSIONER WILL COLLABORATE
TO IMPLEMENT THE SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE FUNDING FOR EQUITY
AND RESILIENCE IN SOUTHERN L.
A. COUNTY WHICH IS CREATED IN
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN SS AND
PROVIDE ASSISTANCE TO SMALL
PUBLIC WATER SYSTEMS INCLUDING
AUTHORITY TO AUDIT SYSTEMS THAT
SEEKS THE FUNDING. IDENTIFY
PUBLIC WATER SYSTEMS THAT NEED
TO BE CONSOLIDATED WITH LARGER
SUCCESSFUL WATER SYSTEMS
REQUEST THE STATE WATER BOARD
TO DETERMINE WHETHER THIS IS
THE MEET THE REQUIREMENTS FOR
CONSOLIDATION. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MS GARCIA. MISTER SPEAKER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS. BUT MEMBERS
MEMBERS I RISE TO ASK YOUR
SUPPORT FOR A BI ELEVEN NINETY
FIVE I ALSO WANT TO THANK THE
MEMBERS FROM THE DISTRICT NEXT
DOOR TO MINE FOR WORKING TO
BRING THIS BILL BEFORE US A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF HARD WORK
ON HER PART SINCE I'VE BEEN IN
THE ASSEMBLY I'VE WORKED HARD
ON WATER QUALITY JUSTICE IT
BEGAN WHEN A RESIDENT OF MY
DISTRICT SHOWED ME THE BROWN
TAP WATER THAT WAS COMING OUT
OF. OUT OF THEIR SINK. FOR A
BECAME SPEAKER I TRAVEL THE
LENGTH OF CALIFORNIA TO
NEGOTIATE A WATER BOND THAT
WOULD AMONG OTHER THINGS.
IMPROVE WATER QUALITY
PARTICULARLY FOR SOME OF OUR
RURAL RESIDENTS. UNFORTUNATELY
THERE ARE DISADVANTAGED URBAN
AREAS THAT ALSO NEED OUR HELP.
THAT INCLUDES CITIES IN MY
DISTRICTS AND IN THE OFFICE
DISTRICT. THIS IS NOT SOMETHING
TO NECESSARILY BLAME ON LOCAL
WATER DISTRICTS THEY HAVE HAD
VERY FEW ACCESS TO REMEDIES.
WE'VE MADE SOME INCREMENTAL
PROGRESS IN MY DISTRICT WITH
TWO SMALL MUTUAL WATER
COMPANIES GETTING ACCESS TO
STATE UNDED TREATMENT PLANTS.
AB ELEVEN NINETY FIVE GOES
BEYOND INCREMENTAL PROGRESS IT
OFFERS A REGIONAL APPROACH A
COMPREHENSIVE AND SUSTAINABLE
DRINKING WATER PLAN TAPPEN AREA
THAT BADLY NEEDS IT. WE'VE
ALREADY TRIED TO REGIONAL
APPROACH APPROACH IN OTHER
PARTS OF CALIFORNIA NOW
SOUTHEAST LOS ANGELES NEEDS A
REGIONAL APPROACH AS WELL. THE
CONSUMERS NEED OUR HELP
CALIFORNIANS NEED OUR HELP THE
SMALL WATER SYSTEMS THEY ARE
HELP THIS IS A GOOD BILL I ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. ON AB ONE ONE
NINE NINE. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. THANK YOU SEEING NO
OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM IS
GARCIA MY CLOTHES IF YOU WISH
THANK YOU DOES WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE MISTER SPEAKER FOR
SPEAKING ON THIS REGIONALLY WE
ALWAYS SAY WE'RE CELIS STRONG
AND THIS BILL WILL ENSURE THAT
OUR DRINKING WATER IS SAFE AND
RELIABLE FOR A COMMUNITY WE
ACTUALLY LIVE UP TO THAT NAME A
CELL A STRONG. RESPECT MASTER
AND I VOTE. AND WITH THAT THE
CLERK LIBERAL. IS THAT A VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
ALL MEMBERS OF A- CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ZERO TITLE AS FIFTY NO
SIXTEEN. THAT MEASURE PASSES.
BACK A REGULAR FILE ORDER. THIS
IS. FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY TWO AB
EIGHT TWENTY FIVE EVENTUALLY BE
INCORPORATED ASSEMBLY BILL A
TWENTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LEVINE AN ACCURATE INFORMATION
PRIVACY MR LEVINE EMAIL OPEN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS EIGHTY NINE SIXTY
FIVE SEEKS TO EXPAND EVEY
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE IN
MULTI UNIT DWELLINGS BY GIVING
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT AND THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING STANDARDS
COMMISSION THE STATUTORY
AUTHORITY TO IMPLEMENT BUILDING
STANDARDS FOR EXISTING HOUSING.
AND NON RESIDENTIAL BUILDING
DEVELOPMENTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE. THANK YOU MR LEVINE.
SAY NO DISCUSSION OF AON THE
ITEM. CARPAL OF THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF A. CHECK
THE ROLE.
THERE IS A STRIKE THE
ROLE WE'RE GOING TO HEAR MR
LEVINE PERCENT A. B. H. TWENTY
FIVE. AB EIGHT TWENTY NINE WILL
BE FORTHCOMING IN A FEW ITEMS
THIS IS AB EIGHT TWENTY FIVE.
FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY TWO EIGHTY
EIGHT TWENTY FIVE CLARK HAS
ALREADY READ. MICHELLE LEVINE
YOU MAY PRESENT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER SPEAKER AND THANK
YOU MEMBERS FOR- SUFFERING
THROUGH THAT THAT MISS HEARING
OF THE NUMBER- AND I WILL TRY
TO BE AS BRIEF ON THIS ONE THIS
IS A FAR MORE TECHNICAL BILL.
MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB EIGHT
TWENTY FIVE WILL REQUIRE
CALIFORNIA'S BEEN NOTIFIED IF
THERE HAS BEEN A BREACH OF
THEIR PERSONAL GENETIC DATA BY
INCLUDING GENETIC DATA IN THE
DEFINITION OF PERSONAL
INFORMATION IN CALIFORNIA'S
DATA BREACH NOTIFICATION LAW
FOR BOTH BUSINESSES AND PUBLIC
AGENCIES GENETIC INFORMATION IS
OUR MOST. IMPORTANT OUR MOST
PERSONAL INFORMATION IT IS
INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT MAKES US
WHO WE ARE THIS SENSITIVE
INFORMATION IN THE WRONG HANDS
RISKS FAR MORE THAN IMPACTING
OUR CREDIT SCORE IT COULD
NEGATIVELY IMPACT OUR HEALTH
PRIVACY MAKE US SUSCEPTIBLE TO
GENETIC DISCRIMINATION SUBJECT
US TO. A NEW GENERATION OF
IDENTITY THEFT AT THE HANDS OF
GENETIC DATA THIEVES THE L. A.
TIMES REPORT IN TWENTY NINETEEN
THAT DNA TESTING SERVICE VITA
JEAN INK LEFT THOUSANDS OF
CLIENT GENETIC RECORDS EXPOSED
ONLINE FOR YEARS. AT THE TIME
OF THE ARTICLES RELEASED THE
COMPANY NOT NOTIFIED CLIENTS
ABOUT THE EXPOSURE OF THEIR
INFORMATION. ONE CUSTOMER SAID
SHE FIRST HEARD HER DNA WAS
LEFT UNSECURED WHEN BLOOMBERG
NEWS CONTACTED HER FOR THE
STORY. CALIFORNIA SHOULD NOT
FIND OUT THERE JANET DATA WAS
BREACHED FROM A REPORTER UNDER
THE LAW A COMPANY OR GOVERNMENT
AGENCY MUST DISCLOSE TO AN
INDIVIDUAL IF THEIR PERSONAL
INFORMATION OR PERSONALLY
IDENTIFYING INFORMATION IS BEEN
BREACHED JUST LIKE YOUR SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBER OR MEDICAL
INFORMATION. AB EIGHT TWENTY
FIVE INSURERS THAT COMPANIES
AND GOVERNMENT AGENCIES NOTIFY
CALIFORNIANS IF THERE IS A
BREACH OF THEIR MOST PERSONAL
INFORMATION THEIR GENETIC DATA.
I RESPECT ASTRONOMICAL. THANK
MUCH OF A- SHE NO DISCUSSION.
FOR DEBATE ON THE ITEM LEVEL OF
THE ROLE. IS THAT A VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESIGN OF A. THE
CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE I
SIXTY SIX NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES IN FILE ORDER THIS IS
FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY THREE AB
EIGHT TWENTY SIX. BY MISTER
BENNETT. COOKERY SOME AGO EIGHT
TWENTY SIX BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BENNETT AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE
IN THE COASTAL RESOURCES MISTER
BENNETT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
ARISES- IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT
TWENTY SIX AB EIGHT TWENTY SIX
PROMOTES THE STATE'S EFFORTS IN
BOTH RESILIENCE AND ADAPTION
PLANNING BY ESTABLISHING BEACON
AS A PROGRAM WITHIN THE STATE
COASTAL CONSERVANCY. AB EIGHT
TWENTY SIX IS A DISTRICT BILL
DESIGNED TO HELP THE RESIDENTS
OF SANTA BARBARA VENTURA COUNTY
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. FAMOUS BETTER SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON THE.
DESERVE IT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF ALL MEMBERS OF. DESERVE
A. CLICK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT I FIFTY FIVE KNOWS NINE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
ONE EIGHTY FOUR IS AB EIGHT
TWENTY NINE COVERAGE. ASSEMBLY
BILL A TWENTY NINE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEVINE AND OTHERS AND I
PUT INTO FOSTER CHILDREN. THE
SHOW RAINY MAY REMIND US ABOUT
THE V. TWENTY THAT. THIS IS
ACTUALLY A THIRD BILL THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB EIGHT
TWENTY NINE WILL IMPROVE
SERVICES TO UNDOCUMENTED FOSTER
YOUTH BY BETTER IDENTIFYING AND
STANDARDIZING ACCESS TO
IMMIGRATION LEGAL SERVICES. FOR
FOSTER YOUTH ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THE
RESERVATIONS. NOTE THIS
QUESTION OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. IS
OUT OF IT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. THE CLERK
WILL CLOSE ROLE TELEVOTERS
FIFTY NINE NO ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES. WE HAVE
DISPENSED FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY
FIVE THIS IS FILE ITEM. ONE
EIGHTY SIX AB EIGHT SEVENTY TWO
BY DOCTOR WOULD CORKERY.
ASSEMBLE EIGHT SEVENTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD AND AFTER
LEARNING TO WORKERS
COMPENSATION DOCTOR WHAT. THANK
YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB
EIGHT SEVENTY TWO WOULD
AUTHORIZE FIREFIGHTERS EMPLOYED
BY CALIFORNIA RECEIVE 1100% OF
THEIR WAGE IF THEY SHOULD
BECOME INJURED ON THE JOB. BUT
ONLY UP TO A YEAR THIS BILL
WOULD BE BRING CAL FIRE
FIREFIGHTERS UP TO PAR WITH
OTHER PUBLIC SAFETY EMPLOYEES
SUCH AS CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL FISHING GAME WARDENS AND
LIFEGUARDS THIS BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU DOCTOR
WOULD I SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ADAM CLARK
LIBERAL. MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
THAT A VOTE. WELL CLOSER ALL
TIED UP BUT I SEVENTY. NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS WE
ARE GOING TO WITHOUT OBJECTION
MOVE AHEAD IN THE FILE TO FILE
ITEM THREE FORTY THREE FORTY.
THIS SAYS AB FIVE NINETY TWO BY
MS FRIEDMAN. CORRECT ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE NINETY TWO BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN AND
ACTIVATING A FOSTER YOUTH
MISTREATMENT THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBER MEMBERS OF
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED WIDE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND HAS NO-OPPOSITION AB FIVE NINETY TWO
PROMOTES PLACEMENT STABILITY IN
A POSITIVE SUPPORTED TRANSITION
TO INDEPENDENCE AND
INDEPENDENCE FOR YOUTH
PARTICIPATING IN THE ASCENDED
FOSTER CARE PROGRAM. BY
RESTRUCTURING THE HOST FAMILIES
TRADITIONAL HOUSING MODEL TO
ALLOW FOR GREATER FLEXIBILITY
AND PROVIDING TARGETED SAFE
INAPPROPRIATE HOUSING AND
SUPPORT TO YOUNG ADULTS NEED
APPROPRIATE SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
WITH THAT ARE QUESTIONABLE
THANK YOU. THANKS FRIEDMAN
SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE
CORPORAL. THE DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VETERANS ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THE
DESERVE A. CLARK WELL. CLOSE
ROLL TIDE AT I. SIXTY NINE OH
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES BACK
IN REGULAR FILE ORDER. WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE A FILE ITEM ONE
NINETY. AB EIGHT NINETY EIGHT
BY MISTER LEE CORPORATION
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT NINETY
EIGHT BY SOMEONE OR REALLY AND
OTHER SNACK LEADING THE
CRIMINAL RECORDS MR LEE YOU MAY
HELP THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB EIGHT NINE EIGHT SIX
TO ENSURE THE PUBLICLY
ACCESSIBLE INFORMATION ABOUT A
PERSON'S CRIMINAL RECORD IS
ACCURATE WHEN PROBATION IS
TRANSFERRED. TO COURTS BECOME
INVOLVED IN A CASE OF SOMEONE
IS CONVICTED AND DIFFERENT-
SECTION THAT WHERE THEY LIVE IF
THE PERSON IS ON FORMAL
PROBATION THEN THE CASE IS
TRANSFERRED TO THE COUNTY WHERE
THEY RESIDE UNDER CURRENT LAW
THERE IS NO WAY TO ENSURE THAT
THE PERSON'S RECORDS WE OPTED
IN BOTH COURTS IF THE PERSON'S
CONVICTION IS SPONSORING JUST.
INACCURATE PUBLICLY ACCESSIBLE
INFORMATION ABOUT A CONVICTION
CAN LINGER ON A PERSON'S RECORD
AFTER CRIMINAL LEASES GRANTED
THIS MAKES IT DIFFICULT FOR
PEOPLE TO EMPLOYMENT OR HOUSING.
AB EIGHT NINE EIGHT ONE SURE.
EXPUNGEMENT REDUCTIONS OF
FELONIES ARE CORRECTLY
REPRESENTED ON A PERSON'S
RECORD RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK RITUALLY SAY NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLICK LIBERAL. ALL MEMBERS.
THE SENATE VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS THAT A VOTE. THE CLERK
WILL CLOTHES ARE ALL TIED UP I
SIXTY SIX NO ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEMS
ONE NINETY ONE. IN. ONE NINETY
TWO. WE ARE AT FILE IN A ONE
NINETY THREE. THIS IS AB NINE
TWENTY FIVE BY THIS DELI CLERK
WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
TWENTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEGAN DALLY ENACTED INTO LAW
ENFORCEMENT THIS DALY. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TO
PRESENT AB NINETY FIVE WHICH
HAS BEEN SELECTED BY THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS IS A
PRIORITY BILL. THIS BILL
PROVIDES GREATER REIMBURSEMENT
TO PROVIDERS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT
MEDICAL FORENSIC EXAMS.
CURRENTLY LIMITED ACCESS TO
THESE EXAMS BECAUSE THEY ARE
TIME CONSUMING COSTLY FOR
PROPRIETORS TO REFORM AND THERE
IS SEVERELY LIMITED
REIMBURSEMENT OPPORTUNITIES FOR
RE FULLY REIMBURSING THESE
EXAMPLE HELP EXPAND ACCESS BY
MAKE IT MORE AFFORDABLE FOR
CLINICS. TO PROVIDE THEM ACCESS
TO THE STATE RIGHT PROBLEM
PROBLEM ESPECIALLY IN RURAL
AREAS FOR EXAMPLE I'M IN MY
DISTRICT THERE'S ONE PROVIDER
FOR SEVEN COUNTIES. AS A RESULT
BECOMES ARE FORCED TO WAIT
SOMETIMES DAYS FOR AN AVAILABLE
EXAMS AB NINE TWENTY FIVE
PASSAGE OF ASSEMBLY I'M PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE ON CONSENT
ENJOYS NO OPPOSITION AND NO NO
VOTES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
RIGHT. THANK YOU MICHELLE I SEE
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. CLARK
WELL OVER THERE ALL ALL MEMBERS
OF THE CEREMONY. ALL MEMBERS
RUNS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS THAT A VOTE THE CLERK
WILL. CLOSER ALL TIED UP HI
SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES. PASSER KAMPALA
ONE NINETY FOUR THIS IS FILE
ONE NINETY FIVE AB NINE THIRTY
BY MR LEVINE COOKERY. ASSEMBLY
ROW NINE THIRTY BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEVINE AN ACCOLADE TO
ESCALATIONS THE SHELVING THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB NINE THIRTY
AUTHORIZES PREVAILING
EXCAVATORS THE AUTHORITY TO
RECOVER ATTORNEY FEES FOR
CLAIMS ARISING FROM DAMAGED
UNDERGROUND UTILITIES THE
MEASURE WILL FORCE UTILITY
COMPANIES TO INCREASE THE
ACCURACY OF THEIR PROGRAMS TO
LOCATE. AND MARK POTENTIALLY
DANGEROUS UNDERGROUND
INFRASTRUCTURE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR NAY VOTE THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MUCH OF A SEEING THEIR
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. THE CLUB
WORLD. ESERVER ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THE. ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS OUT OF A. WELL ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS AT ABOUT.
FRAZIER. MR LEVINE CLOSE ROLL
TIDE ABOUT EYES FORTY ONE NO.
SEVENTEEN THE MEASURE PASSES.
THIS IS FILE ITEM. ONE NINETY
SIX. WE'RE GOING TO PASS
TEMPORARILY. OUR FATHER. ONE
NINETY SIX. PASS RETAIN A FILE
ITEMS ONE NINETY SEVEN AND ONE
NINETY EIGHT WE'RE DISPENSER
FILE ITEMS ONE AND TWO HUNDRED.
PASS AND RETAIN. FILE ITEMS TO
A ONE THREE TWO OH FOUR. THIS
IS FILE ITEM TO A SIX A. B.
NINE NINE EIGHT BY MR LACKEY.
CORRECTION FILE ITEM TWO OH
FIVE FILE ITEM TWO OH FIVE AB
NINE NINE EIGHT. BY MR LACKEY
CORKERY. ASSUME AGO NINE NINETY
EIGHT BYE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LACKEY AND OTHERS AND ACCORDING
TO INCARCERATED PERSONS MR
LACKEY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB NINE NINE
EIGHT WILL ENSURE THE MENTAL
HEALTH RECORDS WERE TRANSFERRED
WITH THE INMATE OR FALL THE
INMATE TO STATE PRISONS WITHIN
A SHORT AMOUNT OF TIME TO THE
INMATES TRANSFER SO THAT OUR
STATE'S MENTAL HEALTH.
CLINICIANS HAVE ADEQUATE
HISTORY AVAILABLE TO THEM IT
HAS BIPARTISAN AUTHORSHIP AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER LUCKY. C.
NOTIFICATION OF A- CLICK
LIBERAL MEMBERS THERE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS REPRESENTABLE. ALL
MEMBERS OF. EVEN A SERVER. THE
CLERK WELL CLOSER TYLER I SIXTY
NINE ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES.
THIS IS FILE ITEM TWO OH SEVEN.
AB ONE THOUSAND NINE BY MISTER
BLOOM. CORRECT ASSEMBLY TWO
NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM
AND ACCORDING TO AGRICULTURE.
MR BELOW THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I'M PLEASED TO
PRESENT AB TEN OH NINE WHICH
ESTABLISHES THE FARM TO SCHOOL
FOOD HUB PROGRAM THE BILL AS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT HAS
NO NO VOTES AND NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU RICH BLOOM. SENIOR
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CARPOOL OF
MORAL. ESERVER ALL MEMBERS OF A
DESIRABLE. ALL MEMBERS OF. IT
IS OUT OF UP. OUR CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE. CALVET I SIXTY
SEVEN KNOWS ZERO. THAT MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE TO TAKE UP FILE ITEM TO
ELEVEN. THIS IS FILE ITEM. TWO
ELEVEN AB TEN THIRTY FIVE AM
MISTER SALAS CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY DALTON THIRTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS AND
OTHERS AND EVERYBODY WAS
TRANSPORTATION MR SALIHU
MEHLMAN. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL TEN
THIRTY FIVE- WHICH WILL HELP
THE STATE MEET ITS
ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS BY
REQUIRING LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
TO ADOPT THE SAME RECYCLED
MATERIAL STANDARDS AS CALTRANS
BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE TO THE
EXTENT FEASIBLE AND COST
EFFECTIVE. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A VOTE. THANK YOU FOR SALAS C.
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
CORPORAL. MEMBERS THE SENATE
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS WILL
DECIDE OF. THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I. SIXTY
FIVE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
GO BACK IN THE FILE AND PICK UP
MISTER COOLIES FILE ITEM ONE
NINETY SIX. THIS IS A B. NINE
THIRTY FOUR. CLERK WILL READ.
LEE AND ACTIVATING THE PUBLIC
BUILDINGS MR COOLEY. COLLEAGUES
I'M TO BRING AB NINE FOUR TO
YOU THIS BILL REFLECTS SORT OF
THE MODERN ERA IN WHICH WE FIND
OURSELVES IN THE YEARS SINCE
NINE ELEVEN THERE HAS BEEN A
GREAT DEAL OF THOUGHT GOING
INTO WHAT MAKES FOR SECURE
PUBLIC SPACES FEMA HAS DONE IT.
PARDEE HOMES IS ON AT THE BAR
OF STAY US OF STATE S. OFFENSE
THIS BILL RICK D. PROVIDED BY
MARK OF NEXT YEAR MISTER GIVES
A ON THESE LESS ABOUT SAFETY
SPACE. AND REPORT TO THE JOINT
COMMITTEE FOR SOME OF ISSUES WE
CURRENTLY OF IN INCLUDES TOPIC
AS HOW YOU SHOPPERS INTO A
PUBLIC PURPOSE. TO IN THE SAME
OF ALL USES I REQUEST AND I
WILL. THANKS MR KOHLI SEE NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. THE
GLOBAL. THAT A VOTE ON VOTERS
OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS OF DESIRE
TO THE. DOES ANY MEMBER WISH TO
REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. SEEING AND HEARING.
NINE MEMBERS BEFORE WE TAKE A
VOTE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE A
RESOLUTIONS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR TO ADD CO AUTHORS THIS
IS FOR THE PURPOSE OF ADDING CO
AUTHORS THE CLERK WILL READ THE
RESOLUTIONS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. HOUSE RESOLUTION
FORTY SIX BY. GABER RELATIVE TO
FOOD ALLERGY PREVENTION
AWARENESS DAY ALSO SOLUTION
FORTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY GABLE
RELATIVE TO ISRAELI AMERICANS
AND HOUSE RESOLUTION FORTY NINE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GAVE A
RELATIVE TO JEWISH AMERICAN
HERITAGE MONTH. MEMBERS WE ARE
NOT GOING OPEN THE ROLE TO
ALLOW ME. AUTHORS THE
RESOLUTION NOT CONSENT THIS IS
FOR CO AUTHORS MEMBERS. ALL
MEMBERS WHICH NOTICE CO AUTHOR
ON THE- RESOLUTIONS ON CONSENT.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS. CLARK
WELL. CLOSER ALL THEIR ARE
SEVENTY ALL ADDED. IN NOW WE
WILL TO A VOTE ON THE CAN CAL.
IS A MEMBER MOVING DATA FROM
CAN SINGER NINE. THE CLERK WILL
READ THE SECOND THEY CAN CHECK
OUT. ASSEMBLY WILL FORTY TWO BY
SOME MEMBER MAYES ACCORDING
SERVICE MY. KIRKWALL THE ROLE.
CALENDAR ALL VOTE WHO WE TO
VOTE THIS IS THE- I THANK. ALL
MY OF. WHICH TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS WOULD WISH TO VOTE THIS
IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR THE
CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIED UP
BUT I SIXTY EIGHT. NO. ZERO THE
CLERK WILL READ REMAIN ITEMS I
CAN. ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY SO I
SIXTY EIGHT NOTES HERE SUM BILL
FIVE SEVENTY ONE HI KNOWS SOME
PEOPLE SAY FIFTY HIGHS SIXTY
EIGHT ZERO SUM WE WILL EAT
FIFTY I. SIXTY EIGHT ZERO SOME
PEOPLE TEN THIRTY I SIXTY NO
ZERO SOME OF THE SIX FOUR HIS
EIGHT KNOWS SUM ELEVEN. HIS
EIGHT KNOWS SUM WE WILL SEVENTY
I SIXTY ZERO SUM ELEVEN I SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO PEOPLE THIRTY. I
SIX EIGHT NO ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL
TWELVE SOME FIVE AS KNOWS SUM
BILL TOOL SEVENTY NINE I SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO WILL SICK TWO HIS
EIGHT ZERO SUM WE WILL TO EIGHT
I SIXTY KNOWS SUM FOURTEEN
SEVENTY SO I EIGHT NO ZERO
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTY EIGHTY SIX
FIVE EIGHT NO ZERO SOME PEOPLE
FIFTEEN SEVEN I. EIGHT NOW ZERO
APPROVED EIGHTY I SIXTY EIGHT
ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN
EIGHTY NINE I SIXTY EIGHT NO
ZERO HOUSE FORTY SIX I'VE EIGHT
NO ZERO HOUSES. FORTY EIGHT
FIVE EIGHT NO ZERO IN
RESOLUTION FORTY NINE I EIGHT
NO ZERO ENNIS PEOPLE FOR SIXTY
ONE I. SIXTY AND I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK THE FLORENTINE FROM
BOTH. FROM BOTH CAUCUSES FOR
THEIR HARD WORK IN MAKING SURE
WE KEPT ON IN TIME. AND THE I
WANT TO THANK THEM ALL THANK
YOU. A CORRECTION ON CONSENT
CALENDAR QUICKLY. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWELVE TWENTY ONE. I SIXTY
EIGHT NO. ZERO MEMBERS WITHOUT
OBJECTION. THE QUORUM CALL IS
LIFTED WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
PREVIOUS IN HOUSE ADJOURNMENTS
IN MEMORY MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
WE WILL BE VERY CHANGES UPON A
GERMAN WE DO HAVE A GERMAN IN
MEMORY AT THIS TIME. PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR.
THERE IS WHERE THE GERMANS IN
MEMORY PLEASE TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBER WAS
GRANTED PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON
A GERMAN IN MEMORY. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CUNNINGHAM YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN IN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TO
JOURNAL MEMORY OF DETECTIVE
LUCA BENEDETTI WHO IS A POLICE
OFFICER THE SLOW SENATE SPECIAL
POLICE DEPARTMENT SINCE TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE. BEFORE THAT
WITH THE TASKER OF POLICE
DEPARTMENT SINCE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT AND A MEMBER OF THE SAN
LUIS OBISPO REGIONAL SWAT TEAM.
HE WAS TRAGICALLY KILLED IN
SERVICE ON MAY TENTH TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE. WHILE
SERVING A SEARCH WARRANT. LUKE
WAS BORN SAN FRANCISCO IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR TO ITALIAN
IMMIGRANT PARENTS HE WAS RAISED
TO CLOSE THEIR TELLING FAMILY
WHERE YOU LEARN THE IMPORTANCE
OF HARD WORK AND INTEGRITY HE
TOOK GREAT PRIDE AS ITALIAN
HERITAGE AND I EVEN LEARNED HIS
FUNERAL SERVICE THEY HAD A-
TATTOO IN THE SHAPE OF THE
COUNTRY OF ITALY AND WORE A